programming throwdown episode 86 wolfram language with steven wolfram take it away jason hey everyone happy new year welcome back and we are starting the year off with an amazing interview. You know, very rarely do we get the opportunity to interview someone who actually invented a language. Every show we always talk about a language. And here we have Stephen Wolfram on the show. And Stephen, why don't you kind of describe yourself and Wolfram research and kind of walk us through your journey? Oh boy. Okay. This is a describe yourself in a few words. I remember I could tell you some interesting stories about times when people have said that to me, but
programming throwdown episode 86 wolfram language with steven wolfram take it away jason hey everyone happy new year welcome back and we are starting the year off with an amazing interview. You know, very rarely do we get the opportunity to interview someone who actually invented a language. Every show we always talk about a language. And here we have Stephen Wolfram on the show. And Stephen, why don't you kind of describe yourself and Wolfram research and kind of walk us through your journey? Oh boy. Okay. This is a describe yourself in a few words. I remember I could tell you some interesting stories about times when people have said that to me, but|||programming throwdown 第 86 期，本期嘉宾是斯蒂芬·沃尔夫曼（Steven Wolfram），聊聊 Wolfram 语言。杰森，交给你啦。大家好，新年快乐，欢迎回来。我们以一场精彩的访谈开启新的一年。你知道，我们极少有机会采访一位真正发明了一种编程语言的人。每期节目我们都在讨论某种语言。今天我们请到了斯蒂芬·沃尔夫曼。斯蒂芬，你能不能简单介绍一下你自己和 Wolfram Research，并带我们回顾一下你的心路历程？天哪。好吧。这是一个“用几句话描述你自己”的问题。我记得我可以讲一些有趣的故事，关于人们对我说这句话时的情景，但是
All right. Well, we have an hour, so you have plenty of words. Well, let's see. For the last 32 years, I've been working on what's now Wolfram language and a couple of things that many people will know about have come out of that one is Mathematica which was first released in 1988 so we just had our 30th anniversary and the other is Wolfram, which came out in 2009. And Wolfram language is kind of the core of those things. I kind of started working, well, gosh, let's see. What's the story? Well, I got really interested in physics when I was about 10 or 11 years old, which is a depressingly long time ago now. That's the beginning of the 1970s. And one of the things about doing physics is you have to calculate all kinds of things with math and so on. And I was very enthusiastic about physics and
All right. Well, we have an hour, so you have plenty of words. Well, let's see. For the last 32 years, I've been working on what's now Wolfram language and a couple of things that many people will know about have come out of that one is Mathematica which was first released in 1988 so we just had our 30th anniversary and the other is Wolfram, which came out in 2009. And Wolfram language is kind of the core of those things. I kind of started working, well, gosh, let's see. What's the story? Well, I got really interested in physics when I was about 10 or 11 years old, which is a depressingly long time ago now. That's the beginning of the 1970s. And one of the things about doing physics is you have to calculate all kinds of things with math and so on. And I was very enthusiastic about physics and|||好吧，我们有一个小时，所以你有足够多的词。嗯，让我想想。在过去的 32 年里，我一直致力于现在被称为 Wolfram 语言的项目，其中诞生了几个许多人熟知的成果：一个是 Mathematica，它于 1988 年首次发布，所以我们刚刚庆祝了 30 周年；另一个是 Wolfram（Alpha），它于 2009 年问世。Wolfram 语言可以说是这些核心的基础。我开始着手……哦，天哪，让我想想。故事是怎么开始的？嗯，我大概 10 岁或 11 岁的时候就对物理学产生了浓厚的兴趣，那已经是令人沮丧的很久以前了。那是 20 世纪 70 年代初。研究物理学的一大特点是，你必须用数学等方法计算各种各样的事情。我对物理学非常热衷，
very unenthusiastic about calculating things with math and so on. And so I kind of said, this is really boring and very mechanical and should be able to be automated. And that time was about 1972, 1973. I first got exposed to a computer, which was a big thing the size of a large desk and so on, programmed with paper tape and all those terrible things. But I started trying to figure out how to essentially automate the computations that I might want to do for things like physics. And that worked really well. And I discovered all kinds of interesting things in physics. And I got my PhD when I was 20 at Caltech. And then I kind of, at that moment, actually, I was like, okay, I've been using all
very unenthusiastic about calculating things with math and so on. And so I kind of said, this is really boring and very mechanical and should be able to be automated. And that time was about 1972, 1973. I first got exposed to a computer, which was a big thing the size of a large desk and so on, programmed with paper tape and all those terrible things. But I started trying to figure out how to essentially automate the computations that I might want to do for things like physics. And that worked really well. And I discovered all kinds of interesting things in physics. And I got my PhD when I was 20 at Caltech. And then I kind of, at that moment, actually, I was like, okay, I've been using all|||但对用数学等方法进行计算却极其提不起兴趣。所以我当时就想，这真的很无聊，而且非常机械化，应该能够实现自动化。那大约是 1972 年或 1973 年。我第一次接触到计算机，那是一个大得像张大桌子的庞然大物，用纸带和其他那些可怕的东西进行编程。但我开始尝试弄清楚，如何本质上自动化我可能想为物理学之类的事情进行的计算。这效果非常好。我在物理学中发现了各种各样有趣的东西。我 20 岁时在加州理工学院获得了博士学位。然后，在那个时候，实际上我在想，好吧，我一直在使用所有
these computer tools and I've kind of outgrown the ones that exist today. If I want to do all sorts of science and things that I'm interested in, I'm going to have to basically build my own tools. So I started building. So can you dive into that thought process a little bit? So how did you decide that you had sort of outgrown the tool, right? I mean, people say Turing complete and all that stuff, right? I'm sorry? Oh, I was just going to say, you could say, oh, you could do anything in assembly language. You could do anything in C. So it actually requires, I think, a lot of, to some degree, experience,
these computer tools and I've kind of outgrown the ones that exist today. If I want to do all sorts of science and things that I'm interested in, I'm going to have to basically build my own tools. So I started building. So can you dive into that thought process a little bit? So how did you decide that you had sort of outgrown the tool, right? I mean, people say Turing complete and all that stuff, right? I'm sorry? Oh, I was just going to say, you could say, oh, you could do anything in assembly language. You could do anything in C. So it actually requires, I think, a lot of, to some degree, experience,|||这些计算机工具，而我已经有点超越现有的工具了。如果我想做各种各样的科学研究以及我感兴趣的事情，我基本上必须构建自己的工具。所以我开始构建。那么，你能深入谈谈当时的思考过程吗？你是怎么决定自己已经“超越”了这些工具的？我的意思是，人们会说图灵完备之类的东西，对吧？不好意思？哦，我本来想说，你可能会说，哦，你可以在汇编语言中做任何事情。你可以在 C 语言中做任何事情。所以这实际上需要，我认为，在某种程度上需要大量的经验，
or maybe wisdom is the right word, but to recognize that, you know, the productivity hit you would take from having to build something, some tool from scratch is justified by the gain you would get once you have that tool, right? Yeah, it's been interesting in my life. You know, I spent, for example, a decade doing big basic science projects starting in 1991. It was after the first version of Mathematica came out. And I realized, it would have taken me 30 years to do what I managed to do in 10 years. So the five years before that that I spent developing Mathematica as a tool was, in the end, I was coming out way ahead relative to saying, I'll just cobble together what I need to be able to do the things that I want to do. But back in 1979, the story was in a sense simpler because I had been, so the idea of sort of doing mathematical and algebraic computation by computer was one that had originated in the
or maybe wisdom is the right word, but to recognize that, you know, the productivity hit you would take from having to build something, some tool from scratch is justified by the gain you would get once you have that tool, right? Yeah, it's been interesting in my life. You know, I spent, for example, a decade doing big basic science projects starting in 1991. It was after the first version of Mathematica came out. And I realized, it would have taken me 30 years to do what I managed to do in 10 years. So the five years before that that I spent developing Mathematica as a tool was, in the end, I was coming out way ahead relative to saying, I'll just cobble together what I need to be able to do the things that I want to do. But back in 1979, the story was in a sense simpler because I had been, so the idea of sort of doing mathematical and algebraic computation by computer was one that had originated in the|||或者“智慧”可能是更合适的词，但要认识到，你知道，从头开始构建某个工具所带来的生产力损失，完全可以通过一旦拥有该工具所获得的收益来弥补，对吧？是的，我的人生经历很有趣。你知道，例如，从 1991 年开始，我花十年时间做了大型基础科学项目。那是在 Mathematica 的第一个版本发布之后。我意识到，如果用传统方法，我花 10 年做完的事情，我得花 30 年才能完成。因此，在此之前我花五年时间开发 Mathematica 作为工具，最终相对于“我只需拼凑我需要的东西来做我想做的事”这种想法而言，我的收益要大得多。但在 1979 年，这个故事在某种程度上更简单，因为我一直在做——所以通过计算机进行数学和代数计算的想法起源于
1960s. People had built a variety of kind of research systems for doing that. And I had used kind of most of the ones that were at all practical for some strange reason. Other people never used them. It was, it was like there were all these physicists and they were spending all their time with, you know, pencil and paper and so on calculating things. And it was like, no, you know, I can just use a computer to do that. So at that time you're talking like Fortran, mainly Fortran, right? Well, at that time, most theoretical physicists did not use computers. I mean, what happened was if you needed a computation done, you would find some programmer who would go off and do the computation. And in terms of programming languages, yeah, Fortran was the main one.
1960s. People had built a variety of kinds of research systems for doing that. And I had used kind of most of the ones that were at all practical for some strange reason. Other people never used them. It was, it was like there were all these physicists and they were spending all their time with, you know, pencil and paper and so on calculating things. And it was like, no, you know, I can just use a computer to do that. So at that time you're talking like Fortran, mainly Fortran, right? Well, at that time, most theoretical physicists did not use computers. I mean, what happened was if you needed a computation done, you would find some programmer who would go off and do the computation. And in terms of programming languages, yeah, Fortran was the main one.|||20 世纪 60 年代。人们为此构建了各种研究系统。由于某种奇怪的原因，我几乎用过所有真正切实可行的系统。其他人从未使用过它们。这就好像，有那么多物理学家，他们把所有时间都花在用铅笔和纸之类的东西上计算，而我的态度是：不，你知道的，我可以直接用计算机来做这件事。所以你当时指的是 Fortran，主要是 Fortran，对吧？嗯，当时大多数理论物理学家并不使用计算机。我的意思是，实际情况是，如果你需要进行计算，你会找一个程序员去帮你计算。至于编程语言，是的，Fortran 是主力。
It's still Fortran 66. And, you know, if you were a real programmer, you used assembly language. And I remember people telling me, oh, even in the 80s, people telling me, oh, you know, all these high-level languages like C, they're never going to catch on. You know, if you want to do something serious,
It's still Fortran 66. And, you know, if you were a real programmer, you used assembly language. And I remember people telling me, oh, even in the 80s, people telling me, oh, you know, all these high-level languages like C, they're never going to catch on. You know, if you want to do something serious,|||那还是 Fortran 66。而且，你知道，如果你是一个真正的程序员，你会使用汇编语言。我记得有人告诉我，甚至在 80 年代，还有人对我说，哦，你知道，所有像 C 这样的高级语言，它们永远不会流行起来。你知道，如果你想做点严肃的事情，
it has to be assembly language. Yeah, yeah. That's kind of a story that will repeat because in terms of Wolfram language, you know, it's kind of a higher-level language than one seen elsewhere. And people still say, oh, if you want to do something serious, you have to use some lower level language. It isn't true. And, you know, the course of history, you know, I'm very confident in the course of history in terms of that. Yeah, if you're willing to play the long game, you know, Moore's Law always works in your favor. And eventually, almost any of these optimizations that you get from C end up not being that important.
it has to be assembly language. Yeah, yeah. That's kind of a story that will repeat because in terms of Wolfram language, you know, it's kind of a higher-level language than one seen elsewhere. And people still say, oh, if you want to do something serious, you have to use some lower level language. It isn't true. And, you know, the course of history, you know, I'm very confident in the course of history in terms of that. Yeah, if you're willing to play the long game, you know, Moore's Law always works in your favor. And eventually, almost any of these optimizations that you get from C end up not being that important.|||就必须使用汇编语言。是的，是的。这是一个会不断重演的故事，因为就 Wolfram 语言而言，你知道，它比在其他地方看到的语言要更高级。人们仍然会说，哦，如果你想做严肃的事情，你必须使用更低级的语言。事实并非如此。而且，你知道，历史的进程，你知道，我对这方面的历史进程非常有信心。是的，如果你愿意打持久战，你知道，摩尔定律总是对你有利的。最终，从 C 语言中获得的几乎所有这些优化到头来其实并没有那么重要。
But I don't think that's the point. I think that the real point is it's sort of the conceptual level that you can reach. I mean, we're jumping around a lot. And I mean, this is, we're jumping around a lot and I mean, this is super interesting stuff, but if you want to go back to the narrative of how I came to start. No, no, jumping around is fine. Yeah. Let's talk about the trade-offs between, say, Mathematica and writing it in C. I think that's interesting. Well, okay. So first thing you have to understand is in terms of Wolfram language,
But I don't think that's the point. I think that the real point is it's sort of the conceptual level that you can reach. I mean, we're jumping around a lot. And I mean, this is, we're jumping around a lot and I mean, this is super interesting stuff, but if you want to go back to the narrative of how I came to start. No, no, jumping around is fine. Yeah. Let's talk about the trade-offs between, say, Mathematica and writing it in C. I think that's interesting. Well, okay. So first thing you have to understand is in terms of Wolfram language,|||但我认为重点不在这里。我认为真正的重点在于你能达到的概念高度。我的意思是，我们跳跃得挺厉害的。我的意思是，这——我们跳跃得挺厉害的，而且这些内容超级有趣，但如果你想回到我是如何开始的这个叙事上来……不，不，跳跃没关系。是的。我们来谈谈，比方说，Mathematica 与用 C 语言编写它之间的权衡。我觉得这很有趣。好吧，好的。所以你首先要了解的是，就 Wolfram 语言而言，
how do I view that? What do I think of it as? I view it as a computational language, a little different from a programming language. It's a super productive programming language, but more importantly, it's a computational language. It's a language for communicating computational ideas in an explicit, concrete form. And it's a language that allows computational ideas to be communicated and understood both by people and by machines. So kind of my goal in Wolfram Language
how do I view that? What do I think of it as? I view it as a computational language, a little different from a programming language. It's a super productive programming language, but more importantly, it's a computational language. It's a language for communicating computational ideas in an explicit, concrete form. And it's a language that allows computational ideas to be communicated and understood both by people and by machines. So kind of my goal in Wolfram Language|||我是如何看待它的？我认为它是什么？我将它视为一个计算语言，与编程语言略有不同。它是一种超级高效的编程语言，但更重要的是，它是一种计算语言。它是一种以显式、具体的形式交流计算思想的语言。它是一种既能让人类也能让机器交流和理解计算思想的语言。所以在 Wolfram 语言中，我的目标大概是
is to do something really very different from the goal of other kind of the traditional programming languages. You know, the traditional programming languages, it's kind of, okay, I've got my computer in front of me. I need to tell it how to operate its transistors, so to speak, in the best possible way to get what I want done, done. What I'm more interested in is how do I represent in a language the way that I think about something computationally? And then it's the job of, you know, us as the implementers of the language to get the computer to take sort of the goals that humans have expressed and get them implemented as efficiently
is to do something really very different from the goal of other kind of the traditional programming languages. You know, the traditional programming languages, it's kind of, okay, I've got my computer in front of me. I need to tell it how to operate its transistors, so to speak, in the best possible way to get what I want done, done. What I'm more interested in is how do I represent in a language the way that I think about something computationally? And then it's the job of, you know, us as the implementers of the language to get the computer to take sort of the goals that humans have expressed and get them implemented as efficiently|||做一些与传统编程语言的目标截然不同的事情。你知道，传统的编程语言，它基本上是这样的：好吧，我的面前有一台计算机。我需要告诉它如何以最佳方式操作它的晶体管（可以这么说），以完成我想要完成的工作。而我更感兴趣的是，我如何用一种语言来表达我对某事物的计算思考方式？然后，作为语言的实现者，我们的工作就是让计算机接受人类所表达的目标，并尽可能高效地将其实现。
as possible. Now, in terms of, you know, what we've tried to do in Wolfram Language is to build as much knowledge as possible into the language. So, you know, typical we've tried to do in Wolfram Language is to build as much knowledge as possible into the language. So, you know, typical language, there's a fairly small core language, and then maybe people add libraries and all kinds of other things to it. But in Wolfram Language, the idea is have it have as much as possible built in in a coherent way into the language. And that's a lot of work. I mean, you know, the last 32 years, basically, I've spent a large fraction of my time trying to fill in the oh, then and just build lots of stuff coherently into the language. I mean, pretty much, you know, every day, I'm working on kind of the design of the language. In fact, I, in the last for the last almost a year now, I've been doing actually live streaming a bunch of our internal design
as possible. Now, in terms of, you0, what we've tried to do in Wolfram Language is to build as much knowledge as possible into the language. So, you know, typical we've tried to do in Wolfram Language is to build as much knowledge as possible into the language. So, you know, typical language, there's a fairly small core language, and then maybe people add libraries and all kinds of other things to it. But in Wolfram Language, the idea is have it have as much as possible built in in a coherent way into the language. And that's a lot of work. I mean, you know, the last 32 years, basically, I've spent a large fraction of my time trying to fill in the oh, then and just build lots of stuff coherently into the language. I mean, pretty much, you know, every day, I'm working on kind of the design of the language. In fact, I, in the last for the last almost a year now, I've been doing actually live streaming a bunch of our internal design|||现在，就我们在 Wolfram 语言中尝试做的事情而言，我们试图将尽可能多的知识内置到语言中。所以，你知道，典型的语言都有一个相当小的核心语言，然后人们可能会向其添加库和各种其他东西。但在 Wolfram 语言中，其理念是尽可能以连贯的方式将这些内置到语言中。这需要大量的工作。我的意思是，你知道，在过去的 32 年里，基本上我花很大一部分时间试图填补这些空白，并将大量内容连贯地内置到语言中。我的意思是，几乎你知道的每一天，我都在从事语言的设计工作。事实上，在过去近一年的时间里，我实际上一直在直播我们的一系列内部设计
review meetings. I think we just passed 250 hours of live stream design review meetings. So that's to the public? So anyone can just watch that? Yeah, absolutely. It's on Twitch and Facebook Live and YouTube Live. Wow, that's awesome. It's really pretty interesting dynamic. I mean, there's some pretty interesting, sophisticated people who tune in, and they give some great comments. I think we've done better design as a result of things people have suggested. It's always interesting because, like, today, let's see, I did one today.
review meetings. I think we just passed 250 hours of live stream design review meetings. So that's to the public? So anyone can just watch that? Yeah, absolutely. It's on Twitch and Facebook Live and YouTube Live. Wow, that's awesome. It's really pretty interesting dynamic. I mean, there's some pretty interesting, sophisticated people who tune in, and they give some great comments. I think we've done better design as a result of things people has suggested. It's always interesting because, like, today, let's see, I did one today.|||评审会议。我想我们刚刚度过了 250 个小时的直播设计评审会议。所以那是面向公众的？所以任何人都可以观看？是的，绝对的。它在 Twitch、Facebook Live 和 YouTube Live 上播出。哇，太棒了！这真的是一个非常有趣的动态。我的意思是，有一些非常有趣、老练的人在收看，他们会给出很好的评论。我认为由于大家提出的建议，我们做得更好了。这总是很有趣，因为就像今天，让我想想，我今天刚做了一场。
Probably the one yesterday is, I did a couple yesterday, actually. One yesterday was interesting, was about, well, this relates to the whole thing about the language knows stuff. So one of the things it knows is, it knows geographic data about the world. So it knows, you know, the locations of all the cities, the populations of all the cities. We happen to have curated the borders
Probably the one yesterday is, I did a couple yesterday, actually. One yesterday was interesting, was about, well, this relates to the whole thing about the language knows stuff. So one of the things it knows is, it knows geographic data about the world. So it knows, you know, the locations of all the cities, the populations of all the cities. We happen to have curated the borders|||可能昨天的那个……事实上我昨天做了好几场。昨天其中一场很有趣，内容是关于——这与“语言了解事物”这一整件事情有关。它所了解的事情之一就是，它了解世界的地理数据。所以它知道，你知道，所有城市的位置、所有城市的人口。碰巧我们已经整理好了边界
of all historical countries that are known. So there's a few thousand historical countries from, you know, the Roman Empire to, you know, the different gyrations of different countries and so on. And so we got all that data, and the issue is how you deal with the language design of talking about a historical country. So, you know, we were starting off looking at, well, I was like, let's look at the Roman Empire in 55 BC.
of all historical countries that are known. So there's a few thousand historical countries from, you know, the Roman Empire to, you know, the different gyrations of different countries and so on. And so we got all that data, and the issue is how you deal with the language design of talking about a historical country. So, you know, we were starting off looking at, well, I was like, let's look at the Roman Empire in 55 BC.|||所有已知的历史国家的边界。因此，有几千个历史国家，从罗马帝国，到不同国家的不同演变等等。我们获得了所有这些数据，问题在于你如何处理谈论历史国家的语言设计。所以，你知道，我们最初在看——嗯，当时我想的是，让我们看看公元前 55 年的罗马帝国。
And then one of the guys who's worked on this stuff said, well, actually the Roman Empire didn't exist in 55 BC. It was the Roman Republic in 55 BC. And it's like, okay, what does it mean for the entity? You know, what counts as France, for example? You know, it's changed its name at various times. And so, you know, so these are questions that are an interesting mixture of sort of real world issues and kind of precise language design. But more than that, this was
And then one of the guys who's worked on this stuff said, well, actually the Roman Empire didn't exist in 55 BC. It was the Roman Republic in 55 BC. And it's like, okay, what does it mean for the entity? You know, what counts as France, for example? You know, it's changed its name at various times. And so, you know, so these are questions that are an interesting mixture of sort of real world issues and kind of precise language design. But more than that, this was|||然后，一个从事这方面工作的人说，嗯，实际上公元前 55 年并不存在罗马帝国。公元前 55 年那是罗马共和国。这就好比，对于这个实体来说，这意味着什么？你知道，什么算作法国？你知道，它在不同时期更改过名称。所以，你知道，这些问题是现实世界问题与精确语言 design（设计）的有趣结合。但不仅如此，这
actually mostly about how do you think about the sort of time series character of country borders, given that one only knows them every year, and how does one deal with the fact that one has a time series which kind of holds to one side, but not to the other, etc., etc., etc. But this is kind of the story of my life, is trying to figure out how to take these kinds of things and make a precise symbolic language in which one can talk about, let's say, historical countries or today's live stream thing happened to be about the display of data sets and figuring out how to parametrize the way that a hierarchical data set is displayed and elided and so on. So one thing that has always interested me is this idea of sort of push versus pull when
actually mostly about how do you think about the sort of time series character of country borders, given that one only knows them every year, and how does one deal with the fact that one has a time series which kind of holds to one side, but not to the other, etc., etc., etc. But this is kind of the story of my life, is trying to figure out how to take these kinds of things and make a precise symbolic language in which one can talk about, let's say, historical countries or today's live stream thing happened to be about the display of data sets and figuring out how to parametrize the way that a hierarchical data set is displayed and elided and so on. So one thing that has always interested me is this idea of sort of push versus pull when|||实际上主要关于：鉴于人们只知道每年的国界，你如何看待国界的这种时间序列特征，以及如何处理这样一种事实：即你拥有一个倾向于某一边而不倾向另一边的时间序列等等，等等。但这可以说是我的生活写照，也就是试图弄清楚如何将这些东西转化为一种精确的符号语言，在其中人们可以讨论，比方说，历史上的国家，或者今天直播的事情恰好是关于数据集的显示，并弄清楚如何参数化显示和省略分层数据集的方式等等。所以一直让我感兴趣的一件事是，关于数据的“推（push）”与“拉（pull）”的理念，当
it comes to data. So for example, if we take, let's say, Google's web mirror, like Google's indexer, right, they crawl the web, they gather a bunch of data. But the websites themselves are not particularly participating. You know, they're sort of involuntarily participating. Yeah, I mean, what we've done is very different. I mean, you know, what we've been interested in for the last, I don't know, 20 years or so is collecting and curating as much data as possible about the world. And so what we've done mostly is we work with sort of the primary providers of data, or we collect it ourselves, and we try and make as good as possible a kind of computable version of the world. There's a big difference between data that's good enough for somebody to read it on a webpage
it comes to data. So for example, if we take, let's say, Google's web mirror, like Google's indexer, right, they crawl the web, they gather a bunch of data. But the websites themselves are not particularly participating. You know, they're sort of involuntarily participating. Yeah, I mean, what we've done is very different. I mean, you know, what we've been interested in for the last, I don't know, 20 years or so is collecting and curating as much data as possible about the world. And so what we've done mostly is we work with sort of the primary providers of data, or we collect it ourselves, and we try and make as good as possible a kind of computable version of the world. There's a big difference between data that's good enough for somebody to read it on a webpage|||涉及数据时。所以，例如，如果我们以谷歌的网络镜像为例，比如谷歌的索引器，对吧，他们抓取网络，收集一堆数据。但网站本身并没有特别参与。你知道，它们有点像是在非自愿地参与。是的，我的意思是，我们所做的是非常不同的。我的意思是，你知道，在过去大约 20 年里，我们一直感兴趣的是收集和整理尽可能多的关于世界的的数据。所以我们主要做的是，我们与主要的数据提供商合作，或者我们自己收集，我们试图尽可能好地制作一个可计算的世界版本。对于“好到足以让某人在网页上阅读的”数据而言，
and data that's good enough to compute from. You can say, well, you can do some NLP extraction of stuff and you can get it 80% right, and that's fine so long as you've got a human to see that 20% of it is totally ridiculous. In fact, one use case that we've been much involved with in computational contracts and smart contracts on blockchains and things like this, in the end, if you want those to allow one to run the world by machine-to-machine contract interactions, you have to have some source of facts about the world by machine to machine sort of contract interactions, you have to have some source of facts about the world. You know, you're selling weather insurance.
and data that's good enough to compute from. You can say, well, you can do some NLP extraction of stuff and you can get it 80% right, and that's fine so long as you've got a human to see that 20% of it is totally ridiculous. In fact, one use case that we've been much involved with in computational contracts and smart contracts on blockchains and things like this, in the end, if you want those to allow one to run the world by machine-to-machine contract interactions, you have to have some source of facts about the world by machine to machine sort of contract interactions, you have to have some source of facts about the world. You know, you're selling weather insurance.|||和“好到足以对其进行计算的”数据之间，存在着巨大的差异。你可以说，嗯，你可以做一些东西的 NLP 提取，你可以做到 80% 的准确率，只要有一个人类能看出那 20% 是完全荒谬的，这就行了。事实上，我们在计算合同、区块链上的智能合同等类似事情中参与了很多的一个用例是：最终，如果你希望这些合同允许人们通过机器与机器之间的合同交互来运作世界，你就必须拥有某种关于世界的事实来源，通过机器与机器之间的合同交互，你必须拥有某种关于世界的事实来源。你知道，你在卖天气保险。
You want to know, did it actually rain yesterday in wherever? And so, in fact, right now, the source in the world, for better or worse, of computational facts is the Wolfram Alpha API, because we've collected and made computable basically a huge range of kinds of facts in a way where those facts can actually be used as inputs to computation in a consistent fashion. Oh, I've heard about this where there's a, I think it's a betting site where you can bet on facts you could basically you could bet you know there's a prediction tomorrow and it's all done on blockchain yeah yeah I mean you know that that that particular
You want to know, did it actually rain yesterday in wherever? And so, in fact, right now, the source in the world, for better or worse, of computational facts is the Wolfram Alpha API, because we've collected and made computable basically a huge range of kinds of facts in a way where those facts can actually be used as inputs to computation in a consistent fashion. Oh, I've heard about this where there's a, I think it's a betting site where you can bet on facts you could basically you could bet you know there's a prediction tomorrow and it's all done on blockchain yeah yeah I mean you know that that that particular|||你想知道昨天某地真的下雨了吗？因此，事实上，现在世界上计算事实的来源（无论好坏）就是 Wolfram Alpha API，因为我们收集并使基本上范围广泛的各种事实变得可计算，以至于这些事实实际上可以以一致的方式用作计算的输入。哦，我听说过这个，有一个，我认为是一个博彩网站，你可以在上面对事实进行下注，基本上你可以下注，你知道明天的预测，而且这全部都是在区块链上完成的……对，对，我的意思是，你知道，那个特定的
activity egregiously violates our
activity egregiously violates our|||活动公然违反了我们的
deal with these kind of, you know, deciding things at that moment, so to speak, in as robust a way as possible. But I think we've gotten to much of the computational fact, computable knowledge that we deal with is knowledge that wasn't stuff that happened today. I mean, we do deal with plenty that happens today, you know, earthquakes, flight times, you know, all this kind of stuff. But I would say the majority of stuff people are using right now is sort of facts that might be, you know, properties of a chemical or, you know, box office results from a movie or something like this. Things which are, you know, firmly in the past, so to speak, rather than things that, you know, just happened and are uncomplicated to verify.
deal with these kind of, you know, deciding things at that moment, so to speak, in as robust a way as possible. But I think we've gotten to much of the computational fact, computable knowledge that we deal with is knowledge that wasn't stuff that happened today. I mean, we do deal with plenty that happens today, you know, earthquakes, flight times, you know, all this kind of stuff. But I would say the majority of stuff people are using right now is sort of facts that might be, you0, properties of a chemical or, you know, box office results from a movie or something like this. Things which are, you know, firmly in the past, so to speak, rather than things that, you know, just happened and are uncomplicated to verify.|||协议，即以尽可能稳健的方式在那个时刻决定事情。但我认为我们所处理的大部分计算事实、可计算知识都是并非今天才发生的知识。我的意思是，我们确实处理了很多今天发生的事情，你知道，地震、航班时刻表，所有这些东西。但我想说，人们现在使用的大多数东西都是这样的事实：可能是化学品的属性，或者电影的票房收入之类的东西。这些东西可以说，坚定地属于过去，而不是那些刚刚发生且验证起来不复杂的事情。
What about, is there, so, you know, there were things like OpenPsych, for example, where people could specify, you know, a list of facts about the world. Is there any way to sort of scale this outwards so that anyone can contribute in some way to deal with Byzantine contributions and things like that? Have you thought about things like that? Of course we have, yeah. Of course. We've had a whole program of volunteer data curators and so on. It hasn't been particularly successful. I would say that there are particular well-columated types of data where people have been very good at contributing and been very helpful to us. Like, for example, properties of fictional characters in books. That was done by a big volunteer effort. Oh, okay. More precise kinds of data, usually there's some sort of professional data collection
What about, is there, so, you know, there were things like OpenPsych, for example, where people could specify, you know, a list of facts about the world. Is there any way to sort of scale this outwards so that anyone can contribute in some way to deal with Byzantine contributions and things like that? Have you thought about things like that? Of course we have, yeah. Of course. We've had a whole program of volunteer data curators and so on. It hasn't been particularly successful. I would say that there are particular well-columated types of data where people have been very good at contributing and been very helpful to us. Like, for example, properties of fictional characters in books. That was done by a big volunteer effort. Oh, okay. More precise kinds of data, usually there's some sort of professional data collection|||那么，有没有……所以，你知道，以前有像 OpenPsych 这样的项目，人们可以在其中指定关于世界的事实列表。有没有什么办法可以将其向外扩展，以便任何人都可以以某种方式做出贡献，来应对拜占庭式的贡献之类的事情？你想过类似的事情吗？我们当然想过，是的。当然。我们曾有过一个完整的志愿数据管理员计划等。但这并不是特别成功。我想说的是，存在某些特定、整理良好的数据类型，人们非常擅长为此做出贡献，对我们非常有帮助。例如，书中的虚构人物的属性。那是通过大规模的志愿者努力完成的。哦，好吧。至于更精确的数据，通常会有某种专业的数据收集
operation that's doing it, or nobody has done it, but to do it consistently is non-trivial. What we found is we employ lots of data curators, and we found that's more efficient than, you know, having volunteers do it because it's just, you know, we can train them. They use a bunch of nice tools, which we could make available to people. But, you know, it takes some training to get to be a good, efficient data curator. And, you know, it's not everybody's cup of tea. That makes sense. I think there's also great ambiguity in the structure of almost any data and so if you just give it to this heterogeneous
operation that's doing it, or nobody has done it, but to do it consistently is non-trivial. What we found is we employ lots of data curators, and we found that's more efficient than, you know, having volunteers do it because it's just, you know, we can train them. They use a bunch of nice tools, which we could make available to people. But, you know, it takes some training to get to be a good, efficient data curator. And, you know, it's not everybody's cup of tea. That makes sense. I think there's also great ambiguity in the structure of almost any data and so if you just give it to this heterogeneous|||工作在做，或者根本没人做，但要始终如一地做好它并非易事。我们发现，我们雇用了大量的数据管理员，而且我们发现这比让志愿者去做更有效率，因为很简单，我们可以培训他们。他们使用一堆我们也可以提供给公众的优秀工具。但是，成为一名优秀、高效的数据管理员需要接受一些培训。而且，你知道，这并不是每个人的爱好。这讲得通。我认为几乎任何数据的结构中也存在巨大的模糊性，所以如果你只是把它交给这些异构的
group of volunteers you're very rarely going to get a consistent structure yeah i think what one of the challenges of data curation and and you know a thing i hadn't really realized but you know we've built this whole sort of culture of doing data curation and i hadn't really realized, but we've built this whole culture of doing data curation, and I hadn't really realized how unique that is. Because we do a bunch of work with all sorts of world's largest companies making basically private versions of Wolfram Alpha. So the Wolfram Alpha that people know that powers Siri and also has just started powering Alexa, that's working on public data. But we've also had a sort of growing business on making enterprise versions of Wolfram Alpha, where we're taking the internal data of some large company and letting people ask unstructured questions about that internal data, making use of public data plus
group of volunteers you're very rarely going to get a consistent structure yeah i think what one of the challenges of data curation and and you know a thing i hadn't really realized but you know we've built this whole sort of culture of doing data curation and i hadn't really realized, but we've built this whole culture of doing data curation, and I hadn't really realized how unique that is. Because we do a bunch of work with all sorts of world's largest companies making basically private versions of Wolfram Alpha. So the Wolfram Alpha that people know that powers Siri and also has just started powering Alexa, that's working on public data. But we've also had a sort of growing business on making enterprise versions of Wolfram Alpha, where we're taking the internal data of some large company and letting people ask unstructured questions about that internal data, making use of public data plus|||志愿者群体，你将极难获得一个一致的结构。是的，我认为数据整理面临的挑战之一——你知道，有一件事我以前并没有真正意识到，但我们已经建立了一整套进行数据整理的文化，我以前真的没有意识到它是多么独特。因为我们与世界各地的各种最大公司合作开展了大量工作，基本上是制作 Wolfram Alpha 的私有版本。因此，人们所熟知的支持 Siri 并且刚刚开始支持 Alexa 的 Wolfram Alpha，它处理的是公共数据。但我们也有不断增长的业务，即制作企业版的 Wolfram Alpha，我们获取某些大公司的内部数据，让人们对这些内部数据提出非结构化的问题，并利用公共数据加上
their internal data. So somebody might say, what were my sales between Christmas and New Year in sub-Saharan Africa or something? And for that, you have to know things about the world, like Christmas and New Year. You have to know what's sub-Saharan Africa. You have to be able to know currency conversion rates, all those kinds of things. And to answer that question, you have to go be hooked up to the internal databases of company X to go and answer that. So we've done a bunch of those things. And one of the things that's been interesting is that people are sort of horrified. You mean you actually have to go and do things with humans to make all this stuff work?
their internal data. So somebody might say, what were my sales between Christmas and New Year in sub-Saharan Africa or something? And for that, you have to know things about the world, like Christmas and New Year. You have to know what's sub-Saharan Africa. You have to be able to know currency conversion rates, all those kinds of things. And to answer that question, you have to go be hooked up to the internal databases of company X to go and answer that. So we've done a bunch of those things. And one of the things that's been interesting is that people are sort of horrified. You mean you actually have to go and do things with humans to make all this stuff work?|||他们的内部数据。所以有人可能会问：“我在撒哈拉以南非洲地区圣诞节到新年之间的销售额是多少？”诸如此类。为此，你必须了解关于世界的事情，比如什么是圣诞节和新年。你必须知道什么是撒哈拉以南非洲。你必须能够了解汇率转换率，所有这些事情。为了回答这个问题，你必须连接到 X 公司的内部数据库去回答它。所以我们做过许多这样类似的事情。其中有趣的一点是，人们有点被吓到了：“你是说你实际上必须让人类参与进来，才能让所有这些东西运作起来吗？”
Well, yes. I mean, you know, it's we can do. We have very good, you know, we've got very leading edge machine learning stuff and NLP stuff and so on. But, you know, that's not if you really want to make computable data, you can't use that stuff. You can use it to help prime various pumps, but in the end, humans and large volume of work to be done and there's also judgment to be exercised. And it's a tricky management issue how you propagate judgment calls up and down the chain of people who are working on this type of thing you know at what point do you propagate you know I don't know in in you know is this a I don't know like if
Well, yes. I mean, you know, it's we can do. We have very good, you know, we've got very leading edge machine learning stuff and NLP stuff and so on. But, you know, that's not if you really want to make computable data, you can't use that stuff. You can use it to help prime various pumps, but in the end, humans and large volume of work to be done and there's also judgment to be exercised. And it's a tricky management issue how you propagate judgment calls up and down the chain of people who are working on this type of thing you know at what point do you propagate you know I don't know in in you know is this a I don't know like if|||嗯，是的。我的意思是，你知道的，我们可以做到。我们拥有非常顶尖的机器学习、NLP 等等技术。但是，你知道，如果你真的想制作可计算的数据，你就不能只用那些东西。你可以用它们来帮助启动各种引擎，但最终，需要人类完成大量的工作，而且还需要发挥判断力。这是一个棘手管理问题：如何在从事此类工作的人员链条上下传递判断。你知道，在哪个节点上进行传递？我不知道，在……你知道，这是否是一个……我不知道，比如如果
you're doing image curation you know does this really count as an elephant or is it a model a plastic elephant you know what does a do we really call this an elephant or do we call it a toy yeah and somebody you know at some point somebody has to make a decision like that. But you have to kind of propagate that to the point where that decision is made by somebody with appropriate experience and who knows how it fits together with the rest of the system. But the person who's actually looking at pages and pages of images doesn't, you know, isn't the one who has to be figuring that out all the time. I feel like there's something kind of philosophically profound about that. You know, there's basically two types of jobs. There are jobs that have almost infinite scalability and then there are jobs that don't. So for example, being a musician now
you're doing image curation you know does this really count as an elephant or is it a model a plastic elephant you know what does a do we really call this an elephant or do we call it a toy yeah and somebody you know at some point somebody has to make a decision like that. But you have to kind of propagate that to the point where that decision is made by somebody with appropriate experience and who knows how it fits together with the rest of the system. But the person who's actually looking at pages and pages of images doesn't, you know, isn't the one who has to be figuring that on all the time. I feel like there's something kind of philosophically profound about that. You know, there's basically two types of jobs. There are jobs that have almost infinite scalability and then there are jobs that don't. So for example, being a musician now|||你在做图像整理时，你知道，这真的算作一头大象，还是一个塑料大象模型？你知道，我们真的称之为大象，还是称之为玩具？是的，而且某人，你知道，在某个时刻，必须做出这样的决定。但你必须将其传递到这样一个程度：即该决定由具有相应经验、且知道它如何与系统其余部分契合的人做出。但那个实际查看一页又一页图像的人，你知道，并不是那个必须一直在琢磨这些问题的人。我觉得这其中蕴含着某种哲学上深刻的东西。你知道，基本上有两种类型的工作。一种是几乎具有无限可扩展性的工作，另一种是没有这种可扩展性的工作。例如，现在成为一名音乐家
is one of these jobs that scales in the sense that some famous musician will go in a studio and record a song once, and then it gets played on the radio over the whole world to millions of people. Being a software engineer is also one of these scalable jobs where you can design some software that's used by billions of people with only, let's say, a few hundred engineers, right? Yeah. And everyone is really worried about, say, automation, taking a job that isn't scalable, like truck driving, and turning it into a scalable job.
is one of these jobs that scales in the sense that some famous musician will go in a studio and record a song once, and then it gets played on the radio over the whole world to millions of people. Being a software engineer is also one of these scalable jobs where you can design some software that's used by billions of people with only, let's say, a few hundred engineers, right? Yeah. And everyone is really worried about, say, automation, taking a job that isn't scalable, like truck driving, and turning it into a scalable job.|||就是这种可扩展的工作之一，因为某个著名的音乐家可以去录音室录制一首歌一次，然后它就会在全世界的广播中播放给数百万人听。软件工程师也是这些可扩展的工作之一，你只需区区几百名工程师，就可以设计出被数十亿人使用的软件，对吧？是的。每个人都非常担心，比如自动化会夺走诸如卡车司机这样不可扩展的工作，并将其变成一种可扩展的工作。
But in your case, you're kind of doing the opposite, where you are taking a job that had been done with, say, NLP poorly, and you're changing the scale, changing that sort of dynamic to get something that has really high fidelity. And it's funny how even intuitively, on the surface, my first reaction is, oh, that doesn't scale. But maybe that's actually a good thing, right? Maybe what we need is to have more of a human touch. Oh, I don't scale. But maybe that's actually a good thing, right? Maybe what we need is to have more of a human touch. Oh, I don't know.
But in your case, you're kind of doing the opposite, where you are taking a job that had been done with, say, NLP poorly, and you're changing the scale, changing that sort of dynamic to get something that has really high fidelity. And it's funny how even intuitively, on the surface, my first reaction is, oh, that doesn't scale. But maybe that's actually a good thing, right? Maybe what we need is to have more of a human touch. Oh, I don't know.|||但在你这里，你做的事情有点相反。你接手了一项以前用 NLP 做得不好的工作，然后你正在改变规模，改变那种动态，以获得具有极高保真度的成果。有趣的是，甚至在直觉上，表面上看，我的第一反应是：“哦，这无法扩展。”但也许这实际上是一件好事，对吧？也许我们需要的是更多的人情味。哦，我不知道。
I think the fact is the thing to understand is what does it mean it doesn't scale? The world is finite. You know, when we started working on Wolfram Alpha, I had been interested in building something like Wolfram Alpha since I was a kid. I've been interested in kind of being able to sort of collect information, answer questions from it, and so on. I mean, horrifyingly, I found a bunch of stuff I did when I was like 12 years old, which is sort of pre-WolframAlpha stuff with, you know, typewriter rather than, you know, data centers, so to speak. But it's always upsetting. In a sense, I don't know whether it's upsetting or satisfying to discover one's really been doing the same thing all one's life.
I think the fact is the thing to understand is what does it mean it doesn't scale? The world is finite. You know, when we started working on Wolfram Alpha, I had been interested in building something like Wolfram Alpha since I was a kid. I've been interested in kind of being able to sort of collect information, answer questions from it, and so on. I mean, horrifyingly, I found a bunch of stuff I did when I was like 12 years old, which is sort of pre-WolframAlpha stuff with, you know, typewriter rather than, you know, data centers, so to speak. But it's always upsetting. In a sense, I don't know whether it’s upsetting or satisfying to discover one's really been doing the same thing all one's life.|||我认为事实是，需要理解的是，“无法扩展”到底意味着什么？世界是有限的。你知道，当我们开始研发 Wolfram Alpha 时，我从小就对构建类似 Wolfram Alpha 的东西感兴趣。我一直对能够收集信息、从中回答问题等事情感兴趣。我的意思是，令人毛骨悚然的是，我发现了许多我大约 12 岁时做过的事情，这可以说是前 Wolfram Alpha 时代的东西，用的是打字机，而不是，你知道的，数据中心。但这总是令人不安。从某种意义上说，我不知道发现自己一生中其实一直在做同一件事是令人不安还是令人满足。
But anyway, I was interested to, you know, I'd been interested in kind of, can you make computational knowledge real since I was a kid? And, you know, I had actually always assumed that one had to kind of invent the whole of AI to do that. And eventually, as a result of a bunch of science I did, I kind of realized that wasn't the case. But when we started doing the Wolf Malfa project, it was like, okay, let's take the team over to a big reference library. And let's look at this reference library. And it's like, it's a big thing with, you know, full of books. And my basic statement was, okay, over the next few years, we're going to grind all of the knowledge that's in here, and we're going to make it computable. And, you know, it's a daunting task, but it is finite.
But anyway, I was interested to, you know, I'd been interested in kind of, can you make computational knowledge real since I was a kid? And, you know, I had actually always assumed that one had to kind of invent the whole of AI to do that. And eventually, as a result of a bunch of science I did, I kind of realized that wasn't the case. But when we started doing the Wolf Malfa project, it was like, okay, let's take the team over to a big reference library. And let's look at this reference library. And it's like, it's a big thing with, you know, full of books. And my basic statement was, okay, over the next few years, we're going to grind all of the knowledge that's in here, and we're going to make it computable. And, you know, it's a daunting task, but it is finite.|||但无论如何，我有兴趣去——你知道的，我从小就对“你能让计算知识变成现实吗？”感兴趣。而且，你知道，我实际上一直以为必须发明整个人工智能才能做到这一点。最终，通过我做的一系列科学研究，我意识到事实并非如此。但当我们开始做 Wolfram Alpha 项目时，就像是：好吧，让我们把团队带到一个大型参考图书馆。让我们看看这个参考图书馆。它就像是一个巨大的、你知道的，充满书本的东西。我的基本宣言是：好吧，在接下来的几年里，我们要把这里所有的知识都“磨”出来，我们要让它们变得可计算。而且，你知道，这是一项艰巨的任务，但它是有限的。
You know, it's a finite-sized room, so to speak. And we got much more knowledge than was in, you know, the big reference library. But it's worth realizing that, you know, our civilization has only collected sort of a finite amount of knowledge about things. It's always surprising, you know, the amount of sort of purely structured data that there is in the world is quite big compared to, for example, the text content of the web. I mean, I don't know whose estimate you want to take, but let's say the web is, I don't know, some modest number of tens of billions of pages of text. There's actually much more of that in structured data that even we have for Malpha. So in other words, even if you say, well, gosh, let's use the scaling of the web and try and deduce knowledge from it, there actually isn't that much there.
You know, it's a finite-sized room, so to speak. And we got much more knowledge than was in, you know, the big reference library. But it's worth realizing that, you know, our civilization has only collected sort of a finite amount of knowledge about things. It's always surprising, you know, the amount of sort of purely structured data that there is in the world is quite big compared to, for example, the text content of the web. I mean, I don't know whose estimate you want to take, but let's say the web is, I don't know, some modest number of tens of billions of pages of text. There's actually much more of that in structured data that even we have for Malpha. So in other words, even if you say, well, gosh, let's use the scaling of the web and try and deduce knowledge from it, there actually isn't that much there.|||你知道，可以这么说，这是一个有限大小的房间。我们获得的知识远远超过了那座大型参考图书馆里的知识。但值得认识到的是，你知道，我们的文明只收集了关于事物的有限数量的知识。总是令人惊讶的是，你知道，与网络的文本内容相比，世界上纯粹结构化数据的数量其实相当巨大。我的意思是，我不知道你想采用谁的估计，但假设网络有，我不知道，几十亿甚至上百亿页的文本。实际上，即使是我们为 Wolfram Alpha 收集的结构化数据，其体量也远超于此。换句话说，即使你说，好吧，天哪，让我们利用网络的规模并试图从中推导知识，那里其实并没有那么多东西。
That makes sense, yeah. But I think, for me, there are two big multipliers that go beyond the sort of curate the data type thing. One is knowledge about computation, knowledge about algorithms, how you compute things from that data. Because actually, most of the time, people don't just want that one number that was sitting in a database. They want something that was the particular thing they wanted to know that is computed using some method or model or algorithm or something from the raw data that might sit in the database or whatever.
That makes sense, yeah. But I think, for me, there are two big multipliers that go beyond the sort of curate the data type thing. One is knowledge about computation, knowledge about algorithms, how you compute things from that data. Because actually, most of the time, people don't just want that one number that was sitting in a database. They want something that was the particular thing they wanted to know that is computed using some method or model or algorithm or something from the raw data that might sit in the database or whatever.|||这讲得通，是的。但我认为，对我来说，有两个巨大的乘数超出了整理数据这类事情的范畴。一个是关于计算的知识，关于算法的知识，以及你如何从这些数据中计算出东西。因为实际上，大多数时候，人们不仅仅想要数据库里躺着的那个数字。他们想要的是他们特别想知道的那种东西，它是使用某种方法、模型或算法，从可能位于数据库或其他地方的原始数据中计算出来的。
Right. Or they're even looking for some signal. They want to decrease the entropy. So for example, they have a bunch of sales data and they want to know which countries are outliers. So they want some decision tree that's going to say, this area of the world is performing great, this area of the world is performing poorly, and they want your system to extract that high level information. Right. But you see now, take that example. It's an interesting example because it's an example where the kind of knowledge-based approach that we use in Wolfram language is important. Because let's say you've got that raw sales data. You've got the table of numbers. You've got the number for Luxembourg. You've got the number for Germany. You've got et cetera, et cetera, et cetera. On its own, those numbers aren't all that significant because if you don't know, let's
Right. Or they're even looking for some signal. They want to decrease the entropy. So for example, they have a bunch of sales data and they want to know which countries are outliers. So they want some decision tree that's going to say, this area of the world is performing great, this area of the world is performing poorly, and they want your system to extract that high level information. Right. But you see now, take that example. It's an interesting example because it's an example where the kind of knowledge-based approach that we use in Wolfram language is important. Because let's say you've got that raw sales data. You've got the table of numbers. You've got the number for Luxembourg. You've got the number for Germany. You've got et cetera, et cetera, et cetera. On its own, those numbers aren't all that significant because if you don't know, let's|||对的。或者他们甚至在寻找某种信号。他们想要减少熵。例如，他们有一堆销售数据，他们想知道哪些国家是异常值。所以他们需要某种决策树来指出：世界的这个区域表现很好，世界的那个区域表现不佳，他们希望你的系统能够提取出那种高级信息。没错。但你看现在，拿这个例子来说。这是一个有趣的例子，因为它说明了我们真正在 Wolfram 语言中使用的基于知识的方法非常重要。因为假设你拥有了原始销售数据。你拥有了数字表格。你拥有了卢森堡的数字。你有了德国的数字。你有了等等，等等，等等。就其本身而言，这些数字并没有那么大意义，因为如果你不知道，比方说，
say, the population or the GDP or the number of internet users or something in each of those countries, it's hard to make all that much from it. And so it becomes really important to have good computable data that you can use as part of the kind of pipeline of actually doing things. You could say, well, I'll go scrape that data from somewhere. Okay, great. Then you scrape the data, you discover that countries that have spaces in their names don't work, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
say, the population or the GDP or the number of internet users or something in each of those countries, it's hard to make all that much from it. And so it becomes really important to have good computable data that you can use as part of the kind of pipeline of actually doing things. You could say, well, I'll go scrape that data from somewhere. Okay, great. Then you scrape the data, you discover that countries that have spaces in their names don't work, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.|||每个国家的人口、GDP 或互联网用户数量等，你就很难从中得出太多结论。因此，拥有良好的可计算数据就变得非常重要，你可以将其用作实际做事流水线的一部分。你可能会说：“好吧，我会去某处抓取这些数据。”好的，太棒了。然后你抓取了数据，你发现名字中带有空格的国家无法正常处理，等等，等等。
This is what I've been trying to do is to kind of add this kind of layer of kind of automated computational intelligence that people can kind of take for granted in computing things. ago and so on, when the first computers were coming out, it was like, well, you could take for granted the fact that there'd be some, what was called a high-level language like COBOL or FORTRAN on that computer. Then a few years later, you could take for granted there'd be an operating system on the computer. Then a few years later, take for granted there'd be some kind of user interface or some kind of networking support on the computer. And what I'm trying to do, basically,
This is what I've been trying to do is to kind of add this kind of layer of kind of automated computational intelligence that people can kind of take for granted in computing things. ago and so on, when the first computers were coming out, it was like, well, you could take for granted the fact that there'd be some, what was called a high-level language like COBOL or FORTRAN on that computer. Then a few years later, you could take for granted there'd be an operating system on the computer. Then a few years later, take for granted there'd be some kind of user interface or some kind of networking support on the computer. And what I'm trying to do, basically,|||这就是我一直试图做的：添加这种自动化计算智能的层，人们在进行计算时可以理所当然地认为它存在。以前等等，当第一台计算机问世时，就好像你可以理所当然地认为那台计算机上会有某种被称为像 COBOL 或 FORTRAN 这样的大型高级语言。然后几年后，你可以理所当然地认为计算机上会有操作系统。然后几年后，理所当然地认为计算机上会有某种用户界面或某种网络支持。而我基本上在尝试做的是，
is to let people take for granted a sort of layer of computational intelligence that they can expect to find on a computer. And where we've tried to take sort of the knowledge that our civilization has accumulated and try to sort of inject that as something that can be automatically accessed by anybody. That's the bigger picture of what we're trying to do and a couple of branches of doing that. In Wolfram Alpha, we're trying to make a consumerized drive-by version of that where you just ask a question with natural language. You can ask it by voice through intelligent assistance, or you can type it on the website or whatever. And the natural language, like the let me ask a question,
is to let people take for granted a sort of layer of computational intelligence that they can expect to find on a computer. And where we've tried to take sort of the knowledge that our civilization has accumulated and try to sort of inject that as something that can be automatically accessed by anybody. That's the bigger picture of what we're trying to do and a couple of branches of doing that. In Wolfram Alpha, we're trying to make a consumerized drive-by version of that where you just ask a question with natural language. You can ask it by voice through intelligent assistance, or you can type it on the website or whatever. And the natural language, like the let me ask a question,|||让人们理所当然地认为，存在着一种他们可以在计算机上找到的计算智能层。我们试图将我们的文明所积累的知识融入其中，并尝试将其注入为任何人都可以自动访问的东西。这就是我们试图做的宏大图景以及实现这一目标的几个分支。在 Wolfram Alpha 中，我们试图制作一个消费级的、即用型的版本，你只需用自然语言提出问题。你可以通过智能助手的语音来提问，也可以在网站上输入等等。而自然语言，比如让我问一个问题，
like what was the population of France in 1952 or something, that's something one can easily ask as a kind of natural language question. And that's what we're doing with Wolfram Alpha. With Wolfram Language, we have a precise language in which a question like that can be expressed. It's very simple to express, but in which one can build up much more sophisticated kinds of things in which one can sort of represent. It provides a more precise way than human language to represent what one's talking about when one thinks about things computationally. I mean, a way to think about this that sort of emerged recently is when we think about contracts, people want to say, I want to say precisely what's going to happen.
like what was the population of France in 1952 or something, that's something one can easily ask as a kind of natural language question. And that's what we're doing with Wolfram Alpha. With Wolfram Language, we have a precise language in which a question like that can be expressed. It's very simple to express, but in which one can build up much more sophisticated kinds of things in which one can sort of represent. It provides a more precise way than human language to represent what one's talking about when one thinks about things computationally. I mean, a way to think about this that sort of emerged recently is when we think about contracts, people want to say, I want to say precisely what's going to happen.|||比如 1952 年法国的人口是多少之类的，这完全可以作为一种自然语言问题轻松提出。这就是我们通过 Wolfram Alpha 正在做的事情。而通过 Wolfram Language，我们拥有了一种精确的语言，可以用它来表达类似的问题。表达起来非常简单，但在此基础上，人们可以构建出更复杂的东西来进行表征。相比人类语言，它提供了一种更精确的方式来表征当人们从计算角度思考事物时所谈论的内容。我的意思是，最近出现的一种思考方式是：当我们考虑合同时，人们希望说：“我想要精确地说明将要发生什么。”
Well, they try and write it in English. Actually, they wind up with some kind of legalese that's some kind of very stilted English often. But what we're trying to do is to make it possible to say what you want to have happen in code, in precise computational language code. But that code, in order to talk about what you want to have happen, it has to be able to talk about things in the world. It's no good to just say, okay, I'm going to declare that there's an array of integers of length whatever. That's not really good enough.
Well, they try and write it in English. Actually, they wind up with some kind of legalese that's some kind of very stilted English often. But what we're trying to do is to make it possible to say what you want to have happen in code, in precise computational language code. But that code, in order to talk about what you want to have happen, it has to be able to talk about things in the world. It's no good to just say, okay, I'm going to declare that there's an array of integers of length whatever. That's not really good enough.|||嗯，他们试图用英语来写。实际上，他们最终写出的是某种法律术语，通常是一种非常生硬的英语。但我们试图做的是，让你能够用代码、用精确的计算语言代码来表达你希望发生的事情。但是，为了谈论你希望发生的事情，这段代码必须能够谈论世界上的事物。仅仅说“好吧，我将声明一个长度为某某的整数数组”是没有用的。这真的不够好。
You have to be able to say, if the person is more than 50 miles from this place, then whatever. That requires that you understand geo positions and distances and, you know, all this kind of thing. You have to actually understand stuff about the world to be able to express these things. But what I've been trying to do is to make a language in which you can express those kinds of things, but you can do it precisely and you can do it in a way that you, where you can kind of build up, of build up many, many layers of complexity. So in a typical, when you interact with Wolfram Alpha, it's like the typical thing will be
You have to be able to say, if the person is more than 50 miles from this place, then whatever. That requires that you understand geo positions and distances and, you know, all this kind of thing. You have to actually understand stuff about the world to be able to express these things. But what I've been trying to do is to make a language in which you can express those kinds of things, but you can do it precisely and you can do it in a way that you, where you can kind of build up, of build up many, many layers of complexity. So in a typical, when you interact with Wolfram Alpha, it's like the typical thing will be|||你必须能够说：如果此人距离这个地方超过 50 英里，那么……这就要求你了解地理位置、距离，你知道，所有这类事情。你实际上必须了解关于世界的事物，才能表达这些事情。但我一直试图做的是创造一种语言，在其中你可以表达这些事情，而且你可以精确地表达，并且你可以以一种能够让你构建出许多层复杂性的方式来表达。因此，在一个典型的情况下，当你与 Wolfram Alpha 交互时，典型的事情通常是
a fragment of a sentence or maybe a whole sentence. When you look at what people do with Wolfram Language, there are probably the biggest code base we have. I don't know what our total, I know Wolfram Alpha is about 15 million lines of Wolfram language code. I think our whole Wolfram language code base, which is mostly written in Wolfram language now, is around 50 million lines. So it's a rather dense code because it's very high level symbolic representation of things. But so, so kind of the idea is that, that one be able to, you know, my, my goal is to give people sort of a, to be able to let them sort of in every line of that code, make use of all the knowledge that, that our civilizations
a fragment of a sentence or maybe a whole sentence. When you look at what people do with Wolfram Language, there are probably the biggest code base we have. I don't know what our total, I know Wolfram Alpha is about 15 million lines of Wolfram language code. I think our whole Wolfram language code base, which is mostly written in Wolfram language now, is around 50 million lines. So it's a rather dense code because it's very high level symbolic representation of things. But so, so kind of the idea is that, that one be able to, you know, my, my goal is to give people sort of a, to be able to let them sort of in every line of that code, make use of all the knowledge that, that our civilizations|||一句话的片段，或者可能是一个完整的句子。当你看看人们用 Wolfram 语言做什么时，那可能是我们拥有的最大的代码库。我不知道我们的总代码量是多少，我知道 Wolfram Alpha 大约有 1500 万行 Wolfram 语言代码。我认为我们整个 Wolfram 语言代码库（现在主要由 Wolfram 语言编写）大约有 5000 万行。所以这是一段相当密集的代码，因为它是非常高级的事物符号表示。但是，所以——这个想法是，能够——你知道的，我的目标是给人们提供一种——能够让他们在代码的每一行中，利用我们文明所积累的所有知识，
been able to accumulate. And, you know, don't have to build everything kind of from the sand up, so to speak. Yeah, that makes sense. I think it's fascinating. One of the things that I've felt in the past is the way, and then I'll jump to something else, but the way Google has sort of crawled the web, it's really kind of, I mean, you know, it's a great service, but one of the issues with that is the data, as you said, hasn't been very structured and other people haven't been able to play a role. Even though you might not have volunteers, but you're still going out to these data providers who are ultimately going out to the actual source of that information. And there's this sort of two-way conversation. And I think that adds a lot to the richness of the data, which I think is awesome.
been able to accumulate. And, you know, don't have to build everything kind of from the sand up, so to speak. Yeah, that makes sense. I think it's fascinating. One of the things that I've felt in the past is the way, and then I'll jump to something else, but the way Google has sort of crawled the web, it's really kind of, I mean, you know, it's a great service, but one of the issues with that is the data, as you said, hasn't been very structured and other people haven't been able to play a role. Even though you might not have volunteers, but you're still going out to these data providers who are ultimately going out to the actual source of that information. And there's this sort of two-way conversation. And I think that adds a lot to the richness of the data, which I think is awesome.|||并且不必一切都从沙子（零）开始构建，可以这么说。是的，这讲得通。我认为这太迷人了。我过去感受到的事情之一是，然后我会跳到别的话题，但谷歌抓取网络的方式，它真的有点——我的意思是，你知道，这是一项伟大的服务，但其中一个问题是，正如你所说，数据一直不是很有结构，其他人也无法发挥作用。尽管你可能没有志愿者，但你仍然在寻找那些最终会找到该信息实际来源的数据提供商。并且存在着这种双向对话。我认为这大大丰富了数据的丰富性，这太棒了。
What do you deal? How do you deal with, let's say, questions around saliency? So if someone wants to say, you know, tell me something interesting about my profits in the past 10 years or something like that. Like, how do you avoid you? How do you how do you take into account someone's mental model? So so when they ask something, it's not just sort of a laundry list of details, but you kind of take into account their intuition there, right? Right. I mean, it's interesting. When I started working on WolfMalfa,
What do you deal? How do you deal with, let's say, questions around saliency? So if someone wants to say, you know, tell me something interesting about my profits in the past 10 years or something like that. Like, how do you avoid you? How do you how do you take into account someone's mental model? So so when they ask something, it's not just sort of a laundry list of details, but you kind of take into account their intuition there, right? Right. I mean, it's interesting. When I started working on WolfMalfa,|||你如何处理？比方说，你如何处理关于显著性（saliency）的问题？所以如果有人想说，你知道，“告诉我一些关于我过去 10 年利润的有趣事情”或类似的话。比如，你如何避免？你如何将某个人的心理模型考虑进去？因此，当他们问某些事情时，它不仅仅是一长串的细节罗列，而是你在其中考虑了他们的直觉，对吧？没错。我的意思是，这很有趣。当我开始研究 Wolfram Alpha 时，
I kind of designed this framework for figuring out, okay, so what does the sort of automated report that WolfMalfa generates look like? And I thought we're going to have to iterate this a zillion times to make it, you know, useful to people. Turns out, you know, with a bunch of fairly clever heuristics and things, we do remarkably well. And, you know, because we obviously have data on what people click on and, you know, where they read and so on. And, you know, I think it's a, but it requires, you know, expert knowledge to build these things. So, I mean, those heuristics are built by using the fact that, you know, somebody who actually knew a lot about this field helped define those heuristics. If it was just like, let's automate it, let's try and put a
我有点设计了这个框架来弄清楚，好吧，Wolfram Alpha 生成的这种自动化报告长什么样？我当时想，我们必须经过无数次的迭代，才能让它对人们有用。事实证明，通过一堆相当聪明的启发式方法和其他东西，我们做得非常出色。而且，你知道，因为我们显然拥有人们点击什么、在哪里阅读等等的数据。而且，我认为这是一个，但这需要专家知识来构建这些东西。所以，我的意思是，这些启发式方法是通过利用这样一个事实建立起来的，即某个对这个领域非常了解的人帮助定义了这些启发式方法。如果只是说，让我们自动化它，让我们试着把一个
ranking algorithm in here and just do it based on, you know, we don't know what this is. It's just a question of how the words are correlated and, you know, let's use, you know, TFIDF or something to do something. It's turned out that that was actually, of all the various things, you know, it was one of many things that I thought was going to be really difficult with Wolfram Alpha that turned out, you know, we had a bunch of big advantages in terms of the way our algorithmic system was, the framework was built, and also the kind of way that we made use of, you know, experts all the way through what we've done. But, you know, that turned out to be making reports that are what people care about has turned out to be remarkably – that has not turned out to be the difficult thing. Now, if you say, okay, let me – throw me some random data. Tell me something interesting about it.
排名算法放在这里，然后仅仅根据——我们不知道这是什么。这只是一个关于词语之间如何相关的问题，然后，让我们用 TF-IDF 或类似的东西来做点什么。事实证明，在各种各样的事情中，这实际上是我原以为在 Wolfram Alpha 上会非常困难的众多事情之一，结果证明我们在算法系统的构建方式、框架以及我们在所做的一切中始终利用专家的方式上，有很多巨大的优势。但是，你知道，事实证明，制作人们关心的报告并不是最困难的事情。现在，如果你说，好吧，让我——随便给我一些随机数据。告诉我一些关于它的有趣的事情。
We actually have done that a bit. We actually had the pro version of Wolfram Alpha. You can actually upload data sets, and it will try and do things like that. I don't consider that particularly successful. I mean, I don't think people, you know, people find it amusing, but I don't think it's, I don't consider it kind of something that is a, you know, a core thing that people really care about at this point. That makes sense. I mean, I think it's profoundly difficult to come up with some kind of distance metric there. Like if someone gives you a bunch of financial data and you just project that into some latent space,
我们实际上已经做过一点了。我们实际上有 Wolfram Alpha 的专业版。你实际上可以上传数据集，它会尝试做诸如此类的事情。我认为这并不算特别成功。我的意思是，我不认为人们——人们会觉得这很有趣，但我不认为这是一个人们在现阶段真正关心的核心事物。这说得通。我的意思是，我认为在那里想出某种距离度量是极其困难的。就像如果有人给你一堆财务数据，而你只是将其投影到某个潜在空间中，
you'll end up with some distance metric, but it probably doesn't match their mental model. And things that you think are really close or really important actually aren't. Okay, so this, I mean, it happens to be something I've thought about a lot is the theory of interestingness. So in other words, if you've, so I've studied a lot kind of simple programs out in the computational universe, things like cellular automata and so on. And so you look at lots of these cellular automata and you say, which ones of these are interesting, right? You know, you look at them and some of them look, Oh, they, that's, that's kind of cool. you say, which ones of these are interesting? Right.
你最终会得到某种距离度量，但它可能与他们的心理模型不符。而你认为非常接近或非常重要的事情实际上并非如此。好吧，所以这个——我的意思是，碰巧是我经常思考的一个关于有趣性的理论。换句话说，如果你有——所以我研究了计算宇宙中的很多简单程序，比如元胞自动机等等。所以你看了很多这样的元胞自动机，然后你会说，这些里面哪些是有趣的？你知道，你看着它们，其中一些看起来，哦，它们，那——那挺酷的。你说，这些里面哪些是有趣的？对吧。
You know, you look at them and some of them look, oh, they, that's, that's kind of cool. You know, it does all these things, but which ones are interesting? Or you can do the same thing for chemicals, let's say. You can start enumerating possible, you know, hydrocarbon structures and you can say, which ones of these are interesting?
你知道，你看着它们，其中一些看起来，哦，它们，那——那挺酷的。你知道，它做了所有这些事情，但哪些是有趣的？或者你可以对化学物质做同样的事情，比方说。你可以开始列举可能的碳氢化合物结构，然后你可以说，这些里面哪些是有趣的？
So interestingness is a, is a very cultural kind of thing. That is what is interesting to somebody depends on, you depends on the whole history of how they got there. And for us as a civilization, when we say, well, what's interesting to invent? Or what mathematical theorems are worth proving? Those are things which are very history and context dependent. And in fact, it's really, so, okay, in my world as a language designer, here's a way to think about this. So, you know, you can imagine sort of concepts in the world and you could say, well, which ones of these concepts are interesting? You know, we see stuff, let's say, you know, in Stone Age or something, we saw, you know, I don't know, you know, different
所以有趣性是一个非常具有文化色彩的东西。也就是说，对某人有趣的东西取决于你，取决于他们如何走到这一步的整个历史。对于我们作为人类文明而言，当我们说，发明什么是有趣的？或者什么数学定理值得证明？这些都是非常依赖历史和背景的事情。事实上，这真的很——好吧，在作为语言设计师的我看来，这里有一种思考方式。所以，你可以想象世界上的某些概念，然后你可以说，这些概念里哪些是有趣的？你知道，我们看到一些东西，比方说，在石器时代或什么的，我们看到，我不知道，泥土中的不同裂缝或某种不同的水洼或诸如此类的东西。在某个时候我们决定，水洼足够有趣，以至于我们可以给它起个名字。因此，随着人类语言的出现，有人说，好吧，那个叫水洼。然后，人们可以讨论水洼，可以讨论湖泊，可以讨论其他有名字的东西，对吧？换句话说，这有一种凝聚力——呃，世界上这一堆东西凝聚成了一个足够有趣而被赋予名字的概念。没错，正如你所说，这确实是文化相关的，你知道，最常见的一个——大家都津津乐道的一个例子是爱斯基摩人对雪有大约 50 个词汇，这只是因为雪在他们的世界心理模型中占据了很大的位置，因为他们见得太多了，对吧？对，完全正确。但我觉得在——所以，好吧，一个语言设计师该做什么呢？一个语言设计师必须考虑，人们可能想要进行的所有计算是什么，其中存在着一种无限的集合。而如果你像我一样，研究可能计算的抽象空间等等，你就会意识到有更多这样的可能计算要做。
cracks in mud or something or different kinds of puddles or something like this. And at some point we decided, well, puddles were interesting enough that we would give them a name. And so as human language emerged, you know, somebody said, OK, that's called a puddle. And then, you know, people could discuss puddles and they could discuss lakes and they could discuss other things for which they have names right so in other words that there was sort of a a con um uh this sort of condensed this this cluster of things in the world condensed into a concept that was interesting enough to be given a name that's right and it's actually culture as you said it's culture dependent you know the the common um uh the one that everyone talks about is how eskimos have i think 50 words for snow and that's just because that that snow occupies a big
水洼足够有趣，以至于我们可以给它起个名字。因此，随着人类语言的出现，有人说，好吧，那个叫水洼。然后，人们可以讨论水洼，可以讨论湖泊，可以讨论其他有名字的东西，对吧？换句话说，这有一种凝聚力——呃，世界上这一堆东西凝聚成了一个足够有趣而被赋予名字的概念。没错，正如你所说，这确实是文化相关的，你知道，最常见的一个——大家都津津乐道的一个例子是爱斯基摩人对雪有大约 50 个词汇，这只是因为雪在他们的世界心理模型中占据了很大的位置，因为他们见得太多了，对吧？对，完全正确。但我觉得在——所以，好吧，一个语言设计师该做什么呢？一个语言设计师必须考虑，人们可能想要进行的所有计算是什么，其中存在着一种无限的集合。而如果你像我一样，研究可能计算的抽象空间等等，你就会意识到有更多这样的可能计算要做。
spot in their mental model of the world right because they see so much of it right right exactly but i think in in um and so okay so what does a language designer do well a language designer has to think about, you know, what are all the computations people might want to do, of which there is sort of an infinite collection. And if you, as I've done, you know, study the sort of abstract space of possible computations and so on, you realize there are even more of these possible computations to do.
问题是，这些计算中，哪些足够有趣到可以赋予它们名字，使它们成为你计算语言中的基元，并让人们以它们为单位来思考？这就是，我认为在元层面，语言设计师的角色是弄清楚，哪些是你应该定义为基元并用以构建语言的重复的计算工作块？对我而言非常有趣的是，当你构建了你的语言并确定了某些基元，并把这种语言交给人时，他们就会开始以该语言的视角来思考。
The question is, which of these are interesting enough to give them names, to make them primitives in your computational language, and to have people think in terms of them? And that's, you know, that I think is the sort of at a meta level, that is the role of the language designer, is to figure out, you know, what are the repeated lumps of computational work that you should define as primitives and build your language out of? And what's really interesting to me is that when you build your language and you identify certain primitives and you give people this language, they will start thinking in terms
因此，我认为 Wolfram Language 的成就之一是，多年来，通过该语言以及 Mathematica 等工具，许多东西被发明和发现了。虽然我无法量化它，但我认为其中相当大一部分之所以被发现，是因为我们为人们提供了一个关于事物的计算性质的思维框架，
of that language. And so one of the achievements, I think, with Wolfram Language is that lots of things have been invented and discovered with the language and with Mathematica and so on over the years. And I can't quantify it, but I think some significant fraction got discovered because we gave people a framework for thinking about things that was of a computational nature
并将其中的概念凝练成这些东西，凝练成作为语言基元的概念锚点。我认为，这种工作方式，它有点像一个有趣的螺旋，因为当你构建了某些基元时，你就会以不同的方式思考事物。而当你以不同的方式思考了这些事物之后，你就可以构建另一层基元。在文明的历史长河中，我们不断地在构建这些抽象层，其结果就是我们成功地将我们的概念凝练成了确定的事物，并为它们赋予了例如名字。这说得通。我的意思是，这就是为什么，如果你回溯历史——我可能在时间顺序上搞不对，
and that sort of condensed their kind of concepts into these things, into these kind of conceptual anchors that are the primitives of the language. And I think that that's, and so the way that works, it's kind of an interesting spiral because as you build certain primitives, you get to think about things in different ways. And when you've thought about those things in different ways, then you can build another level of primitives. And we're kind of continually in the history of sort of civilization, we're continually building these layers of abstraction as a result of having successfully sort of condensed our concepts into definite things that we give, for example, names to. That makes sense. I mean, that's why, you know, if you go back, I'm probably not going
但如果你回溯得足够远，你就会发现只有最聪明的数学家才能理解几何学。而现在，不懂几何学就拿不到高中毕业证书。这仅仅是因为，正如你所说，我们已经将它压缩了，我们已经把它变得如此内在、如此无意识，以至于它可以向所有人广播。是的，没错。我的意思是，我认为关于教育和文明发展史，人们可以思考的一点是，随着时间的推移，我们知道的东西越来越多。你可能会想，天哪，这意味着为了在世界上发挥作用，人们必须接受 100 年的教育，
to get this chronologically right, but if you go back enough, far enough, you get to the point where only the most brilliant mathematicians could understand geometry. And now you can't get a high school certificate without knowing geometry. And that's only because, as you said, we've compacted that and we've made that so innate and so unconscious that it can be broadcast to everybody. Yeah, that's right. I mean, I think one of the things that one can think about about education and the history of sort of development of civilization again is, you know, as time has gone on, we know more and more stuff. And you might think, oh, my gosh, that means we have to, you know, people have got to be educated for 100 years
因为有这么多的知识需要了解。但这种想法忽视了一个事实，那就是曾出现过一些统一和抽象的时刻，允许人们采用你刚刚描述的那种东西。你不必学习欧几里得中的每一个定理。你可以了解几何学的某些原理，这就能让你弄清楚很多事情，而不必经历每一个细节就能到达那里。但是，从语言设计的角度来看，计算语言设计中重要的事情，
in order to be sort of functional in the world because there's all this stuff to know. But the thing that that's ignoring is the fact that there have been these moments of kind of where these kind of moments of unification and abstraction that happen that allow one to take something like what you're just describing. You don't have to learn every, you know, you don't have to learn every theorem in Euclid. You can know certain principles of geometry, and that allows you to figure out a lot of things without having to go through every detail to get there. And that's, but, you know, the thing that's important about that from the point of view of language design,
其实是同一个故事。就像，你必须在语言中放入什么，才能为人们的思考提供一个框架，让他们能够利用这种抽象过程？就我而言，人们还不理解计算语言在塑造人们思考方式方面的作用。这是一件很有趣的事情，因为人们会谈论人类自然语言的萨丕尔-沃尔夫假设。该假设认为，你语言中的词汇决定了你的思维方式。人们会争论萨丕尔-沃尔夫假设有多大有效性，这到底是不是一个重要的因素，这是一个我认为在人类语言中真实存在，但在人类语言中却有些薄弱的东西。而在计算语言中，它是极其强烈的。也就是说，你思考的事物——我们在语言中发展出了一种思考方式。你可以看到，我了解我自己，我也能看到其他精通 Wolfram Language 的用户——我可以说使用者。这是一件很有趣的事。多年前，我碰巧拜访了一群当时大约 11 岁的小朋友，他们一直在学习 Wolfram Language，而且是非常聪明的孩子。那是我唯一一次听到有人真正说出我们的计算语言。对我来说这是一次非常怪异的经历，因为我发明了这种语言，但我却无法足够快地处理它。
computational language design, it's kind of the same story. It's like, what do you have to put into the language that gives people a framework for their thinking that lets them make use of this process of abstraction? And as far as I'm concerned, people don't yet understand the role of computational language in framing the way that people think about things. It's a funny thing because people talk about the Sapper-Whorf hypothesis for human natural languages. And that's the hypothesis that the words in your language define how you think about things. And people argue, how valid is Sapper-Whorf, and, you know, is it really a significant thing or not, and, you know, that's, they're a sort of, you know, it's a, I think it's a real thing in human language, but it's somewhat weak in human language. In computational language, it's extremely strong. That is, the things you think about, you know, we've developed in, you know, in language,
你知道，我只是不习惯听到它作为一种口语被说出来。这非常非常怪异。不过不管怎样，对我来说有趣的是，例如，当我试图思考某事时，我可以开始输入 Wolfram Language 代码的速度，远比我向你解释我要做什么的速度要快得多。所以这就是精通那种计算思维的感觉，而我们的计算语言就是一种
we've developed sort of a way of thinking about things. And you can kind of see that people, you know, I know for myself, and I can see with other people who are kind of fluent Wolfram Language users, I would say speakers. It's a funny thing. Years ago, I happened to visit this group of, I think they were 11-year-olds at the time, who had been learning Wolfram language and pretty smart kids. And that was the only time I've ever heard people actually speak our computational language. And it was a very bizarre experience for me because, you know, I invented this language, but yet I couldn't process it fast enough.
表达这种计算思维的方式，也就是说，这些想法可以说是在将要演变成该语言的事物周围形成的，而不是以一种我可以用人类自然语言表达然后翻译成计算语言的方式来形成想法。这说得通。那么，我的意思是，事情往往在朝着，比方说更多地走向这些——什么才是正确的词，比如信号处理或基于统计的方法，在这里你实际上并不知道任何原子级的东西。你只是把一堆数据扔进某个——你知道的，分层的某个系统、某个神经网络或某种东西中，
You know, I'm just not used to hearing it as a spoken language. It's very, very bizarre. But anyway, I mean, people, it's, you know, it's interesting to me that, for example, when I'm trying to think about something and, you know, I can start typing Wolfram language code much faster than I could explain to you what I can start typing Wolfram language code much faster than I could explain to you what I'm about to do so that's you know that's what it's like to be sort of fluent in that kind of computational thinking and with that with our you know computational language is a way of
它只是，你知道的，这种嵌入的组合，然后在另一端祈祷好运，对吧？是的。那么，随着这种趋势的发展以及人们希望自动提取信号，Wolfram Language 在其中处于什么位置呢？我的猜想是，它会提供一个非常好的基础函数或基础数据集，然后人们就可以去做好那种事情，或者也许——也许那些人完全错了，实际上——不，我不认为这是正确的思考方式。我的意思是，这就像我们使用的方式一样——所以很长一段时间以来，这些所谓的软任务——比如识别这大象还是茶杯的照片，对计算机来说是非常困难的。而且，现在
expressing that computational thinking is you know the the the thoughts are forming so to speak around what will emerge as that language, rather than the thoughts are forming in a way that I could express in human natural language, and then sort of translate into computational language. That makes sense. What about, I mean, you know, things tend to be moving towards, let's say more of like these, what's the right word, like signal processing or statistical based approaches where you, you don't actually know anything atomic. You just throw a bunch of data into some, some, uh, you know, layered some systems, some neural network or something that's
凭借现代机器学习，这变得相当容易。因此，传统上一直非常困难的这些软任务，现在已经变得可行了。如果看看这与 Wolfram Language 是如何交互的，你会发现我们恰好拥有一个相当棒的最高级机器学习框架，人们现在使用的这个东西恰好是我们构建在 MXNet（一个用于机器学习的底层框架）之上的。但是，它与 Wolfram Language 交互的方式是，有一个名为 ImageIdentify 的函数，该函数的内部使用了所有这些软神经网络的东西。
just, you know, this composition of embeddings and then you cross your fingers kind of on the other side right um yeah and so how does you know with with that sort of trending and and people wanting to sort of automatically extract signal where does wolfram language kind of fit into that my guess is it sort of would provide a very nice sort of basis function or basis set of data that then someone can go and and and do that that kind of thing or maybe maybe it's that no those people are totally wrong and really the yeah no that's i don't think that's quite the right way to think about it i mean it's the same as the way that we use so so for a long time these kind of soft tasks like identify whether this is a picture of an elephant or a teacup, those were very hard for computers. And, you know, nowadays
但归根结底，这就好比，好吧，我们拍摄一千张图像，并在所有图像上运行 ImageIdentify，然后我们开始制作直方图，统计这些图片中有多少只犀牛、多少只老鹰等等。换句话说，这些软东西成为了最终将要构建的这个宏大结构的各个元素。我的意思是，如果我们从人类工作的方式来考虑它，同样地，让我们假设这是一个法律合同。在法律合同的某处会写着，如果香蕉太熟了，它们将被拒绝接收。
with modern machine learning, that's rather easy. And so there are these tasks that had traditionally, these kind of soft tasks that had traditionally been very hard. And what's happened, you know, if you look at how that's interacting with orphan language, I mean, we happen to have a rather wonderful sort of highest level machine learning framework that people have right now happens to be the thing we built on top of MXNet, you know, which is a low level framework for machine learning. But, you know, the way that interacts withram language is there's a function called image identify, and the innards of that function make use of all of this kind of soft neural net stuff.
而“如果香蕉太熟了”就是一个软问题。周围的一整套连锁反应，然后它们将被拒绝接收，然后将发生这笔付款，将发生那笔付款等等。这全都是某种符号结构。我的意思是，我们从人类的行为方式来看，符号结构往往是我们倾向于在像这样的对话中用人类语言来表达的东西。但我们做的其他事情是——你在视觉系统中自动处理事情的方式，我们说，是的，我正在看一个水瓶什么的。这是在那个层面上发生的事情。现在，这里有一个有趣的权衡正在发生。因此，某些种类的任务，这绝对是正确的。一个真正好的方法就是你给它一堆训练样本。你让它学习。这很有趣。在机器学习的世界里，进行数据管理意味着什么？例如，我们有这个神经网络存储库。其重要性在于我们不在那里。我们学到的主要东西是特征提取器之类的东西。没错。
But at the end of the day, it's like, okay, we'll take a thousand images and we run image identify on all of them, and then we start making histograms of how many rhinoceroses and how many eagles were there in those pictures and so on. So in other words, these kind of sort of soft things become elements of what is then ultimately going to be this big structure that we build. I mean, if we think about it in terms of the way that humans work on stuff, again, let's imagine it's a legal contract. Somewhere in the legal contract, it will say, if the bananas are too ripe, then they'll be rejected.
所以，你知道，这是一个非常有用的管理片段。你知道，这是我们现在为图像拥有一个非常好的特征提取器，或者，或者为声音也获得了一个相当不错的特征提取器的部分原因。这反过来又允许我们计算很多东西。这是一种不同类型的数据管理。我的意思是，就像我们五六年前刚开始做现代机器学习的时候一样，我们拥有的巨大优势之一是我们非常擅长做数据管理。
And that, if the bananas are too ripe, that's a soft question. The whole chain of things around, then they'll be rejected, and then this payment will happen, and that will happen and so on. That's all sort of symbolic structure. I mean, we look at it in terms of how we as humans act, you know, symbolic structure is what we tend to represent, like in a conversation like this with, with our human language. But there are other things that we do that are, you that are the way that we automatically process things in our visual system where we say, yeah, I'm looking at a bottle of water or something. That's something that is happening at that level. Now, there is an interesting trade-off that's
所以，当面临这样的问题时：获取所有这些图像并弄清楚它们是什么，这不仅仅是“哦，我们将简单地在网上搜索看看它们有什么标签”。我们实际上拥有良好的流程，能够将一些人类知识注入到能够做到这一点的过程中。但我认为还有另一件事，那就是模型和事物之间的权衡。我的意思是，例如，机器学习是科学的终结吗？这是一个有趣的问题。换句话说，人们对物理学一直很感兴趣，比如，让我们理解、写出这个过程的某个理论模型，并通过这个理论模型来看看它有什么后果。这可以说是第一种方法。第二种方法是说，让我们只拿一堆例子，然后试着用机器学习来得出结果。例如，假设你正试图弄清楚你的洗衣机发出的声音。洗衣机是快要爆炸了，还是状态非常好？一种方法是使用像我们拥有的整个系统建模、系统工程系统。你实际上可以拥有某种洗衣机系统的工程模型，你实际上可以拥有某种洗衣机的工程模型，你可以尝试从中计算出共振频率并计算出振动等等，弄清楚
happening right now. So there's certain kinds of tasks where it's absolutely true. A really good way to do it is you just give it a bunch of training examples. You let it learn. It's been interesting. What does it mean to do data curation in a world of machine learning? So for example, we have this neural network repository. And the importance of that is that we are not there. The main thing we're learning is things like feature extractors. Right.
你的洗衣机会发生什么，或者你可以说，让我们只测量 10,000 台洗衣机，把它们全部扔进神经网络，看看会产生什么。这很有趣，我——我不确定我们在使用我们技术栈的人身上看到了什么。他们可以用它做这两件事。看到在过去几年里，有些事情的黑盒方法运作得非常好，而另一些事情的黑盒方法似乎并不起作用，这很有趣。你实际上需要了解发生了什么。
So, you know, and that, you know, that is a very useful piece of curation. You know, it is a piece of sort of the fact that we now have a really good feature extractor for images or, you know, or really good, getting a pretty good feature extractor for sounds, for example, as well. The, you know, that then allows us to compute a lot of things. And that's kind of a different kind of data curation. I mean, just like when we were first doing sort of modern machine learning stuff, maybe five, six years ago, one of the big advantages that we had was that we were very experienced at doing data curation.
是的，完全正确。这就是重点——我把它看作是三个层底层是“是什么”的问题；所以，你知道，这里有一台洗衣机，今天会发生什么？它会坏掉还是不会坏掉？所以你可以拿成千上万台洗衣机。你可以说这些今天坏了，这些没坏。我们有点抽样问题。比方说，拿几百万台洗衣机，你就能弄明白。而且，自动化方法在这方面变得越来越好。对吧。但如果你转向下一个级别，即“怎么样”的问题或控制、控制理论问题。所以我觉得，当你只在底层采用纯粹的自动化方式，然后试图在此基础之上进行控制时，就会变得非常困难，因为你实际上并不知道你在控制什么，因为这些信号实际上只是来自噪声。
So when it was a question of, okay, take all these images and figure out what they're of, it wasn't just, oh, we'll just search the web and see what tags they have. We actually had good processes for being able to inject some human knowledge into being able to do that. But I think there's another thing, which is sort of the trade-off between what is, you know, what's some, when do you have a model of things? I mean, so, for example, is machine learning the end of science? It's an interesting question. In other words, you know, one has been interested in physics, for example, in saying, let's understand, let's write down some theoretical model for this process, and let's work through that theoretical model and see what consequences it
你分不清这些数据和噪声的区别。你从中提取了信号，但现在你正试图基于此进行控制。而最顶层是因果分析。为什么我甚至要采取这个策略？为什么我甚至要基于这些信号来做这个控制器？当你做了太多的自动化、
has. That's sort of, you know, way number one for doing it. Way number two for doing it is say, let's just take a bunch of examples and try and machine learn the results. So for example, let's say you're trying to work out that sound your washing machine is making. Is the washing machine about to blow up or is it perfectly happy? Well, one approach you can take is to use like we have this whole system modeling, systems engineering system. You can actually have some sort of engineering model of your washing machine system you can actually have some some sort of engineering model of your washing machine and you can try and compute from it the resonant frequencies and work out vibrations and so on and figure out
在其中一个较低层做了太多的非结构化学习时，你最终会削弱或残废自己。你使得构建其上的上一层变得不可能。好吧，我的意思是，思考这个问题的一种方法是，如果你问，计算语言、符号语言是否存在某种角色，
what's going to happen to your washing machine or you can just say let's just measure 10,000 washing machines and throw it all into a neural network and see what comes out it's interesting I'm I'm not sure what we're seeing in people who use our technology stack. They can do both of these things with it. And it's interesting to see in the last few years, there are some things where, well, the black box method is working really well. Other things where the black box method just doesn't seem to be making it. You actually need to kind of understand what's going on.
还是我们应该把所有东西都扔进一个黑盒机器学习系统中？好吧，如果你看看人类和其他动物之间的区别，你就会明白符号语言的回报是什么。这就是我们与众不同的方式。是的，你可以让你的普通海狸或某种动物做许多我们可以期待做的事情，而不需要这种允许我们表达抽象事物等的符号语言的构建。有一个水平是你可以做到的，我们在最近之前一直无法用计算机妥善做到这一点，但现在这些成为了我们在人类发展中所构建的东西的组成部分，你知道，我们的文明是由这种符号语言的思想
Yeah, exactly. I's that's exactly it is you i look at it as sort of three layers the bottom layer is is is are what questions so um you know what you know here here's a washing machine uh what will happen today will it break or not and so you can take thousands of washing machines. You can say these ones broke today. These ones didn't. We have a bit of a sampling problem. Let's say take millions of washing machines and you can figure that out. And, you know, automated methods are getting very good at that. Right. But then if you move up the next level or kind of how questions or control, control theory questions. And so I feel as if when you do the pure automated way at the bottom, and then you try to do control on top of that, it becomes very difficult because you don't actually know what you're controlling because the signals are just effectively coming from noise.
以及能够表达抽象等思想的想法所促成的。从某种意义上说，这就是像我这样的人正试图在我们正在构建的计算语言中捕捉的东西。我的意思是，关于计算语言有趣的地方在于，它是一种更高层次的交流。换句话说，当——过去，你知道，生命最基本的交流水平是遗传的。你知道，你将某些信息传递给你的后代。然后有些事情是在每一代中自动学习的，比如你的视觉系统，从你在世界上看到的实际对象和相关性中学习。你的视觉系统，就像神经网络一样，学会了如何去看，可以说是这样。但是，你知道，我们物种的巨大创新在于，我们实际上能够利用思想的抽象符号表示，将东西从一代传给下一代。但是，我们仍然有点陷入困境，因为，你知道，一代人可以写书，下一代人可能会觉得，哦，我们看不懂这些书。当你和某人交谈时，就像你在大脑中形成想法，然后用人类语言表达这些想法。
You don't know the difference between that data and noise. And you've extracted signal from it, but now you're trying to control based on that. And then the top layer is causal analysis. So why am I even taking this policy? Why am I even doing this controller based on these signals? And you end up sort of kneecapping or handicapping yourself
但随后另一端的人必须在他们的大脑中做大量的工作来吸收该语言，使其适应他们的思维模式，以便在此基础上采取行动。就计算语言而言，非常有趣的一点是，我们不需要第二步。一旦我们用计算语言表达了某些东西，它就是可立即执行的。换句话说，我从人工智能世界的角度来看待这一点的方式是，我们不必——我们可以用人类自然语言与我们的人工智能交谈，我们可以试着说，是的，你知道，我们希望你做这个、那个和别的，
when you do too much automation, too much unstructured learning at one of those lower layers. You make it impossible to build the layer above it. Well, I mean, one way to think about this is if you ask, is there a role for kind of computational language, for symbolic language,
人工智能可以试着弄清楚人们在谈论什么，或者，如果一个人有一种好方法用精确的计算语言表达人类的目标，你只需说，好吧，这就是我希望发生的事情。现在，由人工智能来弄清楚如何以最有效的方式实现这一点，但你已经以精确的方式表达了你的目标。我的意思是，我认为——同样，从某种意义上说，自动化的作用是，人类定义——你希望发生什么，就是人类定义他们想要什么，然后尽可能自动地将其实施。但这其中的一部分是人类必须定义他们想要什么。而现在，随着计算和人工智能
or should we just throw everything into a black box machine learning system? Well, if you look at the difference between humans and other animals, you kind of see what the payoff is for symbolic language. That's the way in which we differ. Yes, you can get your average beaver or something to do many of the tasks that we can expect to do without this construction of symbolic language that allows us to express abstract things and so on. There's a level that you can do, which we were unable to do with computers properly until quite recently but now those become components in what you know in our sort of human development has been all the stuff we've built you know our civilization was made possible by this idea of symbolic language
等技术的发展，我们可以自动完成的事情范围非常广泛。这里有一个很大的焦点，那就是：你如何告诉——从某种意义上说，你如何告诉人工智能你想让它们做什么？这就是为什么我关心计算语言的原因，因为它为我们的远大目标、人类思维以及我们能让计算机、计算等做的事情之间提供了桥梁。这就是为什么，我认为它是人类文明发展轨迹历史上的一个相当重要的部分。这是我们现在所处的一个重要时刻，我们可以将非常广泛的事情自动化。问题只是在于说，你知道，我们到底想要什么？然后能够描述我们想要什么。这就是——我们有一个面向中学生的项目。
and by the idea of being able to express abstraction and so on. And that's, you know, that's in a sense what, you know, what someone like me is trying to capture in the computational language that we're building. I mean, what's interesting about the computational language is it's kind of another level of sort of communication. I mean, in other words, when, you know, back in the day, well, you know, there was, you know, the most basic level of communication for life is genetic. You know, you pass to your offspring certain information. Then there's things where sort of things are automatically learnt in each generation, like your visual system, you know, learns from the
据我所知，当时的标语是：谁来告诉人工智能该做什么？很好。我认为，这是一个关于教育以及人们应该学习什么的有趣话题。我的意思是，这种以计算方式思考事物的想法，你知道，这是这段历史时期真正重要的事情。我的意思是，21世纪是计算范式基本上接管一切的时代。是的，我想其中的一点是，我最近看到很多关于
actual objects and correlations it sees in the world. Your visual system, you know, just like a neural net, learns how to see, so to speak. But then, you know, the big innovation of our species is that we get to actually communicate stuff from one generation to the next, using sort of abstract symbolic representation of ideas. But still, we're kind of stuck because, you know, one generation can write the books, the next generation can be like, oh, we don't understand the books. You know, when you talk to somebody, it's like you form the thoughts in your brain, you express those thoughts in human language.
这些生成对抗网络（GAN）的研究，对吧？所以那里的想法是你想把事情投影到某个潜在空间中。这是过去十年或过去五年的重头戏，即这种组合嵌入以及它是多么强大。许多无监督方法被深度学习一网打尽，对吧？现在你看到了试图
But then the person on the other end has to do a whole bunch of work in their brain to absorb that language, to fit it into their thought patterns, to be able to take action on the basis of it. The thing that's pretty interesting in terms of computational language is we don't need that second step. Once we've expressed something in computational language, it is immediately executable. And so, in other words, the way I see that in terms of sort of the AI world is we get to, instead of just having to, you know, we could like talk to our AIs in human natural language, and we could try and say, yeah, you know, we want you to do this and that and the other,
逆转这个过程的方法，所以你会看到，例如，有人会使用 GAN 来生成源源不断的鸟类，你知道，这是我看到的其中一篇研究论文，或者例如，他们会使用 GAN 来逆转嵌入并从图片中生成文本描述。因此，测试集中有一张一个人坐在长椅上的照片，而训练集没有这张照片，但它有很多长椅和很多人，系统足够聪明，可以逆转该嵌入并创造出语言。但这是一个极其困难的问题。而且，与人们已经理解卷积网络和这些东西真正捕捉到了图像规则性的图像相比，我们还没有真正
and the AI can try and figure out what one's talking about, or one can, if one has a good way of expressing one's human goals in a precise computational language, and you just say, okay, here's what I want to have happen. Now, it's up to the AI to figure out how to make that happen in the most efficient possible way, but you've expressed what your goals are in a precise fashion. I mean, I think that the, you know, again, in a sense, the, you know, the role of automation is, you know, humans define, you know, what you want to have happen is humans define what they want, then it gets actuated as automatically as possible. But a piece to that is humans have to define what they want. And now that with computation and AI
为语言做到这一点。而且，研究肯定应该继续下去。但我认为一个替代方案可能是，在教育水平上，让人们以稍微不同的方式与计算机进行交流。这可能是唾手可得的果实，而不是试图对人类语言的整个历史进行逆转工程。不，不，我认为你是对的。我的意思是，我认为人类语言为人类之间的交流进行了体面的优化。你知道，计算机，你知道，我们在做这个生意。我们构建了整个自然语言理解（NLU）系统，它被用于 Wolfram Alpha 中，负责处理人们对手机或厨房里的圆柱体设备等说的随机事情。
and so on, the set of things that we can get done automatically is very broad. There's a big focus on, so how do you tell, in a sense, how do you tell the AIs what you want them to do? And that's, again, that's, you know, that's why I care about computational language is that gives us this bridge between our human goals and human thinking and what we can get computers, computation, and so on to do. And that's, you know, that's why, you know, I see it as being a pretty important thing in the history of developing the trajectory of human civilization. It's an important moment that we're at right now where we can automate a very wide range of things. The question is just to say, you know, what do we actually want? And then to be able to describe what we want. And that's, you know, that's the, we have a program for middle school kids.
而且，你知道，并试图理解这些。并且，你知道，对于简短的陈述，我们可以做得很好，但要构建一个完整的复杂故事，你可以做到，但这确实是一种相当愚蠢的做法，对吧？而且状态成了一个大问题，所以如果有人说——我的意思是，你听到这些——你知道，人们会展示这些例子，但它们总是非常刻意的。所以有人会说——你知道，谷歌在某亇时候展示过这一点，有人会说，你知道，几点钟，或者你知道，那个演员的电影是什么，他们会说，我不知道，黑豹。而这个人会说，那是几点？
And I think the tagline, last I knew at least, the tagline was, who's going to tell the AIs what to do? Nice. And it's, I think the, I mean, it's an interesting thing in terms of education and what people should be learning about. I mean, this idea of sort of thinking about things computationally is, you know, this is the really important thing of this time in history. I mean, we are, the sort of the 21st century is the time when the computational paradigm basically took over everything. Yeah, I think one of the things there is, I'm seeing a lot of research lately around
随后的查询将具有第一个查询的上下文。但它是如此的手工编写。你让一个系统以自动化的方式保持对话的状态。没有人能接近这一点，我们对作为社区取得的进展抱有如此高的期望，以至于这可能不是一个值得解决的好问题。好吧。我的意思是，这里有一个类比。所以在 500 年前，识字并不普遍。
these generative adversarial networks, right? And so the idea there is you want to project things into some latent space. That was sort of the big thing of, let's say the last decade or the last five years was this sort of compositional embedding and how powerful that is. And a lot of the unsupervised methods got kind of wiped out by deep learning, right? Now you're seeing sort of these approaches to try to
但是书面——人们不会读写。所以某些事情可以通过口头表达来表达。人们必须记住。他们当时可能更擅长背诵东西。但是，你知道，曾几何时，例如，如果你——在更久远的过去，就像律师一样，他们会读法律。有人会背诵——好吧，不是读。他们会背诵法律。他们知道每一条法律，他们只会背诵法律来决定某人是否在做正确的事情。然后当识字率出现时，它带来了更高水平的复杂性和丰富性。你可以创造出更多样化的东西，你可以写书，许多人可以阅读它们等等。我认为——你所指的——这个关于人类自然
reverse the process so you'll see for example um someone will use a gan to generate endless amounts of birds you know that was one of the research paper i saw or for example they would use a gan to reverse an embedding and generate a text description from a picture. So there's a picture of a person sitting on a bench that's in the test set and that the training set didn't have that, but it had a lot of benches and a lot of people and the system was smart enough to sort of reverse that embedding and create language. But it's an extraordinarily difficult problem. And, you know, as opposed to images where people have understood that convolutional nets and these things have really captured the regularity of images, we haven't really
语言是否适合表达某些类型的事情的整个问题，但在构建大型结构时，它并不是很好。如果你想象编写一些大型软件工程，其中的每一部分都是用人类自然语言编写的，那真的不会运作得很好。对此有几点要说。所以，我发现了一件非常有趣的事。所以，在我开始在 Wolfram Alpha 上工作之前，我从事 Wolfram Language 的工作大约有 15 年左右。Wolfram Language 是一种非常精确的语言。一切都经过精确定义，非常——万物皆有精确的含义。然后我开始在 Wolfram Alpha 上工作，那里的想法是人们应该只对它说话，万物皆有精确的含义。然后我开始在 Wolfram
done that for language. And, you know, definitely the research should continue. But I think an alternative might be, you know, at the educational level, getting people to communicate with computers in a slightly different way. That might be the low-hanging fruit there rather than trying to reverse engineer the entire history of human language. No, no, I think you're right. I mean, I think that the human language is decently optimized for humans communicating with each other. You know, computers, you know, we are in the business. You know, we built this whole NLU system that, you know, is used in Wolfram Alpha that's in the business of taking the random things that people say to their phones or their, you know, cylinders in their kitchens or whatever.
语言方面已经做过这些了。而且，你知道，研究绝对应该继续。但我认为另一种选择可能是，在教育层面上，让人们用稍微不同的方式与计算机交流。这可能是比较容易取得的成果，而不是去逆向工程人类语言的整个历史。不，不，我想你是对的。我的意思是，我认为人类语言对于人类彼此交流来说是经过相当好地优化的。你知道，计算机，你知道，我们正在从事这个行业。你知道，我们构建了整个NLU系统，你知道，它被用于Wolfram Alpha中，该系统致力于处理人们对手机或厨房里的圆柱体设备（或其他什么）所说的随机话语。
And, you know, and trying to make sense of those. And, you know, for small utter sense of those and and you know for small utterances we can do quite well for building up a whole complicated story you could do it but it's really a pretty silly way to do it now right and the state becomes a big problem so if someone says you know i mean you hear these these these um you know people will showcase these examples but they're always very contrived so someone will say uh you know google was showing this off at one point someone would say uh you know what time or or you know what's the movie with this actor and they would say i don't know black panther and the person would say what time is that and that
并且，你知道，试图理解这些。而且，对于简短的话语，我们可以做得很好，如果要构建一个复杂的完整故事，你可以做到，但这真的是一个非常愚蠢的做法，对吧，而且状态管理成了一个大问题。所以如果有人说，我的意思是，你会听到这些——人们会展示这些例子，但它们总是非常刻意的。所以有人会说——你知道，谷歌在某个时候展示过这个，有人会说——你知道，几点，或者，你知道，哪个电影有这个演员，他们会说我不知道《黑豹》，然后这个人会说那是几点，然后那
subsequent query would have the context of the first query. But it's so hand-coded. You're getting a system to keep state of the conversation in an automated way. No one's even come close to that, and we expected so much more progress than we've got as a community that that might not be a good problem to be solving. Right. I mean, so here's an analogy. So back 500 years ago, literacy was not common.
随后的查询将具有第一个查询的上下文。但它是如此手工编码。你要让一个系统以自动化方式保持对话状态。没有人能接近这一点，作为社区，我们对进展的期望远高于实际取得的成果，所以这可能不是一个好解决的问题。对吧。我的意思是，这里有一个比喻。在500年前，识字率并不普遍。
But written, you know, people didn't know how to read and write. So certain kinds of things could be expressed by, you know, spoken things. People had to memorize. They're probably better at memorizing things back then. But, you know, there was a time when, for example, if you, you know, longer ago in history, like with lawyers, you know, they would read the law. Somebody would recite, well, not read it. They would recite the law. They knew every law and they would just recite the law to decide what, you know, whether somebody was doing the right thing or not. Then when literacy came in, it enabled a much greater level of sophistication and richness. You could create things that were much more, you could write books and many people could read them and so on. I think that uh what your uh you know this this whole question about whether whether it's um uh human natural
但是书面，你知道，人们不会读写。因此，某些类型的事情可以通过口头表达来表达。人们不得不去记忆。他们当时可能更擅长记忆事情。但是，你知道，曾几何时，例如，如果你，你知道，在更久远的过去，就像律师一样，你知道，他们会宣读法律。有人会背诵，嗯，不是宣读。他们会背诵法律，他们知道每一条法律，他们只会背诵法律来决定，你知道，某人做的事情是否正确。然后当识字率出现时，它带来了更高水平的复杂性和丰富性。你可以创造出更丰富的东西，你可以写书，许多人可以阅读它们，等等。我认为，关于这个整的问题，无论是关于它是否是——人类自然
language is is good for expressing certain kinds of things but when it comes to building big structures it's not very good you know if you imagine writing some big doing some big piece of software engineering where every piece of it was written with human natural language it really wouldn't work very well now a couple of things to say about that. So one thing I found really interesting. So, you know, I've worked on Wolfram language for, what was it, 15 years or so before I started working on Wolfram Alpha. Wolfram language is very precise language. Everything is precisely defined and very, you know, there's a precise meaning to everything. Then I started working on Wolfram Alpha, where the idea is people should just talk to it there's a precise meaning to everything. Then I started working on Wolfram
语言在表达某些类型的事情方面很好，但当涉及到构建庞大结构时，它并不是很好。你知道，如果你想象编写一些大型的、做一些大型的软件工程，其中每个部分都是用人类自然语言编写的，那真的行不通。现在有几点要说明。所以，我发现了一件非常有趣的事情。所以，你知道，我在Wolfram语言上工作了，大概是什么，15年左右，在我开始在Wolfram Alpha工作之前。Wolfram语言是非常精确的语言。一切都被精确地定义，非常，你知道，每样东西都有确切的含义。然后我开始在Wolfram Alpha工作，这里的想法是人们应该直接对它说话，每样东西都有确切的含义。然后我开始在Wolfram工作
Alpha, where the idea is people should just talk to it and say whatever they want to say. And there's no documentation. It's just like, it's our job just to understand those weird things that humans say to it. Okay, so I decided to adopt a completely different design philosophy. So in Wolfram language, you know, one of the things is I want everything to be as consistent as possible. I want to minimize concepts. I want to have everything be sort of infinitely factorable and so on and so on and so on. For Wolfram Alpha, it's just a pure do what I mean type story. And it's just like deal with whatever crazy things the humans say, right? So those were two, it was interesting for me because those are two very different design methodologies. And I was, you know, it took me a me because those were two very different design methodologies.
Alpha 的理念是，人们只需要跟它对话，说出他们想说的任何话。而且没有任何文档。我们的工作就是去理解人类对它说的那些奇怪的话。好吧，所以我决定采用一种完全不同的设计哲学。所以在 Wolfram 语言中，你知道，其中一个原则是我希望一切都尽可能一致。我希望将概念减到最少。我希望所有东西都具有某种程度上的无限可分解性，诸如此类。对于 Wolfram Alpha，它完全是一种“明白我的意思”的模式。它就是去处理人类说的任何疯狂的话，对吧？所以对我来说，这是两种非常不同的设计方法，这很有趣。而且我，你知道，我花了一些时间来适应……
And I was, you know, it took me a little while to get used to the second one. But then, you know, I used to be very afraid of heuristics. I used to say never use heuristics. It's crazy. And then, you know, in Wolfram Alpha, it's all heuristics. It's like what does a human mean when they say, you know, 50 cents? Oh, they mean something about money. If they say 50 cent, they probably mean a rapper.
对我来说，这是两种非常不同的设计方法。而且我，你知道，我花了一点时间才习惯第二种。但是后来，你知道，我以前非常害怕启发式方法。我以前总是说绝对不要用启发式方法。这太疯狂了。然后呢，在 Wolfram Alpha 里，全都是启发式方法。比如当人类说“50 cents”时是什么意思？哦，他们指的是钱。如果他们说“50 cent”，他们可能指的是一个说唱歌手。
Oh, yeah. It's very, you know, but if they say 47 cent, you know, that's probably a mistake for 47 cent. So it's just all heuristics. Doesn't that, I mean, when you said that example, it made me feel sort of agoraphobic, right? I mean, it just sounds like there's an endless amount of, there's no end to the amount of things, the heuristics that you need to addoraphobic, right? I mean, it just sounds like there's an endless amount of, there's no end to the amount of things, heuristics that you need to add to the system, right?
哦，是的。非常……你知道，但如果他们说“47 cent”，你知道，那可能把 47 cents 打错了。所以这全都是启发式方法。难道不……我是说，当你举出那个例子时，让我有一种类似广场恐惧症的感觉，对吧？我是说，这听起来有无穷无尽的……你需要在系统中添加的启发式方法简直没完没了，对吧？我是说，这听起来有无穷无尽的……你需要在系统中添加的启发式方法简直没完没了，对吧？
Well, yes, that's what I thought, right? I thought, oh my gosh, the thing's going to drown in heuristics, right? But what I learned after a while is there's a logic to heuristics. And yes, there are lots and lots of them. I mean, it's a, for example, if you're into software quality assurance,
嗯，是的，我也是这么想的！我当时想，天哪，这个系统会被启发式方法淹没的，对吧？但过了一段时间我了解到的是，启发式方法也是有逻辑的。是的，它们数量非常多。我是说，这是一个……举个例子，如果你从事软件质量保证工作，
doing SQA on natural language understanding system is one of the scariest things you can do in that business because nothing is modular. The whole system, you can end up, if there's a new rapper who comes on the scene called 47 Cent, that just blew up a bunch of your NLU for financial transactions and so on. So it's a very weird thing.
在一个自然语言理解系统中做 SQA 是该行业中最让人头皮发麻的事情之一，因为没有任何东西是模块化的。整个系统，你可能会落得……如果出现了一个名叫“47 Cent”的新说唱歌手，这就会直接毁掉你的一大堆用于金融交易等的 NLU（自然语言理解）。所以这是一件非常诡异的事情。
But the point, you know, when in working on Wolfram Alpha, it was just this heuristics, you know, the logic of heuristics. Working on Wolfram Language, it's the sort of very precise, very sort of formal way of doing things. And I didn't know, you know, I thought these were two different branches. Very interesting thing happened a few years ago, when we started to basically build Wolfram Alpha capabilities into Wolfram language. What I realized is that there are little fragments of when you write code, and you need a list of the U.S. states, for example, you just say control equals list of U.S. states. That's a natural language. You hit return. It turns that into a precise symbolic representation of that that then becomes something precise that you can use in your program.
但关键是，你知道，在开发 Wolfram Alpha 时，全都是这种启发式方法，你知道，也就是启发式方法的逻辑。而开发 Wolfram 语言时，则是那种非常精确、非常形式化的做事方式。我当时不知道，你知道，我以为这是两个不同的分支。几年前发生了一件非常有趣的事情，当时我们开始基本上把 Wolfram Alpha 的功能内置到 Wolfram 语言中。我意识到的是，当你编写代码时会有一些小片段，比如你需要一个美国各州的列表，你只需要输入“control 等于美国各州列表”。那是一种自然语言。你按下回车。它会把这转化为一个精确的符号化表示，然后变成你可以在程序中使用的精确的东西。
And so what ends up happening is there are these little fragments of natural language that you use for things like that. You don't say, you know, map this pure function over this using natural language. That's a total lose. But you do say, give me the list of state capitals in the U.S. or something. That you can say with natural language. So there's this interesting sort of, you know of connection between these two things. I mean, it's worth realizing that the software engineering stack that you need to make all this stuff work is somewhat complicated because when you're dealing with, for example, the thing I just said, let's imagine you're mapping over some list of state capitals. Okay. That list of, and you're doing it in some, you know, version of Wolfram language that's sitting on your desktop computer.
因此最终发生的情况是，你会把这种自然语言的小片段用于诸如此类的事情。你不会用自然语言说，你知道，把这个纯函数映射到这个上面。那样做完全是吃力不讨好。但你确实会说，给我美国各州的州府列表之类的。这些你可以用自然语言说。所以这两种事物之间存在着一种有趣的、你知道的联系。我的意思是，值得认识到的是，为了让所有这些东西都能运行，你所需要的软件工程技术栈是有点复杂的，因为当你在处理时，举个例子，我刚刚说的那个，假设你正在对某个州府列表进行映射。好吧。那个列表，而且你是在你的台式电脑上运行的某个版本的 Wolfram 语言中做的。
That list of state capitals lives inside our knowledge base in the cloud. It has to, you know, it's a sort of language where things, you know, sort of it's a language where it can make use of this kind of vast pool of knowledge that exists in the cloud. It's downloaded, you know, sort of magically downloaded and cached and, you know, all those wonderful things. But it's sort of interesting that, again, that's a different kind of software engineering experience, so to speak, to what one might be used to with, oh, that's just a language
那个州府列表存在于我们云端的知识库中。它必须……你知道，这是一种语言，在这里，各种东西……你知道，这是一种语言，它可以利用存在于云端的那种庞大的知识池。它会被下载，你知道，就像施了魔法一样被下载和缓存，你知道，所有这些美妙的事情。但有趣的是，再次说明，与人们可能习惯的“那只是一种可以编译成机器码的语言”相比，这是另一种截然不同的软件工程体验，可以这么说。
and it compiles into machine code type thing. Yeah, it seems like that whole concept of, you know, I wonder if you need to, if it needs, if the programming language needs to be attached to this sort of common sense reasoning database, or maybe, you know, maybe they do have to be attached, but, but my guess is there's probably a large use case where somebody has, you know, because the vast majority of what, let's say someone's building an app, the vast majority of their app, um, is going to be written in a specific language. And that language is going to be designed around showing buttons and showing, you know, uh, sliders and things like that um but then they could take advantage of the capable
是的，整个概念听起来……你知道，我在想你是否需要……如果这个编程语言需要连接到这种常识推理数据库，或者也许，你知道，也许它们确实必须连接在一起，但我的猜测是，可能会有这样一个广泛的应用场景：某人拥有……因为绝大多数的……假设某人在构建一个应用程序，他们的应用程序的绝大多数功能，嗯，都将使用特定的语言来编写。而该语言的设计将围绕显示按钮、显示，你知道，呃，滑块和诸如此类的事情展开，嗯，但随后他们可以利用这些功能。
this this sort of knowledge database and this knowledge language it could almost like be embedded into sure any process that someone's doing you know that's the least less interesting way to do it okay Okay. All right. Yes, we have a great way of making instant APIs where people can call us just for little bits where they have figured out that we can do them.
这种知识数据库和知识语言，几乎可以嵌入到……当然，嵌入到人们正在做的任何流程中。你知道，那是实现这一点最不有趣的方式。好吧。好吧。是的，我们有一种很棒的方法来创建即时 API，人们可以只针对他们发现我们能够处理的那些小片段来调用我们。
What's much more interesting is to think about everything you're doing in this kind of very high level symbolic way. And because you get to do a lot more, like let's say you're laying out those buttons. Okay, well, we have a symbolic representation
更有趣的是，去思考如何用这种非常高级的符号化方式来做你正在做的每一件事。因为你可以做更多的事情，比如假设你正在布局这些按钮。好吧，我们拥有一个符号化表示，
for, you know, a user interface that's completely programmed, you know, that ever for the last 20 years or something has been a completely program manipulable thing. So it's something where, yeah, you could write, you know, hard code to lay out these buttons in this way, but you can have a symbolic structure
用于……你知道，一个完全程序化的用户界面，你知道，在过去 20 年或更长时间里，这一直是一个完全可以通过程序操纵的东西。所以它是这样一种东西：是的，你可以编写硬编码来以这种方式布局这些按钮，但你可以拥有一个符号结构，
that is, you know, computed with nice functional programming sort of on the fly that does that button layout. And being able to think about that, or you could say, you know, make the buttons be, I don't know, let's say a crazy thing,
它是通过精妙的函数式编程在运行过程中计算出来的，从而完成按钮的布局。能够这样去思考，或者你可以说，你知道，让按钮变成……我不知道，比方说一个疯狂的想法，
you know, let's say you want to, you're putting buttons to represent which city you want to go to next. Well, you can actually use geographic data to place the buttons in your interface. It's kind of a stupid idea. But, you know, the whole point is… It could be interesting. Maybe you have a spinning globe or something like that.
你知道，假设你想……你正在放置按钮来表示你想去的下一个城市。好吧，你实际上可以使用地理数据来在你的界面中放置这些按钮。这听起来有点蠢。但是，你知道，重点是……这可能很有趣。也许你有一个旋转的地球仪之类的东西。
Yeah, right. But, I mean, the point is being able to… The big thing with Wolfenlanguage is it's free to do fancy stuff. You know, with most… If somebody says, oh, by the way, I've got, oh, I'm going to have 10 cities and let me do a traveling salesman tour through those cities. And somebody says, oh my gosh, I got to figure out how to write this traveling salesman thing. Download a library. Sometimes library doesn't work.
对，没错。但是，我是说，重点在于能够……Wolfram 语言最大的优势在于它可以免费做一些很酷炫的事情。你知道，在大多数情况下……如果有人说，哦，顺便说一下，我有，哦，我有 10 个城市，让我通过这些城市进行一次旅行商问题巡游。然后有人说，哦天哪，我得弄清楚怎么写这个旅行商问题的代码。下载一个库。有时库还不好用。
Right. But the whole point is for us, it's free to do that stuff. It's just sitting there. It's just some function that does it. And by the way, you asked much earlier about sort of the trade-off between writing things in low-level languages and writing things in, you know, a knowledge-based language, you know, like Wolfram language. Here's what I found. You know, you imagine you were writing an algorithm. Let's say it's some, oh, I don't know, some numerical computation algorithm, and you're going to write it in a low-level language. But at some point in that algorithm, you say, gosh, if only I could do some algebraic analysis of what's going on, or if only I could use some piece of graph theory. Well, you don't do it if you're writing in a low-level language because it's just too hard to get that done. What ends up happening in our language and what's been probably the last decade or so, most of the algorithms that we've produced
没错。但关键对我们来说，做这些事情是免费的。它就在那里。它只是一些能实现该功能的函数。顺便问一下，你之前很久问过关于用底层语言编写代码和用基于知识的语言（如 Wolfram语言）编写代码之间权衡的问题。我发现的情况是这样的：你可以想象你在编写一个算法。假设它是某个……我不知道，某个数值计算算法，你打算用底层语言来编写它。但在这个算法的某个阶段，你心想，天哪，要是我能对正在发生的事情进行一些代数分析就好了，或者要是我能使用图论的一些片段就好了。好吧，如果你用底层语言编写，你根本不会去做，因为要搞定它实在是太难了。在我们的语言中最终发生的事情，以及过去十年左右的时间里发生的事情是，我们生产的大多数算法，
and we create a lot of algorithms, their building blocks are these very sophisticated things. And the fact that those building blocks are kind of freely available is critical to having a much more sophisticated level of algorithm than you could achieve if you were building it kind of from the sand. And by the way, the whole question of, is it efficient? The answer is, gosh, if you're doing, let's say, solving a traveling salesman problem or something, we have the world's best traveling salesman, you know, problem algorithms. You don't have to go, you know, if you were writing that from scratch, you'd never use the world's best such algorithms because it'd be a big pain
而且我们创建了大量的算法，它们的构建块都是这些非常复杂的东西。事实上，这些构建块是可以免费获得的，这对于实现比从零开始构建时所能达到的更高级别的算法至关重要。顺便说一句，关于它是否高效的整个问题，答案是，天哪，如果你正在做，比方说，解决一个旅行商问题之类的事情，我们拥有世界上最好的旅行商问题算法。你不必去……如果你是从头开始编写，你绝对不会使用世界上最好的此类算法，因为这会是一件非常痛苦的事，
to try and figure out how to do that. Yeah. And, you know, then the question is how good can our compilers be? And that's, you know, because that's the big, big thing. You know, back in the day, people used to say when I started doing computing, people would say, oh, you know, cause that's the big, big thing. You know, back in the day people used to say when I, when I started doing computing, people would say, Oh, you know, if you're doing something serious, you've got to write an assembly language. You know, these languages like C, they're, they're just, they're crazily inefficient. And, but of course,
去试图弄清楚该怎么做。是的。然后，问题是我们的编译器能有多好？这就是，你知道，因为这是非常非常重要的事情。你知道，在过去，人们曾经说……当我开始搞计算时，人们会说，哦，你知道……因为这是非常非常重要的事情。你知道，在过去，人们曾经说……当我开始搞计算时，人们会说，哦，你知道，如果你要做什么严肃的事情，你就必须用汇编语言来写。你知道，像 C 语言这样的语言，它们简直……它们效率极其低下。但是当然，
that's not true anymore because, you know, optimizing compilers typically will do better than a human writing. Most kinds, most humans in most situations. It's just not a good idea to write the assembly code yourself. Or even another way of looking at it is the limiting factor now is the person's time and energy. You know, the people, that's the commodity that doesn't scale. You can get a really large data center, but you can't necessarily take someone's mental model and replicate it to 10,000 people, right? Yeah, right. But I think more than that, and what happens, because we've built this kind of
情况已经今非昔比了，因为优化编译器通常会比一个在大多数情况下、由人类（绝大多数类型的人类）写出来的代码做得更好。自己去写汇编代码根本不是一个好主意。或者从另一个角度来看，现在的限制因素是人的时间和精力。你知道，人，才是无法规模化的宝贵资源。你可以拥有一个非常大的数据中心，但你不能把某个人的思维模型复制给一万人，对吧？是的，没错。但我觉得不仅如此，而且由于我们构建了这种……
language at a different level than people have tried to build languages before, what happens there is there's just much more stuff automated. So people who end up getting fluent in the language can just be much more productive. They can write. It might take five lines of orphan language code, or it might take 200 lines of some other language. But by the way, calling on five libraries that you then have to figure out, well, are they really going to work and so on and so on and so on.
这种语言处于人们以前尝试构建语言时所没有达到过的新高度，因此发生的情况是，有更多的东西被自动化了。所以那些最终精通这门语言的人可以变得极具生产力。他们可以编写代码。用 Wolfram 语言可能只需要 5 行代码，而用其他语言可能需要 200 行代码。顺便说一下，还得调用 5 个库，然后你还得去琢磨：它们真的能正常工作吗？诸如此类，没完没了。
So I completely agree. One of the things about orphan language is my original idea is pander to the humans, not to the computers. Back in 30 years ago or more, particularly when I was starting this, everybody was saying, oh, you have to make it easy for the computers. Back in 30 years ago or more, particularly when I was starting this, everybody was saying, oh, you have to make it easy for the computer. I'm saying, no, actually, make it as easy as possible for the humans. And the ultimate version of that is find a way for the humans as easily as possible to express what they want in computational terms. And then it's up to us, the implementers,
所以我完全赞同。关于 Wolfram 语言的一点是，我最初的想法是迎合人类，而不是迎合计算机。在 30 年或更久以前，特别是当我刚开始做这件事的时候，每个人都在说：“哦，你必须让计算机更容易理解。”在 30 年或更久以前，特别是当我刚开始做这件事的时候，每个人都在说：“哦，你必须让计算机更容易理解。”而我说：“不，事实上，应该让尽可能多的人类觉得容易才对。”这其中的终极版本就是：找到一种方法，让人们能够尽可能轻松地用计算术语表达他们想要的东西。然后就轮到我们这些实现者了，
to try and make that run as efficiently as possible. And, you know, it's lots of work. And, you know, like we're just building a very elaborate new layer of compilation technology to basically take this sort of very high level language representation of things and really, you know, turn into LLVM and, you know, really have it grind all the way down, so to speak. Yeah, that makes sense. I think so most people, let's say they have some system, maybe it's a service on the internet or maybe it's an app or it's a website or something like that, and so they can interoperoperate with with wolfram language but
去努力让它尽可能高效地运行。而且，你知道，这有很多工作要做。并且，你知道，比如我们刚刚正在构建一个非常精心设计的新编译技术层，基本上是为了把这种非常高级的语言代码表示形式真正地……你知道，转化为 LLVM，并真正让它一路“向下挖掘”，可以这么说。是的，这讲得通。我想所以大多数人，假设他们有一些系统，也许是互联网上的一个服务，也许是一个应用程序、一个网站或诸如此类的内容，所以他们可以与 Wolfram 语言进行互操作，但是
you're saying that that you know over time uh wolfram language can eventually be used to drive you know apps and uis and things like that yeah and it is right now i mean it's used in in lots of large-scale enterprise applications they are just running wolfram language code i mean they have some web server in the front end and and then behind it is, you know, let's say a private version of our cloud technology, and it's just running, you know, Wolfram language code. And that's, you know, there's lots of that. It's kind of always funny to me, you know, I go to, I don't know, you know, I go to a pharmacy and I pick up a prescription and I realize, oh my gosh, it's our technology that actually created, you know, the thing that I'm seeing
你是说，随着时间的推移，Wolfram 语言最终可以用来驱动应用程序、用户界面（UI）以及诸如此类的东西。是的，现在就是这样——我的意思是，它被用于大量的大型企业应用程序中。它们只是在运行 Wolfram 语言代码。我是说，它们的前端有一些 Web 服务器，然后其后运行的是，比方说我们云技术的私有版本，它运行的正是 Wolfram 语言代码。而且，你知道，有很多这样的应用。对我来说这总是挺搞笑的，你知道，我去……我不知道，你知道，我去药房拿处方药，我意识到，天哪，实际上正是我们的技术创建了……
here that went from, you know, the doctor's prescription, you know, written out to the kind of symbolic representation that's used to compute all kinds of things about, you know, multiple drugs or whatever, and to compute, you know, the schedule. And, you know, in the end, that label is probably, there's probably some piece of orphan language code that made that label, so to speak. It's a weird thing in the world because there's an awful lot of stuff now that, in the past, there was a lot of stuff where the R&D was done with our language. Now there's an increasing amount of stuff where the actual deployment is done with our language. Now there's an increasing amount of stuff where the actual deployment
我在这里看到的这个东西。它从医生开出的纸质处方，转化为了用于计算关于多种药物或其它任何东西的各种信息的符号化表示，并用于计算时间表。而且，你知道，最后，那个标签上……可能有一些 Wolfram 语言的代码制作了那个标签，可以这么说。这在世界上是一件很奇妙的事情，因为现在有大量的事情——在过去，很多研发工作都是用我们的语言完成的。而现在，越来越多的实际部署工作也是用我们的语言完成的。现在，越来越多的实际部署工作
is done with our language. But it's a strange thing. As a language designer, you realize, gosh, it's our technology underneath there. And it's like, and so what? I'm still standing in line picking this thing up, and it doesn't make any difference. I also find it interesting, the flip side of flip side of that, you know, I, I, I, I'm interested in sort of education. And we should talk about that a bit, because I think there's some, some, some worthwhile things to say about, about that. But, but so I end up quite often, you know, talking to groups of kids and things like that. And a lot of them use Wolf Malfa. And they kind of, you know, they notice my name, they know about Wolf Malfa, and there's this moment of surprise when they realize that there's a person who is connected to this thing that exists on the internet and that they use every day.
也是用我们的语言完成的。但这是一件很奇怪的事情。作为一名语言设计者，你意识到，天哪，底层竟然是我们的技术。然后就像是，那又怎样？我依然站在这里排队拿药，这没有任何区别。我也觉得很有趣，硬币的另一面是，你知道，我……我……我……我对教育很感兴趣。我们应该讨论一下这个，因为我认为关于这一点有一些非常值得说的话。但是，所以我经常（你知道）和孩子们交流等等。他们当中很多人都在使用 Wolfram Alpha。他们（你知道）注意到了我的名字，知道 Wolfram Alpha，当他们意识到世界上居然有一个人与这个存在于互联网上、他们每天都在使用的东西息息相关时，会有那么一刻感到惊讶。
That's right. There's a real building and set of people behind all of these websites. They're not just ephemeral. Right, right. And it's like there's a human, somebody decided to do this and somebody actually built it. Yeah, how is Wolfram Alpha answering questions when you're here?
没错。所有这些网站背后，都有一座真正的建筑和一群真实的人。它们并非转瞬即逝的虚影。没错，没错。这就好像有一个真人，有人决定要做这件事，并且真的把它造出来了。是的，你是怎么在现场让 Wolfram Alpha 回答问题的？
Yes, yes, yes, right. We did that as an April Fool gag at one point. We had a handwriting output from the thing and we had a whole backstory about that. Nice. But I think the, you know, in terms of sort of the educational aspects of things, I mean, this whole question about, you talked about, you know, what's the right way to do things?
是的，是的，是的，没错！我们曾经在某个愚人节恶作剧时做过那个。我们让系统输出了手写体，并且我们还为此编了一整段背景故事。太棒了。但我认为，你知道，就教育方面而言，我是说，关于整个问题——你谈到了，你知道，什么是做事的最正确方式？
Is the right way to have computers kind of come and understand human natural language or is the right way for humans to get to the point where they can express things in a more computationally precise way. And I think the thing, you know, I was talking about sort of the literacy transition 500 years ago. There will be another such transition and it will be a transition where people can, where the typical person understands computational language. and I like to think that the things I've spent much of my life building will contribute to that, that people will understand enough computational language that they can routinely express themselves
是让计算机来理解人类的自然语言，还是让人类能够达到用一种计算上更精确的方式来表达事物的程度？我认为，你知道，我之前谈到了 500 年前的识字率转型。将会发生另一次这样的转型，那将是一个普通人能够理解计算语言的转型。我喜欢认为我花了大半生时间构建的东西将为此做出贡献：人们将能够理解足够的计算语言，从而可以常规地用这种方式表达自己。
in that way. They can write that little contract. They can define, you know, the restaurant menu will be in computational language, and they can say, well, actually, I want to make a change to this. Let me, you know, change that piece of code, so to speak. That makes sense. It's sort of like solving a maze by, you know, beginning at the start and the finish and working your way to the middle. You know, if we make it way too open ended for the the people then there's just too much ambiguity um on the flip side we can't expect everyone to write c code um to order a hamburger right but there's probably a spot in the middle where where people think and act people interface with computers
他们可以编写那个小合约。他们可以定义，你知道，餐馆的菜单将采用计算语言，他们可以这样说：“嗯，实际上，我想对此做个修改。让我（可以这么说）修改那段代码。”这说得通。这有点像通过以下方式解迷宫：从起点和终点开始，然后一路通向中间。你知道，如果我们为人们提供过于开放的端点，那么就会有太多的歧义；另一方面，我们不能指望每个人都为了点一个汉堡去写 C 语言代码……但在中间可能有一个切入点，在这个切入点上，人们的思考和行动方式、人们与计算机交互的方式，
um with much more unconscious knowledge similar similar to right now, how we can use algebra almost unconsciously. And that will help the whole process tremendously. Right. No, I think that's, you know, as I say that, you know, language design is a curious kind of art because it isn't, it's not like, it's all about kind of trying to think about how people think about things. It's not like doing basic science where you are purely trying to do something abstract. And you have to be sort of, you have to be thinking about how does this relate to sort of what people care about, how people think about things, and so on. And I think in, you know, one of the things that's really neat right now is that, well, through the technology we built,
会带有更多无意识的知识——类似于现在，我们几乎可以无意识地使用代数一样。这将极大地帮助整个过程。没错。不，我认为那是……正如我所说的那样，你知道，语言设计是一种奇特的艺术，因为它不……它全都是关于试图去理解人们是如何思考事物的。这不像基础科学那样，你纯粹是在试图做一些抽象的事情。你必须……你必须去思考：这与人们关心的事物、人们思考事物的方式等等之间有什么关联。我认为，你知道，现在真正酷的事情之一就是，通过我们构建的技术，
the, you know, the world's fanciest, you know, research scientists and so on, you know, a very large collection of them use our technology to do their work every day. And it turns out that exact same technology is now perfectly accessible to middle school type kids who can learn to express themselves computationally in our language and who can, by the way, do things in the language that they immediately care about. So it's not just this kind of abstract exercise of, you know, write a program that sorts numbers or something. They can say, you know, let's take movie posters of, you know, the popular movies of the last year and let's find out whether red is becoming a more popular color or whatever it is. We always laugh about the, you know, if someone's applying to be a
世界上最顶尖的研究科学家等等，他们当中有很大一部分人每天都在使用我们的技术来开展工作。事实证明，完全相同的技术现在也完全可以被中学生使用，他们可以学习在我们的语言中用计算的方式表达自己，而且顺便说一句，他们可以在该语言中做他们真正关心的事。所以这不仅仅是一种抽象的练习，比如编写一个对数字进行排序的程序之类的。他们可以说，你知道，让我们拿去年的热门电影的海报来看看，然后找出红色是否正在变成一种更流行的颜色，或者诸如此类的事。我们总是取笑……如果有人申请成为
data scientist or, you know, which is basically Silicon Valley's version of just statistician, right? But if someone's applying for one of these roles, they'll do a coding interview where they'll have to sort a list or invert a binary tree or something like that. And it's kind of funny to see someone with, say, 20 years of experience, you know, inverting a binary tree and it's just kind of a running joke but but maybe maybe that's because there's sort of this inertia and maybe something better would be you know using a language that allows you to fetch a lot of information and solving a much more high level problem right right so i you know, a typical one that we've used a few times is, okay, you're given a lat-long coordinate on the Earth, and you're going to produce a map.
数据科学家，或者（你知道）这基本上是硅谷对统计学家的称呼，对吧？但如果有人申请其中一个角色，他们会进行编程面试，必须对列表进行排序、反转二叉树或类似的事情。看到一个有 20 年经验的人去反转二叉树，这有点搞笑，这只流传下来的一个笑话，但也许……也许这是因为存在某种惰性，而更好的做法可能是（你知道）使用一种允许你获取大量信息并解决更高水平问题的语言？对，对。所以我知道，我们用过好几次的一个典型例子是：好吧，给你地球上的一个经纬度坐标，你要生成一张地图。
There's a real problem in Wolfram Alpha. You're going to produce a map. What's the default map scale that you should use, given that you're throwing a particular lat-long coordinate on the Earth? Okay, if the lat-long coordinate lands in the middle of the Pacific, you obviously don't want to show a one-mile radius map. If the lat-long coordinate lands in the middle of Manhattan, you probably don't want to show a 1,000 kilometer radius map. And so the question is, what do you actually do? And so the answer might be, well, you look at the population density.
这是 Wolfram Alpha 中一个真实存在的问题。你要生成一张地图。鉴于你扔给系统的是地球上的某个特定经纬度坐标，你默认应该使用什么地图比例尺？好吧，如果这个经纬度坐标落在了太平洋的正中央，你显然不想显示一个一英里半径的地图。如果这个经纬度坐标落在了曼哈顿的正中央，你大概也不想显示一个一千公里半径的地图。所以问题是，你到底该怎么做？所以答案可能是，好吧，你看一下人口密度。
You look at the actual imagery in the map, you try and figure out density of that. That's kind of typical sort of computational thinking problem. And the whole point of our language is once you can define what you want, like you say, I care about population and people, I care about the entropy of the actual map features, or I care about, you know, you can invent lots of different kinds of things, then it becomes pretty easy to express those things and to, you know, try out your algorithm. And that's a very different kind of exercise than the typical kind of computer science, you know, sort of list type thing. It involves different kinds of thinking. And by the way, it's thinking which is not really taught much in a lot of computer science education. This idea of let's just think computationally about real problems in the world, that's not what ends up being in those computer science education, particularly at the K-12 level, is that it'll go the same way as things have gone with math. I mean, what happens with math, you know, most people's takeaway from studying math in school is, I don't like math. It's kind
你看一下地图中的实际图像，试着弄清楚其中的密度。这是一种典型的计算思维问题。我们语言的全部意义在于，一旦你能定义你想要的东西——比如你说，我关心人口和人类，我关心实际地图特征的信息熵，或者我关心……你可以发明许多不同类型的东西——那么表达这些东西并试运行你的算法就变得相当容易了。这与典型的计算机科学教育中的那种列表类型的任务有着截然不同的体验。它涉及不同类型的思考。顺便说一句，这种思考方式在许多计算机科学教育中并没有真正被教授。这种让我们仅仅针对世界上的真实问题进行计算思考的想法，最终并没有出现在那些计算机科学教育中，特别是在 K-12（基础教育）阶段。我认为它会重蹈数学的覆辙。我的意思是，数学教育会发生什么，你知道，大多数人从学校学习数学中得出的结论是：我不喜欢数学。它有点
of boring. It's very, you know, it's intricate, it's mechanical, it's kind of, why do I care? Like, I've asked many kids of, you know, with quite, you know, quite sophisticated kids. I say the math you've learned in school, have you used it anywhere? And they're like, well, uh, well, uh, no. And that's, you know, that's kind of, so they learned it as a, oh, well, I've got to, you know, do my algebra, calculus, whatever. And I'm doing that as a as a sort of separated abstract thing and it's it's something where i'm i'm going through the mechanics of it i'm learning how to factor a polynomial how to do an integral whatever that's like to the horror
无聊。它非常……你知道，它很繁琐，很机械，而且有点像：我为什么要关心？比如，我问过很多孩子，你知道，相当……相当聪明的孩子。我问他们：“你们在学校里学的数学，在什么地方用过吗？”他们会说：“嗯，呃……嗯，呃……没有。”这就是，你知道，这就是那种情况……所以他们学它只是为了：哦，好吧，我得……你知道，搞定我的代数、微积分，诸如此类。我这样做就像是在经历一个相互隔离的抽象事物，这是一个我要经历其运作机制的过程：我正在学习如何对多项式进行因式分解，如何求积分，诸如此类。这简直令……
of particularly one of my kids yeah one of the things that that cracked me up when i was taking the sat as a teenager was was there was a question where somebody had 17 watermelons and they were at a grocery store and the answer ended up being 17. And it was just, I found that hilarious because I just pictured this person with 17 watermelons, you know, in a shopping cart in a grocery store. And that is the stereotypical math problem. It's just, you know, even in that environment where you had every opportunity to put, I don't know, something, I don't know, bottles of water or something. But they chose something even more absurd than that. And it just shows how disconnected it is from anything real.
特别是我的一个孩子感到惊恐。是的。我十几岁时参加 SAT 考试时，有一道题把我逗乐了，题目是这样的：有人在杂货店里有 17 个西瓜，最后算出来的答案竟然是 17。我当时觉得这太搞笑 L，因为我脑海中浮现出这个人推着一辆购物车，里面装着 17 个西瓜（你知道）在杂货店里的画面。这就是那种典型的数学应用题。它只是，你知道，甚至在那种环境下——你本有无数次机会去放一些，我不知道，某种东西，我不知道，比如瓶装水之类的东西。但他们偏偏选择了一个比这还要荒谬的东西。这正好说明了它与现实生活是多么地脱节。
Right. I mean, look, I think that the, a couple of comments about that, but I think, you know, programming, low-level programming, I think is the enemy of computational thinking in education. That is, if what you do is teach people how to write quicksort, you are, maybe you don't even get to that level, but, you know, if you write them, if you teach them how to, I don't know. Do a for loop or something. Yes, right.
对。我是说，听着，对此我有几点评论，但我认为，你知道，编程，底层编程，我认为它是教育中计算思维的敌人。也就是说，如果你所做的只是教人们如何编写快速排序（quicksort），你就是在……也许你根本达不到那个水平，但是，你知道，如果你教他们如何……我不知道。写一个 for 循环或者诸如此类的事。是的，没错。
You know, most people will find that kind of boring. Some people who might go on to be systems programmers will find that super interesting. And that's great. And, you know, but most people, just like all those people who won't go on to be pure mathematicians, and who find a lot of the you know algebra stuff kind of boring will will similarly be turned off computation by being fed this kind of very you know uh very low level kind of why do i care type stuff and i think you know computer science education has gone through about four waves over time you know the the basic wave, which was one of the better ones, by the way, and then a series of other waves. And, you know, it, you know, one of the things that, you know, I put a fair amount of effort into, although education is such a fragmented area, it's so hard to, to know, really, you know, to, to, to, well, it's easier in smaller countries, actually, where there's more central kind of decision making. But in a country like the U.S., it's really hard to, you know, to sort of put effort and get commensurate returns. But it's, you know, this thing about, okay, let's teach computational thinking and let's teach it by having people be able to sort of form computational ideas and then make it up to the job of the implementers like us to make it so that, you know, what the kids, you know, to make it as easy as possible for the kids to getting the syntax wrong, that's not because the kids are stupid, it's because we haven't given the right
你知道，大多数人会觉得那很无聊。少数会继续成为系统程序员的人会觉得那超级有趣。那很棒。并且，你知道，但是大多数人，就像那些不会去成为纯数学家、并且觉得很多……你知道的代数东西很无聊的人一样，他们同样会因为被喂食这种非常……你知道，呃，非常底层的“我为什么要关心”这类东西而被对计算拒之门外。我认为，你知道，计算机科学教育随着时间的推移已经经历了大约四次浪潮，你知道，最初的那波浪潮，顺便说一句，是较好的浪潮之一，然后是一系列其他的浪潮。而且，你知道，它……你知道，我投入了相当多精力的其中一件事是——尽管教育是一个如此碎片化的领域，很难真正去知道，你知道，去……嗯，其实在较小的国家里反而更容易一些，因为那里有更多中央集权式的决策。但在像美国这样的国家，想要投入精力并获得相应的回报真的是难上加难。但这是一种……你知道，关于这件事：好吧，让我们教授计算思维，并且通过让人们能够形成计算理念来教授它，然后让像我们这样的实现者去完成那些工作，以便确保……你知道，孩子们所做的事情……为了让孩子们尽可能轻松地避免语法错误，这并不是因为孩子们笨，而是因为我们没有提供正确的
user assistance prompts to make sure that they don't get the syntax wrong. I think it's the, whereas in math, you don't get to do that. You don't get to have somebody thinking about how do we provide algebra is algebra, and you don't get to say, oh, let's, we're trying to automate this as much as possible so that the humans just have to do the real thinking part.
用户辅助提示来确保他们不会犯语法错误。我认为，相比之下，在数学中，你没有这种待遇。你不会有人去思考我们如何尽可能地实现自动化，从而让人类只需去做真正需要思考的部分。
It's just like, well, no, actually you have to, you know, add, you know, X and X and get to X and all that kind of thing. And then you have to do that yourself. And I think, so, you know, I think there's an important thing that happens in education there education there i mean it's for me it's it's interesting we we um uh so we we run a um uh summer camp for high school students and we also have a summer school for sort of grown-ups that we've been doing now for 16 years um that uh uh where people come and you know do some original project that's never been done before. And they've often never done a project where you go from sort of nothing and actually create something. And it's really great.
情况更像是：不，实际上你必须……你知道，把 X 和 X 相加，得到 2X，诸如此类。然后你必须自己去做这些。所以，你知道，我认为教育中发生了一件重要的事情……我的意思是，对我来说，这很有趣，我们……我们……所以我们为高中生举办了一个夏令营，我们还为成年人举办了一个夏令营，这个我们已经连续办了 16 年了……人们会来这里做一个从未做过的原创项目。而且他们通常从来没有做过那种从一无所有到真正创造出东西的项目。这真的很棒。
With the tools that we have now, there's an awful lot of low-hanging fruit out there. I mean, there's an awful lot of stuff where using, you know, using our language, using the whole sort of computational paradigm, there are things that people can do. You know, a high school kid can come in and in two weeks actually produce something really, really, really neat. You can, you know, there's a website with all kinds of projects on it that kids have done. But, you know, that's something that is, you know, it's a thing of our times that that's possible. And I think that I find it particularly, you know, for me, it's particularly cool to see that, you know, these kids are able to make use of the same tools that kind of the fanciest, you know, research scientists are using. And they're able to go find
凭借我们现在拥有的工具，外面有大量触手可得的低垂果实。我是说，有大量的事情，通过使用……使用我们的语言，使用整个计算范式，人们可以做很多事情。一个高中生可以来到这里，在两周内真正创造出一个非常非常酷的东西。你可以，你知道，有一个网站上面展示了孩子们做过的各种各样的项目。但是，你知道，那是我们这个时代特有的现象，这是可能的。而且我认为我发现这特别……对我来说，看到这些孩子们能够利用最顶尖的研究科学家们正在使用的同款工具，这真是酷极了。并且他们能够去发现
things that, you know are are interesting new things so to speak yeah let's talk about about that for a minute on the accessibility side so so this is something we actually haven't mentioned on the show but um the vast majority of languages are just you know completely public open source and and totally accessible and the way that the people who put their time and effort into those languages support themselves is usually through some type of enterprise contract. So for
那些……你知道，有趣的新事物，可以这么说。是的，我们花一分钟来谈谈关于可访问性的问题。所以这是我们在节目中实际上还没有提到过的一点，但是，嗯，绝大多数语言都只是（你知道）完全公开的开源代码，完全可访问的。那些将时间和精力投入到这些语言中的人支持他们自己的方式，通常是通过某种类型的企业合同。所以，例如
example Java becomes really popular Java's probably not a good example Let's say Python It's an example of the disaster of what you're describing yeah it's like i immediately regret my decision uh this is a python it's really popular um you know anyone can go and download the source code and look at all of it so in a sense the intellectual property
比方说 Java 变得非常流行——Java 可能不是一个好例子。我们就说 Python 吧。这是你所描述的灾难的一个例子。是的，就像我立刻后悔了自己的决定。这是一个 Python，它非常流行……你知道，任何人都可以去下载源代码并查看所有这些东西。所以从某种意义上说，知识产权
is is is you know the value there is questionable but you know, some enterprise customer starts using it. And now they need to reduce their risk because they have a risk of something bad happening, you know, with their system. That's a fault of Python itself. And so to reduce their risk, they spend money. And that's really what keeps that whole process moving. Now, I know for Mathematica, and I have it to be totally fair, I kept totally up to date on Wolfram language. But I know for Mathematica, it's similar to MATLAB in the sense that it costs money to sort of even enter and start using it. And so how does that work? If someone's a student, how do they get started? And sort of what's sort of, I guess, the business model to some degree?
就是……你知道，其中的价值是值得怀疑的。但是，你知道，一些企业客户开始使用它。现在他们需要降低风险，因为他们的系统有发生坏事的风险。那是 Python 本身的问题。因此为了降低风险，他们花钱。这才是真正推动整个过程不断前进的动力。现在，我知道对于 Mathematica 来说——而且为了绝对公平起见，我一直紧跟 Wolfram 语言的最新进展——但我知道对于 Mathematica 来说，它类似于 MATLAB，即它需要花钱才能进入并开始使用它。那么这到底是怎么运作的呢？如果有人是个学生，他们该如何开始？以及它的商业模式在某种程度上到底是怎样的？
And how does that sort of work operationally? Right. I mean, so, you know, I've been interested my whole life in kind of threading the needle of figuring out how to do the most interesting, innovative stuff for the world and have that be sustainable over the long term. Okay. and innovative stuff for the world and have that be sustainable over the long term. And I think I'm not doing too badly in the sense that we've been able to consistently be building a technology stack for the last 32 years. It's interesting that when I started this, the first company, the first thing I built,
它在运营上是如何运作的？没错。我是说，你知道，我一生都对如何在“为世界做最有趣、最具创新性的事情”与“确保其长期可持续性”之间走钢丝很感兴趣。好吧。为世界做最具创新性的事情，并使其长期可持续。而且我认为我做得还算不错，因为在过去的 32 年里，我们一直能够持续地构建一个技术栈。有趣的是，当我开始做这件事时，第一家公司，我构建的第一件事，
I was originally going to sort of do the open source thing. I realized, gosh, there's no way to start this. It was in 1981. There's no way to support this. I have to start a company. I started a company of a certain kind, you know, venture capital funded and so on. That didn't work out that well. I mean, the company eventually did an IPO and did okay, but, you know, it didn't work out well in terms of having a long term sustained vision. For the last 32 years, I've been pretty lucky in that I have a smallish private company, only 800 people, mostly R&D folk, and we've been able to keep innovating and building things. Now, the problem that we have, namely, build this huge
我最初打算搞开源那套。后来我意识到，天哪，根本没法以此起步。那是 1981 年。根本没有办法维持。我必须创办一家公司。我创办了一家特定类型的公司，你知道的，有风险投资资金支持等等。那并没有取得太大的成功。我是说，这家公司最终进行了 IPO 并且表现尚可，但在维持长期的、可持续的愿景方面，它并没有取得好结果。在过去的 32 年里，我一直非常幸运，因为我拥有一家规模不大的私营公司，只有 800 人，其中大部分是研发人员，我们一直能够不断创新和构建事物。现在，我们面临的问题，也就是构建这个拥有万物的大型
computational language that has everything in it, it's not just one of these, oh, I'm going to spend the weekend and come out with a new language and throw it out on GitHub type thing. It's a thing which is a sustained, in this case, 32-year story. And it's a story where I was pretty pleased in the 30th anniversary of Mathematica. I thought, oh, let me see whether I can take code that I wrote 30 years ago, and there it was on an original Mac, and I get it off with floppies and things like that. I take this code. This was just a few months ago. I take this code.
计算语言，它可不是那种“我打算花个周末搞出一个新语言然后扔到 GitHub 上”的随性之作。这是一个持续的、在这个案例中长达 32 年的故事。这是一个让我感到非常欣慰的故事——在 Mathematica 30 周年之际，我在想，哦，让我看看能不能找到我 30 年前写代码，它保存在一台最初的 Mac 上，我是通过软盘之类的东西把它找出来的。我拿到了这段代码。这就在几个月前。我拿到了这段代码。
With great effort, I get it off the floppy and onto a modern computer, and by golly, it just runs in the latest version of orphan language. That's cool. We have 30 year compatibility and, and, you know, people, a lot of people in sort of the research world really appreciate this. I mean, they, you know, they have stuff that they did, you know, 25 years ago and it just works. And, you know, I think that the, um, the idea that, so, you know, my main goal has been sort of thread the needle of being able to do sustained innovative work for a long period of time and try and deliver something valuable to the world while
我费了好大劲，才把它从软盘转存到现代电脑上，天哪，它竟然能在最新版本的那个被遗弃的语言里直接运行。这太酷了。我们拥有了30年的兼容性，而且，你知道，研究界很多人非常赞赏这一点。我的意思是，他们知道，他们25年前做过的一些东西现在依然能直接运行。而且，你知道，我认为，呃，这种想法——所以，你知道，我的主要目标一直是走一条钢丝，即能够在很长一段时间内进行持续的创新工作，并尝试为世界交付有价值的东西，同时
letting as many people as possible use it and have the ecosystem work. And, you know, we've done a variety of different things. So, for example, you know, basically every major university in the U.S. least, and most around the world has a site license for our technology. So for anybody at a university, it's free. The university is effectively paying an enterprise license, but that means every individual student and so on gets it for free. Nice. So they put in their EDU email address or something like that? Yeah.
让尽可能多的人使用它，并使生态系统正常运转。而且，你知道，我们做过各种不同的尝试。所以，举个例子，你知道，基本上美国至少每一所主要大学，以及世界上的大多数大学，都拥有我们技术的校园许可。因此，对于大学里的任何人来说，它都是免费的。大学实际上是在支付企业许可，这意味着每个学生等等都可以免费使用它。太棒了。所以他们输入自己的EDU电子邮箱地址之类的吗？是的。
I mean, supposedly the universities have ways that they distribute all these things. But yes, and that's basically what happens. And, you know, now Wolfram Alpha, the main Wolfram Alpha is just free to the world. There's a version, there's a pro version that students, some students, well, a lot of students, end up getting because it has some additional capabilities like showing steps and so on for computations. But Wolfram Alpha, the idea was just make it free for the world. Now, then, obviously, we have an API that's what gets used by folks like Apple and Amazon and so on. And we have enterprise versions and all this kind of thing. But that's one model. Now, in terms of Wolfram language, it's sort of interesting, actually. belief that one wants to have the source of funding for something be as aligned as possible
我的意思是，按理说大学有他们分发所有这些东西的渠道。但确实如此，基本上就是这样。而且，你知道，现在Wolfram Alpha，主要的Wolfram Alpha对全世界都是免费的。有一个版本，有一个专业版，学生们——一些学生，嗯，很多学生，最终会选择购买，因为它具有一些额外功能，比如显示计算步骤等等。但Wolfram Alpha的初衷就是让全世界免费使用它。现在，很明显，我们有一个API，这是供苹果、亚马逊等公司使用的。我们还有企业版以及所有这类东西。但这只是一种模式。现在，就Wolfram语言而言，其实挺有趣的。坚信人们希望为某事物寻找资金来源时，其来源能尽可能地与
with where the value is going, so to speak. So in other words, it's like the people who are actually going to use this seriously should be, if they believe in it and they're going to pay for it, then I want, and I don't want something where it's like, well, we'll make a free version, but we're really going to make our money off support. So let's not make the free version too good. Let's make the thing a little bit cockeyed so that we can make money from support, which is unfortunately what's happened. Or let's make everything free and get a lot of people to use it and then say, oh, whoops, we got some patents on this. You have to pay up lots of money because you're using our patents. Yeah, especially when it comes to documentation. I mean, it's like every line of documentation that you provide with your open source language is literally taking revenue away from your business
价值流向保持一致，可以这么说。换句话说，这就好比真正要认真使用它的人，如果他们坚信它的价值并且愿意为此付费，那么我希望——而且我不希望出现那种“嗯，我们会做一个免费版，但我们真正赚钱靠的是技术支持。所以别把免费版做得太好，把它搞得有点别扭，这样我们才能从技术支持赚钱”的情况，而这恰恰是不幸发生的事情。或者让一切都免费，吸引大量人使用，然后说：“哎呀，我们在这上面申请了一些专利。你们得付一大笔钱，因为你们在使用我们的专利。”是的，特别是涉及到文档的时候。我的意思是，你为开源语言提供的每一行文档，简直都是在剥夺你商业模式的收入，
model, which is to support people who are trying to use undocumented code. Yeah, I mean, look, my point of view is, I just want, I mean, you know, I've tried to operate in a sense, a very sort of, you know, a straightforward business, so to speak. I mean, you know, what we try to do is, you know, continue to innovate and produce the best language we can. Of course, the fact that we're doing this in an ultimately commercial way allows us to make use of all these data sources and all these other kinds of things, which there's no way they would say. If we said, oh, we're going to give everything away to everybody, they'd say, well, you can't give our stuff away,
而你的商业模式正是去支持那些试图使用未公开代码的人。是的，我的意思是，听着，我的观点是，我只是想——我的意思是，你知道，我一直试图以某种意义上非常直接的商业方式运作，可以这么说。我的意思是，你知道，我们试图做的是，不断创新并生产出我们所能做出的最好的语言。当然，我们最终以商业方式来做这件事的事实，使我们能够利用所有这些数据源以及所有其他各种类型的数据，而这些数据源是绝对不可能同意的。如果我们说“哦，我们要把所有东西免费送给所有人”，他们就会说“那你们可不能把我们的东西送人，
so forget having financial data or something. It's part of the ecosystem that one has to have everybody. It has to be a sort of thing. The other thing is, there's the question of how do you maintain coherence? That's been my personal commitment, so to speak, for the last three decades or so, is actually try and keep this language consistent and do unified development. I think, like Python, I gather, recently had trouble with that because it's like by the time, if, you know, in our case, I'm, you know, in a position where I'm actually trying to lead this. Now, there's the question of source code.
所以别想获取金融数据之类的信息”。这是生态系统的一部分，每个人都必须参与其中。它必须是这样一种事物。另一件事是，如何保持连贯性的问题。这就是我个人的承诺，可以这么说，在过去的三十年左右里，我实际上一直在努力保持这门语言的一致性并进行统一开发。我想，就像Python一样，我听说它最近在这方面遇到了麻烦，因为如果到了那个时候，如果，你知道，在我们的案例中，我，你知道，处在一个实际上正试图主导这一切的位置上。现在，这里有个关于源代码的问题。
I actually don't really care whether, you know, I mean, our source code isn't sort of publicly out on the internet that's you know that's not something i care that much about and i don't think anybody else cares that much about it either yeah you know actually for a decade we actually had a large chunk of code source code out you know freely available and um the thing that was really funny was and you know we were doing this because we thought, oh, people are going to be interested in all these mathematical algorithms. Isn't that cool type thing? It turned out when we finally did a sort of an assessment, did anybody care? We discovered that a large swath of comments in the code were in Russian. It happened that the people who were working on it were the people
我其实并不在乎，你知道，我的意思是，我们的源代码并没有公开放在互联网上——你知道的，这不是我那么在乎的事情，而且我觉得其他人对此也不是那么在意。是的，你知道，其实有十年时间，我们确实有很大一部分代码——源代码是公开的，你知道，可以自由获取的，而且，呃，真的很有趣的一点是，你知道，我们这样做是因为我们觉得，“哦，大家会对所有这些数学算法感兴趣。这不是挺酷的吗？”结果当我们最后做了一个评估，看看有没有人在意时，我们发现代码中的很大一部分注释竟然是俄语的。碰巧的是，那些致力于此的人就是以俄语为母语、为我们开发这些东西的人，这就好像整整十年都没人看它，我们把它放到了网上，却没有人看，因为有人说：“哎呀，你们的注释是俄语的。”我认为开源模式
who natively speak Russian who work on this stuff for us and it's like nobody read this for a decade we had it out there, nobody read this because somebody said oops, your comments are in Russian I think the open source model
在底层时是有意义的，比如操作系统，你知道，如果操作系统不是开源的，那么就会担心，你知道，有一天我可能无法使用我的鼠标之类的。你总是可以编写一些接口驱动程序。但对于像Mathematica这样的软件，我赞同。我的意思是，如果让我猜的话，我会猜源代码没那么重要。更重要的是有人能将Wolfram语言融入他们的流程中。没错。
makes sense when it's low level, so for example an operating system, you know, if his operating system is not open source, then there's a worry that, you know, I won't be able one day I won't be able to use my mouse or something like that. You could always write some interface driver. But for something like Mathematica, I agree. I mean, if I had to guess, I would guess that the source code is less important. What's more important is that somebody can make Wolfram language a part of their process. Right.
是的。没错。所以我们要做的，我的意思是，所以，你知道，我认为我们在保持三十年稳定、兼容的开发方面有着相当不错的记录，考虑到语言的规模，这可以说是相当令人印象深刻的。而且，你知道，什么，你知道，我想做的，我的目标是让我们的语言永远繁荣下去，可以这么说。而且，最好的方法是什么？我不是很清楚，但很显然，我们希望做出这样的设定：无论我们的公司发生什么，等等等等，这门语言都将永远可用，等等等等。
Yeah. Right. So what we're trying to do, I mean, so, you know, I think we have a pretty good record of, you know, three decades of, you know, stable, compatible, you know, development, which I think is pretty impressive on the scale of languages. And, you know, what, you know, what I want to do, you know, my goal is to have our language prosper, you know, forever, so to speak. And, you know, what's the best way to do that? I don't know precisely, but obviously we want to set it up so that whatever happens to our company, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera, the language will always be available, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
其实，我们正在做的一件事是Wolfram引擎，它是该语言的核心计算内核，我们实际上将改变它的许可方式，以便人们更容易把它整合到各种事物中。基本上那里的交易规则将是：如果你在开发东西，你就可以免费使用这个引擎。你只需要免费下载它。你可以免费下载它。你可以免费使用它。一旦你需要生产许可，如果你真的想要投入生产，你知道，运行某种大型商业网站，那么你就付钱给我们。但是当
Actually, a thing we're doing is the Wolfram engine, which is kind of the core computational kernel of the language, we're actually going to be changing the way that's licensed so that it's much easier for people to incorporate it in things. And basically the deal there is going to be, if you're developing stuff, you can just use the engine for free. You can just download it for free. You can just download it for free. You can use it for free. As soon as you want a production license, if you want to actually go into production, you know, running some big commercial site, then you pay us. But while
你只是在用它，你知道，用它来随便玩玩的时候——现在，你知道，如果你的产品是研发，那是，你知道，那是我们的传统市场，这不算是软件开发。但如果你的目标是，我在开发这个，我在把玩它，我正试图开发某种产品，那么它对开发者来说就是一个免费版本。而且我不知道最终结果会怎样，开发者们会以某种方式打包他们的游戏。但我依然认为这种商业模式是有意义的。人们真正没有充分认识到的另一件事是，而且我可能没有准确表达这一点，但那种人们身上所具备的私人的、慈善般的本质——我的意思是，绝大多数人都能识别价值并愿意为之付费，
you're just using, you know, using the thing to play around now, you know, if your product is R&D, that's, you know, that's our traditional market, and that doesn't count as software development. But if your goal is, I'm developing this, I'm playing around with it, I'm trying to develop some product, then it's just a version that's free for developers. And I don't know exactly how that's going to work out, at the end of the day, package their game in a certain way. But I still think that this business model makes sense. The other thing that people don't really give a full appreciation to is just the, and I might not be saying this correctly, but the sort of private charitable nature of of people i mean the vast majority of people recognize value and and will pay for things um yeah especially if they're also making money
嗯，是的，特别是如果他们也能赚钱的话，如果它是他们商业流程的一部分的话。我的意思是，你知道，我的态度是，有——你知道的，我们把应用程序软件免费赠送给很多，你知道，学生，很多学生和许多不同的群体等等。但就像在树莓派电脑上一样，每个树莓派电脑上都有一个Wolfram语言软件包，供人们免费使用。诸如此类的事情还有很多。我的目标是确保那些真正获得价值的人——这种价值可能是完成下一个伟大的研发成果，这种价值可能是上一堂课，这种价值可能是交付一个产品——那些真正获得最终商业价值的人，能够支持我们所做事情的持续发展。而且，你知道，我的意思是，这是一个复杂艰难的平衡过程，因为，你知道，我个人，你知道，如果我们有无限的商业资源，也许我们就能把它免费送给所有人。
if it's part of their commercial process i mean you know my attitude is there's um you know and we give away you know app software to lots of you know students lots of students and lots of different groups and so on. But like on the Raspberry Pi computer, there's a Wolfram Language bundle on every Raspberry Pi computer freely available to people. And there are lots of things like that. My goal is to make sure that the people who are really deriving value, and that value might be doing the next great R&D thing, that value might be teaching a class, that value might be delivering a product. The people who are really deriving what ends up being commercial value support the continued development of what we're doing. And, you know, I mean, it's been, you know, it's a complicated sort of threading of the needle because, you know, I personally, you know, if we had infinite commercial resources, maybe we'd be able to just give it away to everybody.
但我其实认为这甚至并不健康。我认为拥有这样一种情况是很好的：受益的人正是那些支持持续发展的人。这使我们能够——我的意思是，这促使我们去做那些对世界真正有意义的事情，可以这么说。没错。我的意思是，这就好比如果你在玩模拟城市之类的模拟电子游戏，你给自己无限的资金，突然之间这个游戏就完全失去了方向感。所以你，你如果没有一些客户，就会失去方向。
But I actually think that isn't even healthy. I think it's good to have a situation where the people who are benefiting are the people who are supporting continued development. And that allows us, I mean, it makes us do things that actually make sense for the world, so to speak. That's right. I mean, it's sort of like if you were to play one of these simulation video games like SimCity or something like that, and you give yourself infinite money that all of a sudden the game becomes completely unguided. And so you, you have no direction unless you have some customers.
是的。后期版本的《模拟城市》实际上其中很大一部分是用Wolfram语言设计的。太酷了。我不知道这一点。这只是其中之一。只是，你知道，而且我认为，这些规则，我不知道那里所做所有事情的具体细节。我见过许多关于城市的模拟的模拟的模拟，可以这么说。没错。我看到过一篇有趣的文章，讲的是——为了不扯得太远——他们是如何
Yeah. The later versions of SimCity actually were the a bunch of it was designed in Wolfram language. Cool. I didn't know that. That's just one of those. Just, you know, and I think, you know, the rules, I don't know exactly all the things that were done there. I've seen a bunch of the simulations of the simulations of the simulations of cities, so to speak. Right. I saw an interesting article about how, not to go on too much of a tangent, but how they
决定交通模型的。实际上，这是一个蒙特卡洛方法，他们在每个时间步长随机挑选两个不同的功能区，例如，一个住宅区和一个商业区。然后他们使用玩家放置的道路绘制一条路径。接着，他们还会将所有东西按一个常数递减，以便他们始终拥有一个分布、一个概率分布。随着时间推移，如果许多这样的路径要求人们走同一条路，那么自然而然地，
decided on the traffic model. And effectively, it's a Monte Carlo approach where they, at every time step, they randomly pick two different zoned places. So, for example, a residential zoned place and then a commercial zoned place. And they draw a path using the roads that the player has placed. And then they also then decrease everything by a constant so that they always have a distribution, a probability distribution. And over time, if many of those paths require the person to take the same road, then that naturally,
这就会变成一个非常好的交通数学模型。要做出类似的事情，你需要尝试许多不同的想法。我非常确凿地坚信，凭我对参与其中的团队的了解，那是用Mathematica和Wolfram语言进行原型的。其实，我得讲一个关于交通流的个人故事，这有点像……所以自我小时候起，我就对交通流作为一种有趣的数学问题挺感兴趣的。而且我其实从来没有弄明白过太多关于它的有趣的事情。后来我开始研究一种叫做“元胞自动机”的东西。
that becomes sort of a very nice mathematical model of the traffic. And to do anything like that, you need to try many different ideas. I'm quite certain that that was prototyped in Mathematica and Wolfram Language, just knowing the team that was involved in doing that. Actually, I have to tell a personal story about traffic flow, which is kind of a... So when I was a kid, I was sort of interested in traffic flow as kind of an interesting kind of mathematical type problem. And I didn't really ever figure out terribly much that's interesting about it. Then I started working on these things called cellular automata.
它们是非常简单的程序，我们只有一排黑白相间的格子，并且你有一条规则，上面写着如果右边有一个黑色格子而中间是一个白色格子，等等，那就这样做。关于元胞自动机之类的东西，我主要发现的是：即使规则非常简单，也很容易表现出非常复杂的行为。事实证明，（你知道）这本长达1200页的书名叫《一种新科学》（A New Kind of Science），它就是基于这个理念的，这本书其实就在今天推出了平装版，在作为纯粹的
They're very simple programs that we just have a row of black and white cells, and you just have a rule that says if there's a black cell to the right and a white cell in the middle, et cetera, then do this. And the main thing that I discovered about things like cellular automata is it's very easy to get very complicated behavior even when the rules are very simple. And that turns out to, you know, this 1200 page book called the new kind of science that is based on that idea that actually just today came out in paperback so after 16 years of being a pure
精装书存在了16年后终于出了平装版。不过哦，太酷了，我扯远了。它有Kindle版或其他电子书版本吗？哦，有的，而且网上其实有一个免费版本。太酷了。网上有一个非常精致的版本，我一直在慢慢地采用它。这是一个有趣的故事。所以那本书所有的科学内容——这本书是2002年出版的——但我花在它之前十年为这本书进行研究的所有科学内容，全都写在Wolfram语言的Notebook里。
hardcover book but oh cool i i digress is it on uh on um kindle or anything like that oh yeah and there's actually a free version on the web. Cool. It's a very elaborate version on the web, which I've been slowly taking. This is a fun story. So all the science for that book, the book came out in 2002, but all the science that I spent the decade before that working on for that book, it's all in Wolfram language notebooks.
所以我想要把所有这些东西展示出来。因此我最近一直在做——其实，结果最后不得不由我来做这其中的很多事情，因为我多少还懂一点我以前的代码。所以我一直在对其中一些内容进行直播，并且我一直在使用我在1992年制作的这些Notebook以及诸如此类的东西。这真的很有满足感，因为它们直接就能运行。我只需要启动它们，按Shift+Enter，代码就直接运行了。其中一些现在可以做得更好，因为我们拥有了更干净的，你知道的——
And so I wanted to sort of expose all that stuff. And so I've been just recently, actually, I've been doing, it's ended up that it ends up being me who has to do a bunch of this stuff because I kind of understand the code I wrote before. But so I've been live streaming some of these things and I've been taking these notebooks that I made in 1992 and things like this. And it's really satisfying because they just run. I just start them up and press shift enter and the code just runs. Some of it can be better now because we have cleaner you know, cleaner sort of
更干净的函数，我们在其中（你知道）使用了更高抽象级别的函数来定义某种特定事物的运作方式。所以代码可以更短、更清晰，但真挺酷的，我以前拥有的所有这些研究用Notebook居然都能直接运行。不过无论如何，我扯远了。我刚才在讲道路交通流——所以我研究了这些元胞自动机的东西，然后岁月流逝，你知道，我在年轻时曾未能对道路交通流做出太多成果，
functions that where, you know, we've used sort of higher levels of abstraction to define how certain kinds of things work. So the code can be shorter and clearer, but it's pretty neat that the, you know, that all this sort of research notebooks that I had all just run. But in any case, I digress. I was talking about road traffic flow so so i studied these cellular automaton things and then years went by and you know i had sort of failed in my youth to be able to do much with road traffic flow um and then you know then somebody said by the way there's the cellular automaton model that people have developed of road traffic flow and actually it turns out the standard model now is a cellular automaton model based on a thing called Rule 184, which is the, well, the 184th rule in this enumeration of rules that I made. And so it's like, it's kind of amusing for me because that's become, as I say, the standard model that people use for road traffic flow.
然后，你知道，后来有人说：“对了，人们已经开发出了道路交通流的元胞自动机模型。”实际上，事实证明现在的标准模型是一个基于一种叫做“规则184”（Rule 184）的事物的元胞自动机模型，也就是我所制作的规则枚举中的第184条规则。所以这就好像，对我来说这挺逗的，因为正如我所说，那已经成为了人们用于道路交通流的标准模型。
And there it was sort of right under my nose, the cellular automata that I studied. But it's actually, if one's interested in sort of the meta theory of modeling, it's actually an interesting story because what really happened and what always happens with modeling is modeling is an idealization. So you say, I'm going to model snowflake growth. You might say, what really matters to me is exactly how fast the edges of the snowflake expand. But the fact that my snowflakes are circular, I don't care about that. I really just care about how fast the edges expand. Or I might say, what I really care about is the overall structure of
它就在我眼皮底下，就是我研究过的元胞自动机。但实际上，如果有人对建模的元科学感兴趣的话，这其实是个有趣的故事。因为真正发生的事情、以及建模中一直在发生的事情是：建模是一种理想化。所以你会说：“我要对雪花的生长进行建模。”你可能会说：“对我真正重要的是雪花边缘扩张的具体速度。但我的雪花是圆的这一事实，我并不在乎。我真正在乎的只是边缘扩张的速度有多快。”或者我可能会说：“我真正关心的是雪花的整体结构，
the snowflake, and I don't care whether I get exactly right how fast the edges expand. So modeling is always as much about what you care about as it is about, you know, you're never going to get all the details right because models are always an idealization. And it's a little bit like what we were talking about a while back about sort of, you know, what's interesting, so to speak, you know, and the fact that that's very culturally dependent, so to speak. And so what really happened with this road traffic flow thing is that the things I thought were important about road traffic flow turned out not to be the things that are important. And what the model, what this cellular automaton model captures is a bunch of stuff that I
而我不在乎边缘扩张的速度是否完全正确。”因此，建模从来都是关于你在乎什么，正如它关于——你知道的，你永远不可能把所有细节都弄对，因为模型永远只是一种理想化。这有点像我们前不久讨论的关于（你知道）什么是有趣的，可以这么说，以及这在很大程度上取决于文化，可以这么说。所以，在这个道路交通流事件中真正发生的事情是：我原以为对道路交通流很重要的东西，结果证明并不是重要的东西。这个模型——这个元胞自动机模型所捕捉到的是一堆
really wasn't focused on. I was focused on various quantitative things that it doesn't capture, but what it does capture is the stuff that really matters for you know modeling self-driving you know modeling you know current traffic jams and the effects of self-driving cars on them and all that kind of thing but okay so I think I think that was a digression no I mean one of the nice things about doing something such as inventing a language or doing something you know in the pure math space or publishing a paper in graph theory or one of these things is that it has really wild
我实际上并没有关注的东西。我关注的是各种它没有捕捉到的定量东西，但它确实捕捉到了对（你知道）对自动驾驶建模、对（你知道）对当前交通拥堵及自动驾驶汽车对其影响建模等所有这类事情真正重要的东西。不过好吧，我想——我想那是个题外话。不，我的意思是，做类似发明一门语言、在纯数学领域做点事情、或者在图论领域发表一篇论文之类的事情，其妙处之一在于它具有真正狂野的
implications that get realized over many years. I found out recently some research I had done as a student went into just figuring out the mass of a cork and then I know absolutely nothing about physics that's interesting yeah I'd be curious what that was I I you know my only so I worked on particle physics when I was a teenager actually and um uh it was it's interesting in terms of sort of the meta theory of fields because I worked on particle physics in the late 1970s when it was kind of the golden age of particle because I worked on particle physics in the late 1970s when it was kind of the golden age of particle physics and a bunch of new methodology had come in and there was this like five-year period when just there was major new results every two weeks
影响，这些影响会在多年后显现出来。我最近发现，我还是学生时做的一些研究，最终被用来计算夸克的质量。我对物理学一无所知。那很有趣。是的，我很想知道那是什么。我——你知道，我唯一的——其实我十几岁时曾从事过粒子物理学研究，而且，呃，它在领域的元科学方面很有趣，因为我是在20世纪70年代末从事粒子物理学研究的，那时可以说是粒子物理学的黄金时代，因为我是在20世纪70年代末从事粒子物理学研究的，当时可以说是粒子物理学的黄金时代，引入了许多新方法，并且有这样一个五年时期，每两周就会出现重大的新成果，
type thing kind of the same way that machine learning is today yeah and uh and so what's what's interesting about being involved in a field during its kind of golden age of hypergrowth is that there's low-hanging fruit lying all over the place. And so I invented this thing, this way of studying the structure of particle events, the particle accelerator, which I did when I was like 17 years old or something, and I was really pleased that, you know, when the Higgs particle was discovered, you know, they'd used these, you know, as part of the kind of the pipeline of doing the analysis and so on. They used these things called event shapes that I'd invented. So that was, you know, that's the benefit of being involved in a field during its sort of hypergrowth phase. From a sort of career planning point of view,
有点像今天的机器学习一样。是的，所以，在一个领域的超高速增长黄金时代参与其中，有趣的一点在于到处都有唾手可得的低垂果实。所以我发明了这个东西，一种研究粒子事件结构的方法——粒子加速器，那是我在大约17岁左右的时候做的，我非常高兴地看到，（你知道）当希格斯粒子被发现时，你知道，他们曾将这些（你知道）作为分析流程的一部分等等。他们使用了我发明的被称为“事件形状”（event shapes）的东西。所以，这就是（你知道）在处于超高速增长阶段的领域中参与所带来的好处。从某种职业规划的角度来看，
the downside is you've got a lot of competition during that period. I personally tend to prefer working on things where I can do neat stuff, but nobody else cares. And after it's done, I mean, my favorite thing, in a sense, is producing what I tend to call alien artifacts, things that nobody kind of thought would exist. But once it exists, you can look at it and you can realize it's interesting.
其缺点在于你在那个时期会面临激烈的竞争。我个人倾向于喜欢做那些我能做出好东西、但其他人却毫不在乎的事情。事情完成后——从某种意义上说，我最喜欢的事情是生产我倾向于称之为“外星人工制品”（alien artifacts）的东西，也就是那些没有人认为会存在的东西。但一旦它存在了，你看着它就能意识到它是很有趣的。
So like Wolfram Alpha, I consider to be an example of kind of an alien artifact. Like people hadn't, you know, people had, well, they'd kind of tried to do question answering stuff for years, but they had not, they didn't have knowledge bases, they didn't have symbolic languages underneath them, etc, etc, etc. That hadn't really gone anywhere. Yeah, I think the thing that I noticed about WolframAlpha is it's sort of a blending of two things. So there had been expert systems like i talked about you know open psych and and there had been you know there's word net there had been these sort of prologue obviously driving a lot of that there had been these these systems but they were far too rigid right and then on the other end you have something like like google.com which is extremely open-ended
所以像Wolfram Alpha，我认为这就是一种外星人工制品。就像人们还没——（你知道）人们曾尝试做问答系统多年，但他们没有知识库，他们底层没有符号语言，等等等等。那并没有取得什么进展。是的，我觉得我注意到WolframAlpha的一点是，它是两种事物的融合。所以曾经有过专家系统，就像我谈到的——你知道的——OpenCyc，并且曾经有过——有WordNet，曾经有这些——很显然Prolog在其中推动了很大一部分——曾有过这些系统，但它们太僵化了，对吧？然后在另一端，你拥有像google.com这样极其开放、
but entirely data-driven and there's no there's no structure and there's no human intuition behind those results right and so I feel like Wolfram Alpha sort of walked that line very well yeah I think I mean you know you mentioned things like psych you know psych is a isn is a – I had known Doug Lanat, the guy who created Psyche, from back in the early 80s. And so I watched that whole progress. And it was – I have to say it was interesting because when Wolfram Alpha came out, it was – AI was at one of its real low points.
但完全由数据驱动的事物，并且没有任何结构，这些结果背后也没有人类的直觉，对吧？所以我感觉Wolfram Alpha很好地走在了这条线上。是的，我的意思是——（你知道）你提到了像Cyc这样的东西，（你知道）Cyc是一个——我早在80年代初就认识了Cyc的创造者道格·莱纳特（Doug Lenat）。所以我目睹了整个进展过程。而且它——我必须说这很有趣，因为当Wolfram Alpha问世时，人工智能正处于其真正的低谷之一。
I mean, people didn't really believe AI. You know, 2009, AI was not – you know, people said, I'm working on AI. It's like, oh, that's not going anywhere type thing. Yep. I literally, my background is in deep neural networks. And in 2009, I got a job writing JavaScript because nobody needed someone who knew anything about neural networks. That's good. That's, that's a, yeah. So you're a data point.
我的意思是，人们并不真正相信人工智能。你知道，2009年的人工智能并不是——（你知道）人们说：“我在做人工智能。”别人就会说：“哦，那没什么前途。”之类的话。是的。我实际上，我的背景是深度神经网络。而在2009年，我找到了一份编写JavaScript的工作，因为没有人需要懂神经网络的人。那很好。那是，那是一个，是的。所以你是一个数据点。
No, I think, I mean, it was interesting when, when, when Wolfram Alpha was coming out, I had a friend named Marvin Minsky who was a sort of pioneer of the AI world. And, you know, I saw Marvin, oh probably a few weeks before Wolfram Alpha went live. And I said, Marvin, let me show you something. It's like I said, it's a question answering system, among other things. And it's like, okay.
不，我认为，我的意思是，当Wolfram Alpha问世时，情况很有意思，我有一个朋友叫马文·明斯基（Marvin Minsky），他是人工智能领域的先驱之一。而且，（你知道）我见到马文是在Wolfram Alpha上线前几周吧。我说：“马文，让我给你看个东西。”我说：“它是一个问答系统，除其他功能外。”它就像是，“好吧。”
And so type a couple of things in. And then Marvin changes the subject, wants to talk about something different. I said, no, Marvin, this time it actually works. And then he's like, oh, well, let me try something else. Let me try something else. Oh, wow. And he's like, it was interesting to see because he'd seen so many kind of fake question answering systems over the course of many years. He just decided it was impossible. And why were we able to succeed? Basically,
然后输入了几个问题。接着马文就转移了话题，想谈点别的。我说：“不，马文，这次它真的管用。”然后他就说：“哦，好吧，让我试试别的。让我试试别的。哦，哇。”就像是——看到这一幕很有趣，因为多年来他见过太多虚假的问答系统。他只是觉得这是不可能的。为什么我们能够成功？基本上，
I didn't really even understand this until sort of after the fact. I mean, as far as I was concerned in building Wolfram Alpha, it was just use what cleverness I might have and just do a bunch of engineering. But after the fact, I realized a couple of things. First of all, we had a lot of actual knowledge and people have been trying to do natural language understanding and so on without knowledge. They've been trying to abstractly do it. It's just like, what's the structure? Let's parse the sentence and find the noun and the verb and so on. That's much, much less relevant than knowing this is a city and its population is roughly this and so on. And that's why, you know, that's why it's likely to be talking about
我直到事后才真正明白这一点。就我构建Wolfram Alpha而言，它只是运用了我可能拥有的机智并做了一堆工程。但在事后，我意识到了一些事情。首先，我们拥有大量真实的知识，而人们一直在试图在没有知识的情况下进行自然语言理解等工作。他们一直试图抽象地做到这一点。这就好像是：结构是什么？让我们解析句子并找到名词和动词等等。这与知道“这是一座城市，它的火车站人口大约是这么多”之类的知识相比，其相关性要小得多、得多。这就是为什么（你知道）这就是为什么它更有可能是在谈论
Springfield, Massachusetts, rather than Springfield, you know, Illinois or something like this. And the second thing was, which I, is that we actually had a target to turn the natural language into, namely, we had our symbolic language that could represent things about the world. And another thing that, again, only became sort of clear after the fact is that a bunch of the, well, ideas about algorithm, what one might call algorithm discovery that came out of my new kind of science project, we use that a lot in building the way that Wolf Malfoy works. I mean, you know, just to say something about that, I mean, you know, the traditional way to think about building software is or has been, you know, let's write the lines of code to do what we want to do. What I ended up discovering from sort of just looking at, you know, trillions of simple
马萨诸塞州的斯普林菲尔德，而不是伊利诺伊州的斯普林菲尔德（或其他地方）的原因。第二件事是，我——是我们实际上有一个目标可以将自然语言转化为该目标，也就是说，我们拥有能够表示世界上各种事物的符号语言。另一件同样是在事后才变得清晰的事情是，我的“一种新科学”项目所产生的大量关于算法的想法——人们可能会称之为“算法发现”的想法——我们在构建Wolfram Alpha的工作方式时大量使用了这些。我的意思是，（你知道）简单说明一下，（你知道）构建软件的传统思考方式过去是、或者一直是：让我们编写代码行来做我们想做的事情。而我通过观察（你知道）数以万亿计的简单
programs is that there are simple programs that do really interesting things. And sometimes those things are really useful. They might be good pseudonym number generators. They might be good image processing things and so on. And so we started developing this kind of methodology for just finding algorithms by knowing what kind of a thing you want and then just going out and searching the space of possible programs. I mean, in today's world, that seems less surprising because with deep learning and so on, one's sort of doing the same kind of thing, although what we've done a lot more of
程序最终发现的是：有一些简单的程序能够做出非常有趣的事情。有时这些事情真的很有用。它们可能是很好的伪随机数生成器、可能是很好的图像处理程序等等。因此，我们开始开发这种方法论，通过了解你想要什么样的事物，然后直接去搜索可能程序的空间来寻找算法。在当今世界，这似乎不那么令人惊讶，因为有了深度学习等技术，人们正在做类似的事情，尽管我们做了更多的事情
is just exhaustively going out and sampling the computational universe, whereas in typical neural nets, you're doing this kind of incremental sort of more like biological evolution, you know, taking small steps and trying to make sure the animals don't die on the way type thing rather than just sampling the whole space. But, you know, I think that the but to go back to to represent, to use essentially predicate logic to represent sort of facts about the world, common sense facts about the world, you know. If something is dunked in water, then it is wet, those kinds of things. Right. when Wolfram Alpha came out, you know, Doug Lannat said basically, well, you succeeded in what I tried to do.
是穷举并采样计算宇宙，而在典型的神经网络中，你正在进行这种渐进式的、更像生物进化式的操作（你知道，采取小步伐并试图确保动物在途中不会死掉），而不是直接采样整个空间。但是，（你知道）我认为——但回到——为了表示，本质上使用谓词逻辑来表示关于世界的各种事实、关于世界的常识事实（你知道），如果某物浸入水中，那么它就是湿的，诸如此类的事情。没错。当Wolfram Alpha问世时，（你知道）道格·莱纳特基本上说：“嗯，你成功做到了我试图去做的事情。”
And, you know, and the whole sort of common sense reasoning thing clearly wasn't able to get there. What I realized was a sort of interesting conceptual point, which is in a sense, what Doug was trying to do was to use the state of human thinking in the medieval time, in the Middle Ages. And I just cheated and used the last 300 years of science. Because for him, if he wants to figure out some physics problem with common sense reasoning, he's like, oh, well, you know, if you push on this,
而且，（你知道）整个常识推理的事情显然没能做到那一步。我意识到的是一个有趣的观念点，从某种意义上说，道格试图做的是使用中世纪人类思维的状态。而我作弊了，我使用了过去300年的科学。因为对他来说，如果他想通过常识推理弄清楚某个物理问题，他会觉得：“哦，好吧，你知道，如果你推这个，
then it'll push on that, which will make this happen. And it's kind of like you're reasoning through it, like you're doing natural philosophy to figure out what's going to happen in the world. For us, it's like, well, let's just, you know, just use all that science that people have figured out. Let's just, you know, for the physics problem, let's turn that into, you know, Lagrangian mechanics and solve the differential equations and say, and the answer is 7.5 or something. So essentially we're, you know, we're making use of all that additional knowledge that's been developed in civilization beyond the pure human reasoning knowledge. And I think that's what, you know, that's kind of, you know, in a sense we cheated relative to the original mission of kind of common sense AI.
那么它就会推那个，这就会导致这个发生。”这感觉就像你在推理它，就像你在做自然哲学来弄清楚世界上将要发生什么。对我们来说，这就好比，好吧，让我们——只需（你知道）利用人们已经弄清楚的所有科学。让我们——（你知道）对于物理问题，将其转化为（你知道）拉格朗日力学并求解微分方程，然后说：“答案是7.5左右。”所以本质上我们（你知道）我们正在利用文明中发展起来的所有超出纯粹人类推理知识的额外知识。我认为这就是（你知道）——从某种意义上说，相对于常识AI最初的使命，我们作弊了。
I think that the fact that you have these dynamical systems and they don't is definitely part of it. But I think the other, the even more important part is the resolving of the ambiguity, ultimately through, you know, heuristics, but also through statistics and through language understanding and things like that. No, no, right. I mean, look, it's just, I mean, as an engineering project, it's a, I mean, you know, our effort was much, you know, has been much more, I don't know, pragmatic and in a sense making use of many more methods. I mean, not just saying, we're just going to use common sense reasoning to figure everything out.
我认为，你拥有这些动力系统而他们没有，绝对是其中的一部分。但我认为另一部分、更重要的一部分是解决歧义，最终通过（你知道）启发式方法，但也通过统计学、语言理解以及诸如此类的事情来解决。不，不，对吧？我的意思是，看，作为一项工程项目，它是一个——我的意思是，（你知道）我们的努力要得多得多（你知道）一直是更加务实的，并且在某种意义上利用了更多的方法。我的意思是，不仅仅是说：“我们将只使用常识推理来弄清楚一切。”
We're using whatever method makes sense. And that's kind of a story, you know, that's, that's part of kind of the whole Wolfram language story is put everything in so you can use whatever makes sense. I mean, you know, when we come to do data science, for example, we like to talk about kind of multi-paradigm data science. It's just everything is there, so whatever makes sense to do, you can do, so to speak, rather than, oh, we've got a package that does this, so that's what we're going to have to do. But I was going to say, you know, you're talking, we were talking earlier about math problems and watermelons and, and, and so on. And one of the use cases that I really wanted to make use of sort of common sense reasoning for was math word problems. So we, you know, I, and I, we still have never managed to do this. And, and it's, you know, when you talk about, you know,
我们使用的是任何说得通的方法。这有点像一个故事，（你知道）那是整个Wolfram语言故事的一部分——把所有东西都放进来，这样你就可以使用任何说得通的方法。我的意思是，（你知道）当我们开始做数据科学时，例如，我们喜欢谈论所谓的多范式数据科学。一切都在那里，所以无论做什么说得通，你都可以做，可以这么说，而不是说：“哦，我们有一个能做这个的软件包，所以这就是我们不得不做的事情。”但我正要说的是，（你知道）你正在谈论——我们刚才在谈论数学问题和西瓜等等。我真正想要将常识推理应用于的用例之一就是数学应用题。所以我们（你知道）我——我们仍然设法做到这一点。并且，（你知道）当你谈论（你知道）
putting the watermelons in your, in your cart or whatever and then and then somebody might say um and uh i don't know um after well let's say you put the watermelon you know um uh you know you put the watermelons in bags in the shopping cart and uh you And if there are X number of watermelons go in these bags, how many of them are still visible as you're walking around the store? Well, of course, to know that it will be visible when you're walking around the store, you have to know that once a watermelon has been put in a bag, you can't see it anymore.
把西瓜放进购物车或者别的什么东西里，然后然后有人可能会说，呃，我不知道，呃，在——好吧，假设你把西瓜放进——（你知道，呃，你知道）你把西瓜装进袋子并放进购物车，然后——如果有X个西瓜放进这些袋子里，当你在店里走动时，它们中有多少仍然是可见的？好吧，当然，要知道当你走过商店时它是否可见，你必须知道一旦西瓜被放进袋子里，你就再也看不到它了。
And that's kind of common sense reasoning. And so to do, you know, if you set up a word problem like that, you have to have a layer of common sense reasoning. You know, we might be able to, if we can get an equation out of it, you know, 3x plus 7 equals 14 or something, where x is the number of watermelons, then, you know, then we're all done. And we can just use, you know, modern science, so to speak, to just crack that and get to the answer. But the thing about, you know, how many watermelons can you see in the shopping cart that we need common sense reasoning for now, you know, I've been hoping, uh, uh, you know, I've been hoping that, that we'll be able to make use of what Doug has
这就是某种常识推理。因此要做（你知道）如果你设立了这样一道应用题，你就必须具备一层常识推理。你知道，如果我们能从中得到一个方程（你知道，3x + 7 = 14或者别的什么，其中x是西瓜的数量），那么（你知道）我们就大功告成了。我们就可以使用（你知道）现代科学，可以这么说，来破解它并得出答案。但关于（你知道）你在购物车里能看到多少个西瓜的问题，我们需要常识推理。现在，（你知道）我一直希望——呃，（你知道）我一直希望我们能够利用道格多年来所做的事情。我的意思是，他——
done for so many years. I mean, he,. I mean, he's been very pessimistic about whether this is going to work. So it's never been tried. But, you know, in fact, we've reached, we can do basically up to middle school level math word problems using extremely boring heuristic template-y type techniques. We can't do more sophisticated ones. and it's sort of an interesting open problem to be able to do those, and it's a place where one might be able to use, or one should be able to use, you know, common sense reasoning. But it's interesting to realize that the space where there's sort of things that one actually wants to do with sort of common sense reasoning is still worth doing is a narrow space, and it's a space where, in a sense,
我的意思是，他对这是否会成功一直非常悲观。所以它从未被尝试过。但是，实际上，我们已经达到了——我们基本上可以使用极其无聊的启发式模板技术来做初中水平的数学应用题。我们做不了更复杂的。能够做到这一点是一个有趣的未解问题，这也是一个人们可能会使用——或者应该能够使用（你知道）常识推理的地方。但意识到这一点很有趣：人们实际上想要用常识推理去做的那些事情的空间仍然是一个狭窄的空间，它是一个在某种程度上，
those things were built for humans to have to sort of put effort in to figure them out. They weren't, they're not natural things. I mean, you know, another example might be, you know, let's say you're doing medical school and you're saying, you know, which nerve goes near the such and such tendon, you know, of such and such. Well, you know, which nerve goes near the such and such tendon, you know, such and such? Well, you could do that with common sense reasoning, but actually, you know, we've got a complete 3D map of human anatomy and you can just go and use computational geometry and answer the question. And it's not, you know, even though a medical student might do it by thinking through, oh, you know, this goes that place and that place. And so they're
这些东西是为了让人类不得不付出努力去弄清楚它们而构建的空间。它们不是自然的事物。我的意思是，（你知道）另一个例子可能是，假设你在读医学院，你在说（你知道）哪条神经靠近某个肌腱，（你知道）某个……的肌腱。好吧，（你知道）哪条神经靠近某个肌腱？好吧，你可以用常识推理来做到这一点，但实际上，（你知道）我们拥有完整的人体解剖三维图谱，你可以直接去使用计算几何来回答这个问题。而且它不是——尽管医学院的学生可能会通过思考“哦，这个去那个地方，那个去那个地方”来完成它。所以他们
using common sense reasoning, but that's not how, you know, we're going to do it with a computer. It's interesting. It sounds like, so if you think about these word problems, ultimately what they're trying to do is, they're really trying to do two things. One is sort of obfuscate the core problem. So they're not just giving you 3x plus 7 equals 14, but they're wrapping it in some narrative that you have to understand. So making the problem harder. But then they're also trying to relate the problem to real life, which is why it was so funny to see the 17 watermelons in one shopping cart. So in a sense, if you could generate relevant, if you could generate, say, SAT math questions that really connected with somebody, that would be maybe more difficult than the counting they would do at a real grocery
运用常识推理，但你知道，我们不会用计算机来那样做。这很有趣。听起来，如果你仔细想想这些文字题，他们最终想做的是，其实是想做两件事。一是掩盖核心问题。所以他们不仅给你 3x 加 7 等于 14，而是把它包装在一个你需要理解的故事中。这样就增加了问题的难度。但同时，他们也试图将问题与现实生活联系起来，这就是为什么在一个购物车里看到 17 个西瓜会觉得那么好笑。从某种意义上说，如果你能生成相关的，如果你能生成，比方说，真正能与某人产生共鸣的 SAT 数学题，这可能比他们在真正的杂货店
store, but would closely emulate something they would do in real life. I feel like there's something really profound there. So, I mean, because you've sort of understood that it is truly a common sense reasoning problem. You've understood the way, the routine things that people do and the math that people do on a routine basis.
里进行的数数要困难，但会高度模拟他们在现实生活中会做的事情。我觉得这里面有一些非常深刻的东西。所以，我的意思是，因为你已经理解了它确实是一个常识推理问题。你已经理解了人们所做的常规事情以及人们日常所做的数学运算的方式。
And you've been able to sort of extrapolate that to something more difficult, like differential equations and figure out a way to sort of tie those two things together. That's actually something profoundly complex. Right. I mean, look, I think that the thing one would like people to learn is the stuff they can't just feed to computers and get automated. And, you know, the main thing is this question learn is the stuff they can't just feed to computers and get automated. The main thing is this question of taking a human thing you want to do and thinking
并且你已经能够将这些外推到更困难的事情上，比如微分方程，并找出一种将这两件事联系起来的方法。这其实是一件非常深奥复杂的事情。没错。我的意思是，听着，我认为人们希望学到的东西是那些他们不能简单地喂给计算机并实现自动化的东西。而且，你知道，最主要的是这个学习的问题是他们不能简单地喂给计算机并实现自动化的东西。最主要的是将你想做的人类事情并进行思考
about it in computational enough terms that you can describe it in a precise language and have a computer unambiguously know what you're talking about. And I think that process, I mean, when you talk about math word problems, sort of the idea there is take these kind of fake situations in the world and try and mathematize them. I think the real thing that people should be learning how to do, and very few people are actually learning this yet, is take things in the world that are real things in the world and learn how to think about them computationally and be able to express them
用足够的计算术语来描述它，这样你就可以用精确的语言来描述它，并让计算机毫不含糊地知道你在说什么。我认为这个过程，当谈到数学文字题时，那里的想法基本上是采用世界上这种虚假的情况并将其实际数学化。我认为人们真正应该学习如何去做，而且实际上很少有人在学习这一点，那就是把世界上真实存在的东西拿来，学习如何用计算的方式去思考它们，并能够表达它们
in such a way that both you can think about them more clearly. I mean, the remarkable thing for me, at least, is, you know, I've been spending years kind of thinking about things computationally. And so there are lots of kinds of, you know, very everyday questions where I think about them in terms of breaking it down into the kinds of, you know, structure that I would use to think about something computationally. And then by golly, I can actually get to an answer. And whereas otherwise you just don't have, it's very mushy. You don't have a way to think about it. You know, if you don't have this sort of framework and in our case, you know, computational language
用这样一种方式，既能让你更清晰地思考它们。对我而言，至少最了不起的事情是，你知道，我花了很多年时间用计算的方式来思考问题。所以有许多非常日常的问题，我会把它们分解成我用来进行计算思考的结构。然后，天哪，我真的能得到一个答案。而如果没有这个，你就没有办法，它非常模糊。你没有办法去思考它。你知道，如果你没有这种框架，在我们的例子中，你知道，计算语言
to use to think about things, you know, you can't form them precisely enough in your mind to actually get to a conclusion. I mean, it's the same problem as, you know, Doug's common sense reasoning thing. You just, you end up with, up with, you don't get, it's kind of all, it's all these, if it rains, then it will get wet, then this. But it's all very kind of vague. And it doesn't give you a precise structure to operate in. Talking of which, I think we're probably reaching the end of my,
用来思考事情，你知道，你无法在脑海中对它们进行足够精确的构思来得出结论。我的意思是，这和道格的常识推理问题是一样的。你只是，你最终得到的是，你没有得到，这有点像，这都是这些，如果下雨了，那么就会变湿，然后就会这样。但这一切都很模糊。它没有为你提供一个可以运作的精确结构。说到这儿，我想我的时间大概快到头了，
I'm a creature of, you know, one of the things I, I'm a data oriented person. Yeah. I do, I've, I've do a lot of sort of personal analytics stuff. And I probably, I was somewhat horrified a number of years ago to discover that i'm the human who's collected more data on themselves than anybody else and so one of the things i know is that i get uh i get sleepy at a very precise time and that time was about 10 minutes ago all right so i'm gonna start failing here but but um no think that's great. So I wanted to, I mean, this has been just absolutely fantastic. Thank you so much for coming on the show. I think people are going to be absolutely fascinated to hear a true programming language inventor and to sort of hear your story and this dialogue.
我是一个习惯于，你知道，我关注数据的一个人。是的。我做，我做过很多个人分析方面的事情。我可能，几年前曾有些震惊地发现，我是收集最多关于自己数据的个人，超过了其他任何人，所以我知道的一件事是，我，嗯，我在一个非常精确的时间会犯困，那个时间大约是 10 分钟前。好吧，所以我从这里开始撑不住了，但是，嗯，不，我觉得这很好。所以我想要，我的意思是，这绝对太棒了。非常感谢你能来参加节目。我想人们一定会为听到真正的编程语言发明者的声音以及聆听你的故事和这段对话而着迷。
I think it's been amazing. What about just to sort of conclude here conclude here like um you know we always ask um two things one is sort of what is it like day to day at your company um so in this case you know well from research and and are you hiring if so what kind of jobs are you hiring for where things like that okay so i mean for me i spend most of my time figuring stuff out it's pretty neat actually it's you know i've i've uh you know it's it's i'm an unusual kind of ceo because i um uh you know i i'm deeply involved in the design of the product and so on and uh you know i have we, we've got great people at the company. And so an awful lot of what happens at the company just happens and doesn't require,
我觉得这太棒了。为了在这里做个小结，就像，嗯，你知道，我们总是会问两件事，一是你在公司的日常工作是怎样的，在这个情况下，也就是 Wolfram Research，你们在招人吗？如果是的话，你们在招什么样岗位的员工诸如此类？好吧，对我来说，我大部分时间都在琢磨各种事情。其实挺酷的，你知道，我，我，我是一个不寻常的 CEO，因为我，嗯，你知道，我深入参与了产品的设计等等，并且，你知道，我们，我们在公司里有很棒的员工。所以公司里发生的大量事情都是自然而然发生的，并不需要，
you know, the CEO to stick his nose into those things. And in fact, you know, one thing that's been interesting the last year, but since we've been doing this live streaming of internal design review meetings, is that folks who want to know what it's like to work at our company, company well there's 250 hours of what a bunch of meetings are like that's uh out there in the archives of the of the live streamed um uh stuff i think that um so our company is very geographically distributed where our headquarters is in champaign illinois i have been a remote ceo for 28. I live near Boston. Although I happen to be tomorrow doing my about three times a year trip to Illinois.
你知道，CEO 去对这些事情指手画脚。事实上，你知道，过去一年很有趣的一点是，自从我们开始对内部设计评审会议进行直播以来，那些想知道在我们公司工作是什么体验的人，嗯，有 250 小时的各种会议记录，这些都在我们直播内容的档案里。我认为，所以我们的公司在地理分布上非常广泛，我们的总部在伊利诺伊州尚佩恩。我担任远程 CEO 已经 28 年了。我住在波士顿附近。虽然我明天正好要进行每年大约三次的伊利诺伊州之行。
But the thing that we end up having people kind of scattered all over the world. Actually, our HR department tries to maintain an accurate map on our careers section of our website of where people are in the world. And it's quite diverse, I would say. In terms of what we, well, the places we tend to not hire people in New York and Silicon Valley, because we're going to, that's super expensive for us. And it doesn't, you know, we don't, we don't really need the, the proximity to other things that, that Silicon Valley provides. Not that, I mean, it's, I think, in terms of, you know, we've ended up with, well, I would say, a wonderfully talented group of people from around the world.
但我们最终还是让人分散在世界各地。实际上，我们的 HR 部门试图在我们网站的招聘页面上维护一张准确的地图，展示世界各地都有哪些人。而且我想说，这是相当多元化的。至于我们倾向于不在哪里招人，也就是纽约和硅谷，因为这太贵了。而且它并不，你知道，我们并不真正需要硅谷所提供的与其他事物的邻近性。并不是说，我的意思是，我认为，就，你知道，我们最终拥有了一群来自世界各地、才华横溢得出奇的人。
Yeah, I know some parents who work at Wolfram Research who are in South Africa. Yes. Yeah, it's amazing. Right. The thing that I really actually, I've come to appreciate the diversity of having people all over the world in all kinds of different settings and situations and so on. I think it adds a certain vibrancy to what happens that is something I certainly appreciate. But we've ended up with lots of world experts on lots of kinds of things. We've had lots of people who've been at the company a very long time. And some people, they're at the company for a decade.
是的，我知道有些在 Wolfram Research 工作的父母在南非。是的。是的，太棒了。实际上，我真正开始欣赏在世界各地各种不同环境和情况下都有人员的这种多样性。我认为它为所发生的事情增添了一种活力，这是我非常赞赏的。但我们最终拥有了许多涉及各种领域的全球专家。我们有许多在公司呆了很长时间的人。有些人，他们在公司呆了十年。
Then they say, oh, the grass is greener somewhere else. And they go off somewhere else for a few years. And then they come back, which is always satisfying. It's satisfying for management to see that happen, so to speak. Yeah, definitely. Because it means we're doing something right. But I think that the thing that we've ended up with, it's like people who are good at thinking are the people who tend to succeed because you know we have we're always trying to solve you know a lot of what we're doing is stuff that's never been
然后他们说，哦，外面的草更绿。然后他们去别的地方待几年。接着他们又回来了，这总是令人满意的。对于管理层来说，看到这一幕发生是令人满意的，可以这么说。是的，绝对的。因为这意味着我们做对了某些事情。但我认为我们最终得到的结果是，善于思考的人往往是那些容易成功的人，因为你知道我们有，我们总是在努力解决，你知道，我们的很多工作都是以前从未做过的事情
done before and you know my principle in building the company is very similar to my principle in building our language automate as much as possible and so you know for me you know you mentioned javascript programming you know there was a period of time when we had tons of javascript programmers automate as much as possible. For me, you mentioned JavaScript programming. There was a period of time when we had tons of JavaScript programmers. It's like, look, guys, what you're doing is, why don't we build something higher level that just automates a bunch of this stuff? So we did that. Then those folks moved on to doing other things. For us, they end up being able to work on higher-level things.
而且，你知道，我建立公司的原则与我建立语言的原则非常相似：尽可能实现自动化。所以，你知道，对我来说，你提到了 JavaScript 编程，你知道，曾有一段时间我们有大量的 JavaScript 程序员，尽可能实现自动化。对我来说，你提到了 JavaScript 编程。曾有一段时间我们有大量的 JavaScript 程序员。这就像，听着，伙计们，你们在做的事情是，为什么我们不构建一些更高层次的东西来自动完成这些事情呢？所以我们这样做了。然后那些人就去从事其他事情了。对我们来说，他们最终能够从事更高层次的事情。
For the company, that's how we get away with only having 800 people is by the fact that we've automated a huge amount of what goes on internal to the company. We're using both the principles and the actual technology that we've built. Like our testing system is, of course, all written in Wolfram language. One of the more exotic things that we're now doing is writing our ERP transaction processing system in Wolfram language because we just got fed up with some of these pseudo open source things, which actually are costing way too much money. And we said, these don't even work well. Let's just build our own. So that stuff is...
对于公司来说，这就是我们能够只维持 800 人的秘诀，因为我们已经将公司内部发生的大量事情实现了自动化。我们同时使用了我们构建的原则和实际技术。比如我们的测试系统，当然全部是用 Wolfram 语言编写的。我们现在正在做的比较奇特的事情之一是用 Wolfram 语言编写我们的 ERP 事务处理系统，因为我们对其中一些伪开源的东西实在是厌烦了，这些东西实际上花钱太多了。然后我们说，这些甚至都不能很好地工作。我们自己造一个吧。所以这些东西是……
Now, in terms of hiring, one of the things I might mention is we have the summer school every year. It's usually about 70 people from around the world. One of the things I might mention is we have the summer school every year. It's usually about 70 people from around the world. It's a great collection of people. It's become a favorite sort of pseudo-vacation for a bunch of our R&D folk. And, in fact, most of the instructors at the summer school are alumni of the summer school, which reveals the fact that the summer school is our single sort of… We recruit a lot of people from there. Cool. That makes sense.
现在，在招聘方面，我可以提的一件事是我们每年都有夏令营。通常来自世界各地的大约有 70 人。我可以提的一件事是我们每年都有夏令营。通常来自世界各地的大约有 70 人。这是一群很棒的人。它已经成为我们许多研发人员最喜欢的伪度假方式。事实上，夏令营的大多数讲师都是夏令营的校友，这表明夏令营是我们唯一的某种……我们从那里招募了很多人。酷。这讲得通。
It works really well because people come and they often have never thought about working for the company. They come and spend three weeks and they do a project and they get to know a bunch of people at the company and we get to see what they do they get to see what uh kind of you know our approach to doing things is and it's kind of uh you know it's uh it's it's very um uh works well but i think in terms of what are we what are we i mean we're we're always looking for you you know, very talented people. I would say that my approach to management tends to be, you know, we've got a lot of projects we want to do. We've got a certain pool of people that, you know, have lots of talents.
它运行得非常好，因为人们来这里时通常从未想过为这家公司工作。他们来这里度过三周，做一个项目，认识公司里的一群人，我们也能看到他们做什么，他们能看到我们做事的方法是什么样的，而且这有点，你知道，这，这，非常，嗯，运作得很好，但我认为就我们正在，我们在，我的意思是，我们一直在寻找你，你知道，非常有才华的人。我想说，我的管理方法往往是，你知道，我们有很多想做的项目。我们有一群具有多种才能的人。
And sort of the role of management is to solve the puzzle of how do you connect, you know, the talented people with the projects that you want to get done. And so we're more interested in kind of, you know, really talented people than we are in the specifics of, oh, we want to get a such and such kind of person right now. Yeah, that makes sense. And, you know, it's sort of strange because we're a company where, you know, we actually need things like history PhDs because we actually do stuff with curating all military conflicts and history type thing where it's useful to... We need people... Actually, another thing
管理层的角色就是解开如何将有才华的人与你想完成的项目联系起来这个谜题。所以我们对真正有才华的人更感兴趣，而不是纠结于诸如“我们现在就要找这种或那种人”的具体细节。是的，这说得通。而且，你知道，这有点奇怪，因为我们是一家，你知道，我们实际上需要像历史学博士这样的人，因为我们确实在做整理所有军事冲突和历史类型的事情，这很有用……我们需要人……其实还有一件事
interesting to mention in connection with orphan language is if you look at the people who are... We have a whole lot of people who have, I would say, subject area backgrounds. And many of whom were not, you know, quotes computer people particularly before. But they're very smart people. And they, you know, and it's turned out many of them have become really, really strong Wolfram language programmers, which is an interesting thing to watch. I mean, it's interesting to see that we see, you know, in an educational level, for example, you know, like in K through 12 education, it's like, well, okay,
有趣的是，关于奥芬语言（注：此处应为Wolfram语言的误听或翻译变体），如果你看看那些人……我们有相当多的人，我想说，他们有专业领域背景。其中许多人在那之前并不是，引号里的电脑专家。但他们是非常聪明的人。而且，你知道，事实证明，他们中的许多人已经成为了非常非常强大的 Wolfram 语言程序员，这是一个很有趣的观察。我的意思是，有趣的是，我们看到，在教育层面上，例如，在 K-12 教育中，就像，好吧，
which teachers are really going to understand this stuff? Is it going to be the math teacher? Is it going to be the computer science teacher who knows Java, for example? Or is it going to be the head of the English department who's just a smart person who decides that they're going to pick the stuff up? It turns out it's a diverse background of people, and that's the same thing we see in people who end up being really strong Wolfram language programmers. So I guess the point there is that it's a whole world of computational language and computational thinking is the most important thing. It's a bit of a disruption relative to the, you know, we're all going to learn to be the,
哪些老师会真正理解这些东西？会是数学老师吗？会是懂 Java 的计算机科学老师吗？还是英语系主任，一个决定要学习这些东西的聪明人？事实证明，人们有着不同的背景，我们在最终成为非常强大的 Wolfram 语言程序员的人身上也看到了这一点。所以我想这里的重点是，计算语言和计算思维的世界是最重要的。与那种“我们都要学会成为”的模式相比，这有点像是一种颠覆，
you know, the best, you know, churn out the maximum number of lines of code and make sure that, you know, the type checking works correctly type. Right. Yeah, that makes sense. You know, I think in, anyway, that's some. Yeah, that totally makes sense i think i think the the camp sounds awesome especially for um you know people are interested in uh as you said maybe they have a great background in history or particle physics or something like that and this is a great way to to um you know jump into computation and and programming and things like that. No, it's been, I mean, look, the one for grownups, that's the case. The one for high school kids, that's interesting because, you know,
你知道，最好的，你知道，大量产出最多行数的代码并确保类型检查能够正确运行的人。对。是的，这说得通。你知道，我认为不管怎样，这算是一些。是的，完全说得通，我认为，我认为这个夏令营听起来棒极了，特别是对于，你知道，对……感兴趣的人，正如你所说的，也许他们在历史、粒子物理学或类似领域有很好的背景，这是进入计算和编程等领域的绝佳途径。不，这真的是，我的意思是，看，面向成年人的夏令营就是这样。面向高中生的夏令营很有趣，因为，你知道，
it turns out that even at the fancy high schools, and we've tried very hard to get kids also not from the fancy high schools, but it turns out that many fewer people are learning any kind of real programming, any kind of anything computational in high school than you might think. I mean, I kind of assumed with all the noise that's made about, oh, everybody's, you know, doing... Everyone's STEM crazy. Right. You know, but it turns out a lot of these kids, and actually it's often, it's often the worst case is they did a c++ class and they found it boring and they learned a bunch of you know the most important thing to do is to i don't even know i put a semicolon every time or something yes yes yes right it's um uh
事实证明，即使在高档高中里——我们也曾非常努力地争取让不来自高档高中的孩子们也来参与——但事实证明，高中生学习任何真正的编程、任何计算相关知识的人数比你想象的要少得多。我的意思是，我曾以为，伴随着那些喧嚣的声音，哦，每个人都在，你知道，在做……每个人都对 STEM 疯狂。对。你知道，但事实证明，许多这样的孩子，而且实际上往往，往往最糟糕的情况是他们上了一个 C++ 课，觉得很无聊，然后学了一堆，你知道，最重要的事情是，我甚至不知道，每次都加一个分号之类的。是的，是的，对，这……
anyway well listen i should i should be off but yeah totally so yeah just to recap real quick so if you're a student you have access to Mathematica already you just you might have not known it so definitely check it out I mean it's totally free go through your university and start playing with it and see how many people there are in each country and do all these cool things if you aren't a student I believe correct me if I'm'm wrong, but you can still use it for free. Yeah. In fact, the web version, you can just go to the front of our website and it says immediate access and startup. Wolfram Programming Lab, which is Wolfram Programming Lab is the full Wolfram language, but it's kind of themed for kids.
不管怎样，听着，我得走了，但是，是的，完全同意。所以，简单回顾一下，如果你是一名学生，你已经可以使用 Mathematica，你可能只是之前不知道，所以一定要去看看。我的意思是，它是完全免费的，通过你的大学去开始使用它，看看每个国家有多少人，做所有这些酷炫的事情。如果你不是学生，如果我没记错的话请纠正我，你仍然可以免费使用它。是的。事实上，对于网页版，你只需访问我们网站的首页，上面写着“立即访问并开始”。Wolfram Programming Lab，即 Wolfram 编程实验室是完整的 Wolfram 语言，但它是面向儿童设计的。
So if you don't mind that it's themed for kids, you get it for free. Cool. Good to know. And if you want to integrate it with something you already have half written, you can use the Wolfram language, which is also free, right? For personal use. Yeah. I mean, the Wolfram engine,
所以如果你不介意它是面向儿童的，你可以免费获得它。太酷了，知道了。如果你想把它与你已经写了一半的东西结合起来，你可以使用 Wolfram 语言，这也是免费的，对吧？供个人使用。是的。我的意思是，Wolfram 引擎，
I mean, everything gets complicated at this point. But basically it's uh everything gets complicated at this point but but basically it's been um uh uh it's it's you know go to our website and you should find a path yeah getting getting go you can find good documentation there's there's there's there's definitely at least a web way to to sort of like a sandbox where you could play around yes exactly right and everything. Cool. Thank you so much for coming on the show. It's been amazing. It has gone a little long, but I'm sure the people
我的意思是，到了这一步一切都变得复杂了。但基本上是，嗯，这一切到了这一步都变得复杂了，但基本上是，嗯，嗯，嗯，你知道，去我们的网站，你应该能找到一条途径，嗯，获取，你可以找到好的文档，那里，那里，那里，绝对至少有一个网页端的方法，就像一个沙盒，你可以在里面玩耍。是的，完全正确，而且一切都是。太酷了。非常感谢你来参加节目。这太棒了。时间稍微有点长，但我确信大家
are going to be, they're not going to be upset about that. This is an absolutely fantastic interview and thanks for staying up late with us. Yeah, sounds great. It was fun. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Share Alike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work,
不会对此感到不高兴的。这是一次绝对精彩的采访，谢谢你陪我们熬夜。是的，听起来很棒。这很有趣。片头曲是 Binar Pilot 的 Axo。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 协议下发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，重新混合、改编作品，
but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但你必须署名归属帕特里克和我，并以相同方式分享。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。